BUT A QUICK ANNOUNCEMENT JUST SO
YOU KNOW WE ARE RULES ARE
COMMITTEE DON'T ALLOW US TO
START UNTIL WE HAVE A REPUBLICAN
MEMBER. AND AS YOU SEE IT I'M
LIKE THE ONLY MEMBER HERE RIGHT
NOW. SO WE'RE GONNA WAIT. WELL I
MEAN WITH HIS EX. I'M SORRY
MAKES MAKES. WE GOT TO MEMBERS
NOW THAT ARE THERE COMING OUT OF
THE WOODWORK SO- SO. LITERALLY
BUT THE THANK THANK YOU TO MIKE
TO DEMOCRATIC COLLEAGUES FOR
BEING HERE. WE CANNOT START
UNTIL WE HAVE A REPUBLICANS OF
ANYWAY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD
BEGINNER HEARING THIS THIS
AFTERNOON- BEFORE I BEGIN I'D
LIKE TO MAKE A STATEMENT OF
PROVIDING TESTIMONY AT THIS
HEARING OF YOU WANT TO TELL. US
THAT WE ARE GONNA TAKE ONE ITEM
OUT OF ORDER I'M GOING TO
PRESENT A BILL. FIRST REGULAR
THE CHAIR I GUESS OF- WE'LL BE
DOING THAT AND GOING BACK TO
OUR- OUR REGULAR AGENDA- SOMEONE
OKAY CORRECT WE'RE STILL TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT THE BUTTONS APPEAR
. ARSONIST ON AIRPLANES. SO
FIRST OF ALL WE SEEK TO PROTECT
THE RIGHTS OF ALL WHO
PARTICIPATE IN THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS SO THAT WE CAN HAVE AN
EFFECTIVE DELIBERATION ON THE
CRITICAL ISSUES FACING
CALIFORNIA IN ORDER TO
FACILITATE THE GOAL OF THIS
HEARING WE WILL NOT PERMIT
CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS DISTURBS
OR OTHERWISE IMPEDE THE ORDERLY
CONDUCT OF LEGISLATIVE
PROCEEDINGS WILL ACCEPT BEHAVIOR
THAT INCITES OR THREATENS
VIOLENCE EVEN VEILED THREATS. AS
WE PROCEED WITH THE WITNESSES
AND PUBLIC COMMENT WANT TO MAKE
SURE EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS THAT
THE ASSEMBLY HAS RULES TO ENSURE
THAT WE MAINTAIN ORDER AND RUN
AN EFFICIENT AND FAIR HEARING WE
APPLY THESE RULES ALL PEOPLE WHO
PARTICIPATE IN OUR HEARINGS ALL
ME WITNESSES WILL BE TESTIFYING
IN PERSON WE ALLOW TO ME
WITNESSES FOR A MAXIMUM OF THREE
MINUTES EACH. ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY CAN BE MADE IN PERSON
OR OVER THE PHONE AFTER THE MAIN
WITNESSES HAVE PROVIDED THEIR
TESTIMONY IT ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY WILL BE COMBINED AND
NOT GROUP BY POSITION ALL PUBLIC
COMMENT NEEDS TO FOCUS ON THE
BILL AT HAND COMMENTS ON OTHER
ISSUES AND THAT WILL BE RULED
OUT OF ORDER AND YOUR TIME WILL
EXPIRE IMMEDIATELY. PLEASE BE
AWARE THAT THESE VOTE THAT
VIOLATIONS OF THESE RULES MAY
SUBJECT YOU TO REMOVAL OR OTHER
ENFORCEMENT PROCESS WE
APPRECIATE YOUR COOPERATION AND
WE HOPE AUTHORS AND STAKEHOLDERS
ARE RESPECTFUL OF THE PROCESS-
THE COVERED PANDEMIC WE HAVE
LIMITED SPACE FOR THE PUBLIC TO
PARTICIPATE SO WE CAN ENSURE
EVERYONE MAINTAIN SIXTY TO
SOCIAL DISTANCE. I WOULD ASK THE
PUBLIC. NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. WHEN YOU COMPLETE
YOUR TESTIMONY MAY EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM OR RETURN YOUR SEAT
IF SPACE PERMITS. WE USE IN A
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE
THROUGH WHICH ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES CAN TESTIFY ON A BILL
AFTER THE MAIN WITNESS TESTIFIES
TESTIMONY. THE COMMON NUMBER FOR
THIS HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS ONE EIGHT FIVE. ZERO ONE ONE.
ZERO ZERO. YOU CAN FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY HEALTH
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND ON YOUR TV
SCREEN. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO WELL BEFORE
THE AUTHOR BEGINS PRESENTING
THAT BILL. THE OPERATOR ON THE
LINE WILL GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW TO BE PLACED IN THE
QUEUE. ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE MUTURI LIVESTREAM AND YOUR
SMART DEVICES IN ORDER TO REDUCE
THE SOUND DISTORTION. YOUR
REMAIN ALIVE LINE IT WILL NEED
pCALLED UPON BY THE MODERATOR TO
SPEAK. YOU'RE HAVING PROBLEMS
WITH THE MODERATE TELEPHONE
SERVICE CALL THE COMMITTEE AT
NINE ONE SIX. THREE ONE NINE.
TWO ZERO NINE SEVEN AND MY STAFF
WILL BE THERE TO HELP. ACCEPTING
WRITTEN TESTIMONY THROUGH THE
POSITION LETTER PORTAL WITH
INSTRUCTIONS ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. YOU CAN FIND THE EMAIL
FOR THE COMMITTEE THERE AS WELL.
THANK YOU FOR BEARING WITH US AS
WE IMPLEMENT METHODS TO CONTINUE
TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WE ALL
FACE. BILLS WILL BE HEARD IN THE
ORDER PRINTED IN THE DAILY FILE
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF THE FACT
THAT I'M GOING TO PRESENT THE
FIRST BILL TODAY- CONSENT ITEM.
WE DO HAVE PRO PROPOSED CONSENT
CALENDAR FOR TODAY. HEARING THAT
THOSE ARE THE ITEMS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ARE. PROPOSED
TO BE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN. AB TWO
ZERO SEVEN. TWO BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GABRIEL. ITEM NUMBER NINE
AB TWO ZERO THREE TWO. BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA. A
NUMBER ELEVEN AB TWO SIX FOUR
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEBER
GRAYSON. ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN AB
TWENTY TWO NINETY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAYES AND ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY ONE. OF TWENTY
SEVEN A BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO. WE'RE THANKFUL THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ASH KALRA WE
WILL REPLACE THE DEMOCRATIC
VACANCY FOR TODAY'S HEARING I
THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN MISTER
KALRA- WITH THAT- WE WILL GO
AHEAD AND- I WILL GO AHEAD
PRESENT. AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
AND I'LL ASK OUR OUR VICE CHAIR
OF MISS WALDRON TO- THE CONTROL
OF THE MEETING. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR.
BUT OKAY SO- ITEM TWENTY FIVE AB
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
CHAIR AND THANK YOU MEMBERS.
GREAT I'M PROUD TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY EXERCISING A
WORKERS RIGHT TO STRIKE SHOULD
NOT MEAN RISKING THEIR HEALTH
COVERAGE FOR THEMSELVES OR THEIR
FAMILIES. AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
ENSURES THAT IN THE RARE CASES
WHERE LABOR DISPUTES GO ON LONG
ENOUGH TO JEOPARDIZE THEIR
EMPLOYER FUNDED HEALTH COVERAGE
WRECKING THAT STRIKING WORKERS
WILL HAVE ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE NOT ONLY
FOR THEMSELVES BUT FOR THEIR
FAMILY MEMBERS. ALTHOUGH
AFFORDABLE COVERAGE THROUGH
COVERED CALIFORNIA IS CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE TO INDIVIDUAL WORKERS
WHO LOSE BENEFITS DUE TO A LABOR
DISPUTE BEING IS FOR FAMILY
COVERAGE CAN COST AS MUCH AS
THIRTY OR 40% OF THE FAMILY'S
INCOME. IN FACT JUST TODAY THE
VICE ADMINISTRATION ANNOUNCED IT
IS DIRECTING THE U. S. TREASURY
TO INTRODUCE REGULATION TO FIX
THIS FAMILY GLITCH. ADDITION TO
COST CONCERNS WORKERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES MUST WAIT UNTIL THE
FIRST OF THE NEXT MONTH TO BE
COVERED THROUGH COVER CALIFORNIA
THIS MEANS THERE WILL BE A GAP
IN COVERAGE LEAVING FAMILIES
WITHOUT HEALTH INSURANCE FOR
WEEKS. THIS BILL IS MODELED
AFTER WHAT THE AMERICAN RESCUE
PLAN IS DONE FOR THOSE ON
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE DURING
THE COPA NINETEEN PANDEMIC IT
PROVIDES PREMIUM SUBSIDIES AND
COST SHARING ASSISTANCE AS IF
THE WORKERS INCOME WAS JUST OVER
THE MEDICARE ELIGIBILITY LEVEL.
INCLUDING ZERO PREMIUMS AND
DEDUCTIBLES AND FIVE DOLLAR
COPAYS AND ELIMINATES THE ANY
WAITING PERIOD ASSOCIATE WAS
SIGNING UP FOR COVER CALIFORNIA.
YOU'RE A TESTIFIED SUPPORT R. B.
K. BK WHITE WITH USW LOCAL FIVE.
AND LISA LNS PRESIDENT OF UNITE
HERE LOCAL TWENTY FIFTY. I FELT
COMPELLED ON BEHALF OF TEACHERS
AND UNITE HERE TO THE CO
SPONSORS PKA IS COMING FROM A
STRIKE AND IS SLIGHTLY DELAYED
AS RESULT BUT WE'LL START WITH
YOU LISA AND HE'LL- JOIN US AS
SOON AS HE CAN'T. BATES GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE- MY NAME'S
YOU LISA AND I'M THE PRESIDENT
OF UNITE HERE LOCAL TWENTY EIGHT
FIFTY WHERE THE HOSPITALITY
WORKER UNION. IN THE EAST BAY IN
NORTH BAY- IN IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
I LED A STRIKE OF TWO HUNDRED
WORKERS- AT THE OAKLAND MARRIOTT
CITY CENTER. OUR SLOGAN WAS ONE
JOB SHOULD BE ENOUGH. THESE
HOTEL WORKERS JOIN THOUSANDS OF
OTHER WORKERS AT TWENTY THREE
DIFFERENT MARRIOTT'S- HOTELS IN
SAN FRANCISCO SAN DIEGO SAN JOSE
BOSTON DETROIT. MALLEY AND
HONOLULU. THE BIGGEST AND
RICHEST HOTEL COMPANIES IN THE
WORLD ULTIMATELY AGREED TO THE
WORKERS DEMANDS FOR HIGHER
WAGES. STRONGER HEALTHCARE
BETTER WORKLOAD AND IMPROVE
THEIR JOB SECURITY. BUT ONLY
AFTER THAT- WORKERS HAD TO
STRIKE- IN OAKLAND WE WERE ON
STRIKE FOR THIRTY DAYS- BECAUSE
OF THE WAY THAT OUR HEALTH CARE
IS STRUCTURED NO ONE LOS
HEALTHCARE. AS A RESULT OF THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN MERIAH STRIKE.
BUT IF THEY WOULD HAVE HAD. THAT
THAT LOSS WOULD HAVE BEEN
DEVASTATED FOR WORKERS AND ALSO
THEIR FAMILIES. WORKERS WOULD
HAVE BEEN FORCED TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN HEALTHCARE. IN FOOD OR
RENT A MAJOR HEALTH EVENT COULD
HAVE RESULTED IN WORKERS GOING
INTO THAT. OUR MEMBERS ARE LOW
WAGE WORKERS LACK OF COVERAGE IS
THE RESULT OF A STRIKE COULD BE
DEVASTATING. NO WORKER WHO GOES
ON STRIKE SHOULD HAVE TO HAVE
THE- HEALTH INSURANCE WEAPONIZE
AGAINST THEM. BY THEIR EMPLOYER
THAT'S WHY THIS BILL IS
NECESSARY WE'RE ASKING THE
COMMITTEE TO APPROVE APPROVE A.
B. TWENTY FIVE THIRTY THANK YOU
. THAT COMPEL HERE I'D HAVE TO
TEAMSTERS AND UNITED HEROES CO
SPONSORS AND HEALTH ACCESS IS
SUPPORTER WILL RESERVE OUR TIME
FOR OUR LIKING WITNESS WHO WILL
COME AFTER ME CHOOSE. THANK YOU-
WE CAN MOVE TO OPPOSITION-
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. OKAY I
DON'T SEE ANYONE- ALLOW ANY
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION PLEASE
COME FORWARD. AND WE HAVE FOLKS
IN THE WHOLE MAP. SO PARDON. WE
BROUGHT A FEW FRIENDS. OKAY WE
JUST NAY NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL YES MY NAME
IS HECTOR ESPERICUETA UNDER
SECRETARY THREE- FOR THE- TO
WORK SERVICE OUR WORKERS IN
MARIN COUNTY OUR LOCAL FORTY
THREE AND I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
A NUMBER OF BLACK GUYS MAKE. SO
IT IS A LOCAL DIGESTING WHAT THE
- IT BROKEN INTO DOKLAM IT.
ANALYSTS ASTONISHING UP WE LIKE
YEAH. AT THE LOOK AT THE PERSON. HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS IDA GONZALEZ I WORK AT THE
OAKLAND INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT
I'M HERE WITH YOUR LOCAL UNITE
TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY AND I'M HERE
TO SUPPORT. HI MY NAME'S VICKI
SOLD BY WORK AT THE HYATT
REGENCY AMANO RAIN I'M
SUPPORTING FORTY THREE. UNITE.
HI MY NAME IS COMMITTEE KEEM I'M
HERE BECAUSE I'M A HOTEL WORKER
FOR THE SOME BRIDGES FOR SIXTEEN
YEARS. AND ARMONK WE UNITE HERE-
YOU KNOW MEMBER FOR TWENTY FIVE
YEARS I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THIS
HEALTHCARE LOW BECAUSE WE NEED.
HIGH MY NAME IS LAWCENTER I'M
MISSING I'M FROM MY LOCAL TO
LOOK AT ST REGIS SAN FRANCISCO-
I'M A LOCAL TO MEMBER FOR TEN
YEARS I SUPPORT. MY NAME IS
JESSE JOHNSON- LOCAL TO MEMBER
FROM SFO- INTERNATIONAL AND I'M
HERE IN SUPPORT. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS YOUR HIGHNESS AT
MACOMB I AM LOCAL TO I WORKS AT
WESTIN ST FRANCIS I'M A MEMBER
OVER TWENTY YEARS LOCAL TO I
SUPPORT. HI MY NAME IS BILL I
WORK LOCAL SCHOOL. I WOULD BE
SAN FRANCISCO I'M A BETTER LOOK
UP TO I'M SUPPORT THANK YOU. HI
WELFARE UNIT- HYATT CENTRIC
SACRAMENTO IS FRONT DESK- UNITE
HERE LOCAL FORTY NINE SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME'S KATIE MELBOURNE
THUNDER VALLEY CASINO LOCAL
FORTY NINE I SUPPORT. IN A THAT
WILL GUEST ON THE RELIC ASCENA
LOOK FORTY NINE I SUPPORT.
FRANCISCO GARCIA LOCAL FORTY
NINE GOLDEN ONE CENTER SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS JOSE LONGER HIRE
SOMEONE'S HIS COAT RICARDO I
SUPPORT. MY NAME IS MARIE SO
PARAMOUNT FOR MOTEL LOOK GOOD TO. HI MY NAME IS I WAS RELEASED I
WORKING OTHER HIGHER SAN
FRANCISCO FROM LOCAL STILL I
SUPPORT. MY NAME IS LITERAL
REYES. I WILL IN THE ENTIRE SAN
FRANCISCO NINE LOCAL TOOL I
SUPPORT. HI I'M TELL PERRY ART
FROM LOCAL FORTY NINE I WORK AT
CACHE CREEK CASINO RESORT IN
BROOKS CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT. HI THERE MAKAYLA VONGOLA WORK
AT SACRAMENTO INTERNATIONAL
AIRPORT I'M A CHEF AND- UNITE
HERE. A SUPPORT. HI SEAN PRASAD
FROM- THEY AFFECT MANAGEMENT
INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT HAVE BEEN
THERE TEN YEARS AND I SUPPORT
THIS. HI MY NAME IS SURAJ ONE
CAR I AM WORKING SACRAMENTO
INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT. AND I
WORK BE IS EIGHTEEN YEAR. AS A
COOK SO I. UNITE LOCAL FORTY
NINE SPORT THANK YOU. HI MY NAME
HI MY NAME IS STEPHANIE DUNN I
WORK AT THE HOLIDAY INN DOWNTOWN
PLAZA AND I'VE BEEN WORKING
THERE FOR SIXTEEN YEARS I'M A
SERVER AND I SUPPORT LOCAL FORTY
NINE THANK YOU. MY NAMEIS OUT
QUICKER TO WORK WITH UNITE HERE
LOCAL NINETEEN IN SAN JOSE AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. OUR SEMINARS
FOOD I WORKED AT FACEBOOK MENLO
PARK AS A LINE COOK. A LOCAL
NINETEEN AND I SUPPORT. MARIO
YOU DURING A UNITE HERE
INTERNATIONAL UNION SUPPORT.
MIKE CASEY UNITE HERE AND THE
CENSUS CALL LABOR COUNCIL
SUPPORT. HI THAT'S NOT ASK YOU
THAT'S YEAH YOU STATE COUNCIL
SUPPORT. HI JULIE NELSON WITH
THE NATIONAL UNION OF HEALTH
CARE WORKERS SUPPORT. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHOULD INVESTMENT ON
BEHALF OF THE TEAMSTERS PROUD CO
SPONSOR THIS BILL ALSO THE
AMALGAMATED TRANSIT UNION THE
MACHINISTS UNION UTILITY WORKERS
UNION ALL SUPPORT. TIM MADDEN
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS IN SUPPORT.
OKAY IS THAT EVERYONE IN THE
ROOM THAT WANTS TO. MAKE A
COMMENT. THE MISTER LEWIS SO.
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU MADAM VICE
CHAIR MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
NICHOLS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
PLANS I THINK IT WAS THE IT'S
THIRTY TO ONE I LIKE MY ODDS- NO
BUT I THINK YOU WE WE'VE TAKEN A
RESPECTFUL OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION ON THE BILL AND I'D-
JUST LIKE A FEW MONTHS TO
EXPLAIN OUR POSITION. WE
CERTAINLY DON'T HAVE ANY ISSUE
WITH THE INTENT OF THE BILL- I
THINK THERE ARE CERTAIN POLICY
CONSIDERATIONS AND OPERATIONAL
THINGS THAT NEED TO BE IRONED
OUT BEFORE SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
CAN BE PUT INTO A FACT AND-
WE'VE HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE AND- THE
SPONSORS. ABOUT SOME OF THOSE
ISSUES AND WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT
YOU KNOW MOVING FOR WE CAN WORK
SOME OF THOSE OUT BUT- HE NEEDS
TO BE POINTED OUT YOU KNOW-
EMPLOYEES THAT DO YOU LOSE THEIR
COVERAGE- IN THESE CIRCUMSTANCES
ALREADY QUALIFY FOR SPECIAL
ENROLLMENT PERIOD AND WITH THIS
BILL TRIES TO DO. IS DESIGN A
DIFFERENT BENEFIT PACKAGE FOR
THOSE EMPLOYEES- AS OPPOSED TO-
YOU KNOW EMPLOYEES IN OTHER
CIRCUMSTANCES IN INDIVIDUALS IN
OTHER CIRCUMSTANCES AND SO.
THAT'S ONE ISSUE BUT YOU KNOW IN
TERMS OF LIKE THE- NUTS AND
BOLTS OF IT ON. YOU KNOW THERE
ARE OPERATIONAL AND TIMING
ISSUES LIKE FOR INSTANCE OUR
MEMBERS- ARE CURRENTLY FILING
THEIR BENEFIT DESIGNSIN RATE
FILINGS WITH STATE REGULATORS AS
WE SPEAK. IN FACT APRIL FIRST AS
WAS ONE OF THE DEADLINE TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTH
CARE. OF COURSE LEGISLATIVE
CALENDARS WRITING ON A DIFFERENT
RAIL IN SO- YOU KNOW IF THIS
BILLS ENACTED LATER IN THE YEAR-
YOU KNOW THAT PUTS OUR MEMBERS
IN A BIND SO YOU KNOW WE DISCUSS
THAT WITH SPONSORS AS WELL- WE
DO BELIEVE THERE. THERE ARE SOME
INCONSISTENCIES WITH THE ACA IN
TERMS OF THE SOLUTION IN THIS
BILL TO FIX THE QUOTE UNQUOTE
FAMILY GLITCH- YOU KNOW FEDERAL
SUBSIDIES CAN ONLY BE USED IN
CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES AND NOT
OTHERS. SO I THINK THIS IS ONE
WHERE STATE FUNDING MIGHT BE
REQUIRED AND THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE'D- LIKE TO TALK TO THE-
YOU KNOW THIS. THIS BILL ABOUT
AS WELL- SO THOSE ARE KIND OF
OUR ISSUES AND AGAIN YOU KNOW-
THIS SOMETHING THAT. WE YOU KNOW
WE LIKE TO HAVE FOR THE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHOR-
AND THE SPONSORS ABOUT BUT YOU
KNOW NO NO QUARREL WITH THE
INTENT. AND LOOK FOR THE
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS MOVING
FORWARD THANKS. THANK YOU. OKAY
WE ARE WITNESSES ON THE PHONE.
MODERATOR PLEASE ALLOW WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION TO
STATE THEIR NAME ORGANIZATION
AND POSITION ONLY. OUR FIRST.
COMMENT FROM NINE THIRTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE THIRTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN FOR OPPOSITION
OR SUPPORT. COPY TO ME TO COPY
MATED. WE'LL GO TO LINE TWENTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN FOR
COMMENT. A GOOD AFTERNOON
REBECCA GONZALEZ WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. CONNECT COMMENT FROM
NINE ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. TO
LOOK AT THE L. L. WITH ACCENTS
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE AND WE'RE
IN SUPPORT OF TWENTY BY THIRTY
THANK YOU. OUR NEXT COMMON IS
FROM LINE SIXTY SEVEN YES GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
NUMBERS JACQUI GREAT WELL WITH
UFCW WESTERN STATE COUNCIL A
PROUD COACH BOND- AND THINK THE
CHAIRMAN FOR OFFERING THE BILL
THANK YOU. OUR NEXT QUESTION IS
FROM NINE SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. VANDERBUR ERROL ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. OUR NEXT COMMON IS HAVE LINE
SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS THERE A
FLOCK ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY FEDERATION OF
LABOR WHICH IS A PROUD CO
SPONSOR AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA I GOT TO COUNCIL
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. OUR NECKS
COMMENT IS FROM THE LINE. EIGHTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. COMMITTEE
MEMBERS LOOK UP THE WITH
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE
BOARD SMART TRANSPORTATION
DIVISION IN SUPPORT. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS YOUR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. THANK
YOU WE CAN BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE FOR MEMBER COMMENTS WE
DON'T HAVE A QUORUM YET BUT- ANY
QUESTIONS. SEEING NONE- MISTER
CHAIR WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
YES WELL THANK YOU FIRST OF ALL-
I DON'T THINK WORKERS SHOULD BE
PENALIZED FOR THEIR EXERCISING
THEIR RIGHT TO STRIKE AND THAT'S
REALLY WHAT THIS BILL IS ALL
ABOUT- AND- IT'S AN HONOR TO BE
ABLE TO PRESENT THIS BILL AND I
WANT TO THANK THE WITNESSES WHO
CAME MANY OF THEM LONG DISTANCES
HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. AND I SINCERELY HOPE THAT
WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM I CAN HAVE
A MOTION THAT WE WILL- WILL BE
ABLE TO PASS THIS BILL FOR THE
NEXT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU. MADAM CHAIR ON. ANOTHER
SUPPORTER OUR SECOND WITNESS
OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
INDULGENCE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MY NAME IS B. K. WHY I'M AN
OPERATOR FROM THE CHEVRON
REFINERY IN RICHMOND I'M A PROUD
MEMBER OF THE U. S. W. FIVE.
WITH MEMBERS ARE ON STRIKE AT
THIS TIME. WE WILL STRIKE TRY TO
GET A FAIR CONTRACT FOR- OUR
MEMBERSHIP. I WOULD BE WORKING
HARD. FOR SEVENTY DAYS TO TRY TO
OBTAIN THIS CONTRACT. WITH NO
SUCCESS. RECENTLY ABOUT TWO DAYS
AGO WE LOST OUR HEALTHCARE. NEWS
YOU KNOW HEALTHCARE IS A
LIFELINE FOR WORKING PEOPLE. NO
WORKER SHOULD BE SHOULD LOSE
THEIR HEALTHCARE OUR HEALTH
COVERAGE FOR THE FAMILY AS A
RESULT OF CORPORATIONS WEAPONIZE
IT AGAINST THOSE OF US WHO ARE
JUST TRYING TO GET A FAIR
CONTRACT. IN THE LAST TWO YEARS
AGO IT. WE'VE SEEN HOW IMPORTANT
HEALTH CARE IS. AND THIS TIME
NOT ONLY MY MEMBERS CAN AFFORD
TO LOSE IT. OF THE LEGISLATOR IN
THE GOVERNMENT HAVE PROVIDED
CRITICAL PROTECTION. FOR PUBLIC
SECTOR WORKERS THIS LAST YEAR BY
INSURANCE STRIKING THE LOCKED
OUT WORKERS CONTINUE TO HAVE
ACCESS TO LIFE SAVING HEALTHCARE
. IT'S TIME TO FINISH THE JOB
AND EXTEND THE PROTECTIONS. THE
WORKERS IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR.
RIGHT NOW WORKERS ARE FED UP AND
MORE FRUSTRATED NEVER. WE'VE
SEEN THE COMPANIES WILL NOT
PROTECT US. SOMETIMES AS IN THE
CASE OF MY UNION RIGHT NOW
RICHMAN. WORKERS MUST STRIKE. IN
A SUCH A PRO WORKER STATUS
CALIFORNIA WE WANT TO KNOW THAT
THE STATE HAS OUR BACK. WE
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO VOTE YES ON
AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY. TO
PROTECT THE FAMILIES AND BILL
CALIFORNIA COMMITMENT TO HEALTH
CARE COVERAGE OVERALL. WE
BELIEVE WITHOUT PROTECTION ON
HEALTHCARE. THAT OUR MEMBERS MAY
NOT STAND UP LIKE THEY SHOULD
AND FIGHT FOR THE RIGHTS THAT
THEY DESERVE. OUR FOR THEIR
PIECE OF AMERICAN PIE. WE
BELIEVE THAT IS ONE MORE THING
THAT COULD DETER THEM FROM
STANDING UP WHEN THEY HAVE TO
CHOOSE BETWEEN. THE HEALTH.
THEIR LIVELIHOOD. AND THEIR
WORKING CONDITIONS IF WE CAN
REMOVE THAT ONE SECTION OUT OF
IT MAYBE THEY'RE MORE LIKELY TO
STAND UP AND FIGHT FOR
THEMSELVES. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU. AND THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE WILL GO BACK TO OUR REGULAR
FILE ORDER. A ROUGH. NEXT
PRESENTER IS DR ARAMBULA.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY DOCTOR
AMBULANCE. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT ON AB
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY I FIRST WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR HARD WORK ON THE BILL AND
I AM PLEASED TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. AB
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY ENSURES THAT
PATIENTS WHO ARE DENIED COVERAGE
OF CRITICAL MEDICATIONS. CAN
HELP THEIR APPEALS REVIEWED BY A
PHYSICIAN WHO UNDERSTANDS THEIR
CONDITION. ADDITIONALLY AB
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY ALSO ADDS DATA
COLLECTION MEASURES TO
UNDERSTAND THE EXTENT OF THE USE
OF STEP THERAPY AND HEALTH CARE
. IN JANUARY AB THREE FORTY
SEVEN ESTABLISHED A PROCESS
WHERE PHYSICIANS COULD REQUEST
INSURANCE COMPANIES COVER THE
MOST EFFECTIVE MEDICINE FOR
THEIR PATIENTS. THESE REQUESTS
ARE TYPICALLY REVIEWED BY A
HEALTH PROFESSIONAL WITH OUT THE
SAME QUALIFICATIONS AS THE
PATIENT'S PHYSICIAN. THIS MEANS
THAT THOSE WHO ARE MAKING THE
INITIAL NOT
FULLY GRASP THE- PHYSICIAN'S
MEDICAL ARGUMENTS AND CURRENTLY
IF THE INITIAL REQUEST IS DENIED
THE PHYSICIANS APPEAL OF THE
DENIAL CAN SIMILARLY BE REVIEWED
BY AN INDIVIDUAL WITHOUT%
SUFFICIENT KNOWLEDGE OF THE
MEDICAL CONDITION. THIS PROCESS
IS HUGELY WAITED AGAINST
PATIENTS AND CAN LEAD TO
PROLONGED PAIN AND SUFFERING.
FOR REFERENCE I'M COLLEGES ARE
REQUIRED TO HAVE MULTIPLE YEARS
OF ADDITIONAL TRAINING AND
SPECIALIZATION TO DIAGNOSE AND
PRESCRIBE DRUGS TO TREAT CANCER
. AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY GIVES THESE
PATIENTS AND SO MANY OTHERS WITH
COMPLICATED ILLNESSES A FAIR
REVIEW OF THEIR APPEALS. THIS
BILL REQUIRES A PHYSICIAN OF THE
SAME OR SIMILAR SPECIALTY TO
REVIEW THEIR CASE AND THE
MEDICAL ARGUMENTS WHICH ARE
BEING MADE. I'M JOINED HERE
TODAY BY STEVEN SCHULTZ FROM THE
ARTHRITIS FOUNDATION AND TIM
MADDEN REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA RHEUMATOLOGY ALLIANCE
. IT'S GREAT WHEN YOU'RE READY.
I THANK YOU CHAIR THANK YOU
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY HEALTH
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS TO CONTROL
SOME DIRECTOR STATE LEGISLATIVE
AFFAIRS FOR THE ARTHRITIS
FOUNDATION AND CO SPONSOR OF AB
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY I SEE HERE-
PROUD TO REPRESENT THE FIVE
POINT SEVEN. MILLION PEOPLE WITH
ARTHRITIS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I WANTED THEY COULD
START DURING THE WAR A FURTHER
TRYING TO STREAMLINE IT AND ADD
TRANSPARENCY TO THE UTILIZATION
MANAGEMENT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF OF PATIENTS
AND HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS AFTER
THE RECENT NACHMAN OF AB THREE
FOUR SEVEN- WHICH HAD THE
SUPPORT OF THIS COMMITTEE AND
ITS MEMBERS. I'M GONNA FOCUS ON
THE PIECE OF AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
WHICH WOULD ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENTS LIKE THE DEPARTMENT
HEALTH CARE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE TO REALLY GATHER
INFORMATION ON HOW UTILIZATION
MANAGEMENT PROTOCOLS SUCH STEP
THERAPY AND PRIOR AUTHORIZATION
ARE BEING. USED AS YOU MAY
RECALL PRIVATIZATIONS USUALLY
JUST THE STEP THAT. HELPING TO
PUT IN PLACE TO REALLY CHECK IF
SOMETHING'S MEDICALLY NECESSARY-
AND STEP THERAPY IS THE PROCESS
THAT. HEALTH PLANS USE THAT.
REQUIRE A PATIENT TO TRY A
MEDICATION BEFORE I TRY AND FAIL
A MEDICATION FOR- STEPPING ARE
FEELING THEIR WAY- TO ANOTHER
MEDICATION OFTEN TIMES THE ONE
THAT'S PRESCRIBED BY. THEIR
HEALTHCARE PROVIDER- THIS LEVEL
OF TRANSPARENCY WILL PAINT A
BETTER PICTURE OF HOW
UTILIZATION MANAGEMENT
PROTOCOLS. ARGUES SUCH AS HOW
OFTEN STEP THERAPY AND PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION REQUEST OR DENIED
AND FOR WHAT REASONS ARE BEING
DENIED- AS A LEGISLATURE AND
DEPARTMENTS THAT. ARE OFTEN
CONSIDERING LEGISLATION AROUND
THIS TOPIC- IN REGULATING- THIS
TOPIC. I WOULD ASSUME THAT THIS
WOULD BE GREAT INFORMATION TO BE
ABLE TO HELP- STAKEHOLDERS
LEGISLATORS REGULATORS- BE ABLE
TO DO THEIR JOB IN. FUTURE
LEGISLATION AROUND THIS TOPIC A
SIMILAR TRANSPARENCY PIECE- OF.
COMMITTEE LAST YEAR- AND WE HOPE
THAT THE SLIGHT CHANGE THAT WAS
MADE. IN THE LANGUAGE TO REALLY.
GO FROM REQUIRING THAT THE
DEPARTMENT COMPILED THIS
INFORMATION AND- COMPLETE REPORT
TO SOMETHING WHERE IT'S MORE
OPTION OR TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX-
FOR THE- DEPARTMENTS TO USE. IS
MORE PALATABLE FOR BOTH PARTIES
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU. I
THINK CHAIR MEMBERS DEMAND
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
RHEUMATOLOGY ALLIANCE AND WE ARE
ALSO A CO SPONSOR OF AB EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY. I'M I'M GOING TO FOCUS
ON THE PORTION OF THE BILL TO
DEAL WITH HAVING A CLINICAL PEER
REVIEW APPEALS. I DON'T THINK
IT'S READ STATED ANY BETTER THAN
WHAT DOCTOR EMILY DID. FOR
RHEUMATOLOGISTS IS NOT UNCOMMON
WHEN WE'RE APPEALING A PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION OR STEP THERAPY
EXCEPTION REQUEST. THEY HAD THE
REVIEWING PHYSICIAN AT THE
PAYER. BE A CARDIOLOGISTS WORD
BE TRAINED IN- A STATURE EXCERPT
OF GYNECOLOGY. SO THEY DON'T
HAVE THE EXPERIENCE RHEUMATOLOGY
SO IT MAKES THAT CONVERSATION IN
TERMS OF WHY WE FEEL THAT THIS
APPEAL SHOULD BE GRANTED THAT.
MUCH MORE DIFFICULT WE FEEL THIS
IS AN FOR PROVISION THEY'LL HELP
PAGE. ENSURE THEY GET THE- THEY
NEED IN A MORE TIMELY. FOR THOSE
REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. PLEASE
COME FORWARD AND. YOU'RE GONNA
COME TO THE TABLE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN OF
THE COMMITTEE JEFF HAMPTON WITH
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
PLANS A REGRETTABLY WE ARE HERE
IN OPPOSITION TO AB EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY WHICH REQUIRE HEALTH
PLANS TO REDESIGN THEIR
UTILIZATION MANAGEMENT PROCESSES
REQUIRE THAT THE NILES OF THE
STEP THERAPY CEPTION REQUEST FOR
CERTAIN PRESCRIPTION DRUGS
REVIEWED BY CLINICAL PIER.
WITHIN THE SAME SPECIALTY
DESPITE THE PRESENCE OF EXISTING
LAWS AND REGULATIONS ADDRESSING
THE ISSUE WE WOULD LIKE TO THINK
THE AUTHOR- THE SPONSORS AND
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THE
THOUGHTFUL CONVERSATIONS THAT
WE'VE HAD TO DATE ON THIS BILL.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT NOTE THAT
TO MEDICAL MANAGEMENT PRACTICES
SUCH AS PRIOR AUTHORIZATION AND
STEP THERAPY. A CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT TOOLS USED BY HEALTH
PLANS TO ENSURE THAT PATIENTS
RECEIVE THE HIGHEST QUALITY
MEDICAL CARE. WHILE ALSO
ENSURING PATIENT SAFETY AND
CONTROLLING HEALTHCARE COSTS.
SPECIFICALLY STEP THERAPY
PROTOCOLS ENSURE PATIENT SAFETY.
BY ENCOURAGING PROVIDERS AND
PATIENTS UNDERTAKEN MORE
EVIDENCE BASED. MEASURE APPROACH
TO TREATMENT THAT IS TAILORED TO
THE INDIVIDUAL. BY GAUGING A
PATIENT'S RESPONSE TO LESS
HARMFUL MEDICATIONS BEFORE
GRADUATING. MORE POTENT HIGH
RISK DRUGS. STEP THERAPY ALSO
INSURERS THE HEALTH PLANS ARE
GOOD STEWARDS OF PREMIUM DOLLARS
PAID BY THE EMPLOYER IN THE
ENROLLEES BY REQUIRING DRUG
THERAPY FOR A MEDICAL CONDITION-
TO BEGIN WITH THE SAFEST AND
MOST COST EFFECTIVE DRUG BEFORE
PROGRESSING TO THE OTHER MORE
COSTLY THERAPIES- CURRENTLY
EXISTING LAW ALLOWS ENROLLEES
AND PROVIDERS TO REQUEST AN
EXCEPTION TO HELP PLAN STEP- P.
PROTOCOLS FOR PRESCRIPTION DRUG.
HEALTH PLANS MUST RESPOND TO
THIS WITHIN TWENTY FOUR HOURS OR
SEVENTY TWO HOURS DEPENDING ON
THE CIRCUMSTANCE. UNFORTUNATELY
WE BELIEVE AS WRITTEN THE AB
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY REMIND THESE
EXISTING PROCESSES BY CREATING
NEW ONEROUS CLINICAL REVIEW
PROCESS FOR SPECIFIED DRUGS
DESPITE EXISTING LAWS AND
REGULATIONS THAT ENSURE STRONG
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS IN THE
DELIVERY OF QUALITY HEALTHCARE.
ADDITIONALLY WE ARE CONCERNED
THAT THE BILL WOULD CREATE A
ADMINISTRATIVELY CUMBERSOME THE
POTENTIALLY COSTLY REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS ON HEALTH PLANS.
DESPITE EXISTING CHALLENGES ON
CURRENT DATA COLLECTION EFFORTS.
I WE DO UNDERSTAND THAT THAT THE
COMMITTEE- AMENDMENTS- ARE OUT
AND POTENTIALLY MAY DEAL WITH
THE KIND OF CLINICAL PEER REVIEW
PROCESS. WE'VE NOT HAD A CHANCE
TO SEE THE LANGUAGE THAT
SPECIFICALLY- BUT WE DO LOOK
FORWARD TO REVIEWING ANALYZING
THE AMENDMENTS TO ASSESS THE
POTENTIAL IMPACTS OUR MEMBER
HEALTH PLANS- BUT HOWEVER-
SPEAKING TO THAT THE BILL PRINTS
OUT WE ARE OPPOSED AB EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY. AND THE FOR TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHORITIES MEASURE.
THANK YOU. SEARCH OUR MEMBERS
SEVENTY WALKEN'S ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
LIFE AND HEALTH INSURANCE
COMPANIES IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME- ACCO MUST MY COLLEAGUES
COMMENTS WE ARE CONCERNED- ABOUT
THE REPORTING REQUIREMENT BE
REMISS IF I DIDN'T MENTION THE
ONEROUS AND COSTLY REQUIREMENT
IN ADDITION TO NO TIME FRAMES ON
THE REPORTING REQUIREMENTS SO
WHILE IT IS LIMITED TO THE
DEPARTMENT REQUESTING THE
INFORMATION THERE'S NO ACTUAL
TIME LIMIT FOR WHICH WE WOULD
HAVE TO HOUSE STORE IN COAL THAT
POTENTIAL INFORMATION. TO THE
DEGREE- WE DO APPRECIATE ALL THE
OPEN DIALOGUE AND CONVERSATION
WE'VE HAD WITH THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSORS OFFICE- UNFORTUNATELY
TODAY WE ARE STILL OPPOSED TO
THE BILL AND PRINT THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
THE ROOM JUST YOUR NAME POSITION
ORGANIZATION PLEASE- JOHN LINGER
ON BEHALF AMERICA'S HEALTH
INSURANCE PLANS APOLOGIES FORGET
OUR LETTER IN LATE BUT WE DO
SHARE THE SAME CONCERNS. THANK
YOU. RIGHT SPEND SOME HALF THE
CROHN'S AND COLITIS FOUNDATION
WE ALSO CO SPONSORED A MEASURE
AND SPORT THANK YOU. MISTER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE BRAND
IN MARCH WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. HELLO TARA
GAMBLE EASTMAN WITH THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR CHRIS ROSE ON BEHALF OF
BIOGEN IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE. YOU KNOW
WHEN WE GO TO THE FRONT LINES
MISREPRESENT THE LINES FOR
WITNESSES EITHER IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION JUST YOUR NAME
POSITION AND ORGANIZATION IF YOU
REPRESENT ONE. OKAY OUR FIRST
QUESTION OR COMMENT IS FROM LINE
NUMBER EIGHTY NINE. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ALEX CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CRIME CARE
COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. OUR NEXT COMMENTED
FROM LINE NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI JENNIFER
SNIDERMAN CAPTAIN CALIFORNIA
LIFE SCIENCES IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. OUR NEXT COMMON IN SOME
LINE NUMBER THIRTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI I VERY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY
BE IT A HOBBY SINCE HE AND WE
ARE SUPPOSED THE MEASURE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANKS CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT CALL IS LINE
NUMBER. ONE TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
AND CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SEARCHING A BIRD ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
I WILL BE GIVEN A CHANCE TO BUY.
PREVIOUSLY SO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. OUR
NEXT COMMENT IS FROM NINE NUMBER
SIXTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU PRESTON YOUNG FR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
CURRENTLY OPPOSE MUCH AMENDED TO
THE BILL'S IT APPEARS IN PRINT
TODAY THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. BUT WHAT YOU CAN
IF YOU ABOUT. OPPOSITION OR OR
PAPER A PRESS ONE THEN ZERO YOU
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. OUR NEXT
COMMENT IS FROM NINE. ONE
TWELVE. PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME'S ON GAIL AND I'M A
CONSULTANT WITH THE HOTEL
WORKERS UNION AND I'M IN FAVOR
OF THIS BILL. OKAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
CALLER LINE FOURTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THIS IS
STEVE HORN DIRECTOR GOVERNMENTAL
RELATIONS FOR I CAN
INTERNATIONAL CANCER AFFECTS YOU
NETWORK WE ARE STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. OUR NEXT AND FINAL COLOR
IS LIGHT. ONE OH TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES THIS IS PAGE TALLY
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL FOR THE ADVANCEMENT OF
PHARMACY IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THE NEW OTHER CALLERS TO
OTHER WITNESSES- BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS OF THE AUTHOR. SEE NON-
WHEN THE BILL WHEN WE HAVE A
QUORUM. WE CAN. HAVE A VOTE BE
AN EMOTION THE BILL DOES ENJOY A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE DOCTOR REGULAR.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT AND AGAIN FOR THE RECORD
I ACCEPT THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS IF AND WHEN THE TIME
IS RIGHT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THAT. WE'RE GOING TO GO OUT OF
ORDER BECAUSE THE NEXT AUTHOR IS
NOT PRESENT SO MR CHAN YOU HAVE
BEEN HERE PROBABLY SINCE SEVEN
O'CLOCK THIS MORNING SO YOU'RE
WELCOME TO COME FORWARD. AND
PRESENT AB. THAT SEVENTEEN OH
FOUR. OKAY TIME'S UP ALL RIGHT
NEXT NOW JUST GETTING. THANK YOU
SEE HERE AND I APPRECIATE THEIR
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS FROM SOMEONE
FOR A- MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THANK
YOU 4% AB SEVENTEEN OH FOUR. I
WANT TO BEGIN BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING SO
DILIGENTLY AND WITH MY STAFF ON
THESE AMENDMENTS WERE MORE THAN
HAPPY TO ACCEPT THEM. EARLY LAW
STATES IN ORDER FOR INDIVIDUAL
TO PERFORM X. RAYS OF THE FOOT
AND ANKLE THEY WOULD NEED AT
LEAST A CALIFORNIA X. RAY
TECHNICIAN. LIMITED PERMIT WITH
EITHER THE EXTREMITIES CATEGORY
OR A LEDGE WE ADDRESS CATEGORY.
HOWEVER THERE ARE NO SCHOOLS IN
CALIFORNIA WHO OFFER THIS
PERMIT. THIS IS WHAT A DIRE
SHORTAGE OF INDIVIDUALS
AVAILABLE TO ASSIST IN
PERFORMING X. RAYS. AND
PODIATRIC OFFICES WHICH CREATES
A SITUATION THAT HARMS
INDIVIDUAL AND SMALL GROUP
PRACTICES ABILITY PROVIDE PROPER
CARE RESULT IN X. RAYS EITHER
NOT BE PERFORMED BEFORE TO
OUTSIDE CENTERS WERE OTHER
INFERIOR MODALITIES BEING
EMPLOYED. THIS ULTIMATE DANGERS
THE PUBLIC. THE REPORT. DR
SURPRISE MEDICINE CANNOT FIND X.
RAY TECHNICIANS WERE WILLING TO
WORK. IN A PODIATRIC OFFICE AND
BE LIMITED TO ONLY PERFORMING
PODIATRIC RADIOGRAPHY. AB
SEVENTEEN ZERO FOUR WILL CREATE
A ALTERNATE PATHWAY FOR X. RAY
TCHNICIANS. TAKE A
COMPREHENSIVE COURSE OR EXAM.
CERTIFIED BY THE PODIATRIC
MEDICAL BOARD CALIFORNIA.
PERFORM THESE X. RAYS ON
SPECIALIZED PODIATRIC X. RAY
EQUIPMENT. BUT BUILT IN SAFETY
FEATURES. SPECIFIC TO THE FOOT
AND ANKLE. YOUR BY PREVENTING
THE OVER CERTIFICATION OF OUR
TECHNICIANS ENCOURAGED TO FEEL
THE PODIATRY. THE QUALIFIED
APPLICANTS HERE TO TESTIFY IS DR
KAREN RUBLE AND DR ERIC BALL.
THANK YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD. PUSH
THE BUTTON THERE YOU HAVE TO. M.
I. C. A AREA THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M DR KAREN RUBLE I'M
A DOCTOR OF PODIATRIC MEDICINE
IN THE LOS ANGELES AREA I'M HERE
TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PODIATRIC MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION. ALONG WITH MY
COLLEAGUE DR PAUL WHO WILL
PROVIDE TESTIMONY AND THEN WE
BOTH ARE AVAILABLE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. I'M
DOCTOR DURABLE I'M A PRACTICING.
A PODIATRIST IN LOS ANGELES
AREA. AND I'M ALSO REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA PODIATRIC MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION. AND THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF COMMITTEE WE AND PUT
EXTRA MEDICINE HAVE A PROBLEM
AND WE NEED YOUR HELP- THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING US TO SPEAK TODAY
TO ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM. AND
WE'VE BEEN EXPERIENCING IN IN
THE PODIATRIC OFFICES ACROSS THE
STATE. THAT IS THE INABILITY TO
FIND AN EMPLOYER QUALIFIED
INDIVIDUALS TO PERFORM LIMITED
X. RAYS OF THE FOOT AND ANKLE.
ON ANY GIVEN DAY AND PUT AFTER
MEDICINE. ONLY ABOUT 20% OF OUR
PATIENTS REQUIRE AN EXTRA. THIS
PROCESS INVOLVES THE USE OF
PLAIN X. RAYS USING A TYPE OF
DIGITAL EQUIPMENT WHICH IS
SPECIFIC TO THE FOOT AND ANKLE.
AND WHICH HAS BUILT IN SAFETY
FEATURES. MANY OF THE COMMON
PATHOLOGIES WE TREAT INCLUDING
TRAUMA INFECTION PRE AND POST
SURGICAL CARE ALL REQUIRE AN
IMMEDIATE. X. RAY READ TO
DETERMINE PROPER TREATMENT.
FAILURE TO OBTAIN THAT IMMEDIATE
READ CAN DIRECTLY AFFECT THE
TRAJECTORY OF THESE PATHOLOGIES.
WITHOUT QUALIFIED STAFF
AVAILABLE TO ASSIST US. THE
REALITY OF TIME MANAGEMENT IN
MOST OFFICES MAKE IT DIFFICULT
OR IMPOSSIBLE FOR PODIATRISTS TO
TAKE OUR OWN EX RACE. THIS EVEN
THOUGH WE ARE CERTIFIED BY THAT
REGULATION HEALTH BRANCH AS
RADIOLOGY SUPERVISORS AND
OPERATORS OURSELVES. THE REALITY
IS THAT THESE ACTUALLY STUDIES
ARE EITHER IMPORTED ENTIRELY OR
SENT ON TO TERTIARY FACILITIES
WITH THE RESULTANT DELAY IN CARE
. TO ENSURE THAT OUR PATIENTS
RECEIVE IMMEDIATE CARE THAT THEY
NEED BUT AFTER SEEK ASSISTANCE
FROM TECHNICIANS TO PERFORM THE
IN OFFICE X. RAY THESE
INDIVIDUALS OR PODIA ETTRICK
MEDICAL ASSISTANTS. ARE
DIFFERENT FROM OTHER TECHNICIANS
WHO PERFORM X. RAYS IN THAT
THEIR PRIMARY DUTY IS CHAIR SIDE
ASSISTING. WELL FOOT ANKLE X.
RAYS ARE A SECONDARY DUTY. FOR
DECADES PRIOR TO TWENTY THIRTEEN
OUR EXISTING PODIA ETTRICK
MEDICAL ASSISTANTS WHO WISH TO
INCREASE THEIR SKILLS. WOULD
TAKE IN AVAILABLE COURSE IN
RADIATION TECHNIQUE AND SAFETY.
THIS WAS OFFERED OVER SEVERAL
WEEKENDS. AFTER PASSING THE
REQUIRED TEST WHICH WAS SPECIFIC
THE PARTY AFTER MEDICINE. THEY
WERE AWARDED A CERTIFICATION BY
THE RADIOLOGIC HEALTH BRANCH.
MANY OF OUR MEDICAL ASSISTANCE
TOOK THIS COURSE ANDINCREASE
THEIR VALUE TO OUR PRACTICES.
AND THEIR BY THEIR SALARIES AS
WELL. BUT IN TWENTY THIRTEEN THE
REGULATION THAT ALLOWED THIS WAS
REMOVED. THE ABILITY TO BECOME
EDUCATED AS LAKE PARTY OUT
TRICK. X. P. IS NO LONGER EXISTS
THERE ARE CURRENTLY NO SCHOOLS
IN CALIFORNIA OFFERING OR
WILLING TO OFFER COURSES. IN THE
SPECIFIC LEG PARTY AFTER COURT
CATEGORY. ALSO NOW THOSE LIKE
PUT AFTER TAXIS WHO DID TAKE
THAT COURSE IN THE PAST. HAVE
BEEN LOST TO ATTRITION. IN FACT
ONLY HANDFUL REMAINING
CALIFORNIA THIS IS CREATED A
CRISIS FOR WHICH WE HAVE COME TO
YOU OR SOLUTION TODAY. IT COULD
BE MISUNDERSTOOD THAT A
CERTIFIED EXTREMITY AND XTC SUCH
AS ONE WHO MIGHT WORK FOR AN
ORTHOPEDIC GROUP. COULD BE
EMPLOYED HERE HOWEVER EVEN
IGNORING THE FINANCIAL REALITIES
THEY COMMAND MUCH HIGHER
SALARIES THIS WOULD BE AN ERROR.
THOSE EXTREMITY XTC
UNDERSTANDABLY ELECT TO PRACTICE
FULL SCOPE. ALMOST SOLELY AS
RADIOLOGY TAX NOT AS PRIMARILY
MEDICAL ASSISTANCE SIMPLY PUT
THE PM'S CANNOT FIND XTC WERE
WILLING TO WORK IN A PARTY AFTER
OFFICE. I'LL CONTINUE THEN SO
SIMPLY PUT AGAIN D. PM'S CANNOT
FIND EXCUSE ARE WILLING TO WORK
IN A PARTY THAT TOOK OFFICE AND
PERFORM ONLY FOOT AND ANKLE
RADIOGRAPHY THEY JUST DO NOT
EXIST. TO REMOVE EXISTING
BARRIERS TO EDUCATION AND TO
ACCOMMODATE THE SPECIALIZED PUT
AFTER EXITING WE NEED TO SAFELY
EXPAND THE NUMBER OF QUALIFIED
AND APPROVED TECHNICIANS BY
ADDRESSING OUTDATED IMPEDIMENTS
THE TRAINING AND EDUCATION WHICH
HAD BECOME A DE FACTO
PROHIBITION. WE ARE SEEKING A
SOLUTION THAT WILL ENABLE THESE
INDIVIDUALS THESE MEDICAL
ASSISTANCE PARTICULARLY THOSE
ALREADY WORKING AT A PARTY AFTER
GO OFFICE TO BE FURTHER TRAINED
AND PERMITTED TO PERFORM X. RAYS
AB SEVENTEEN OH FOUR CREATES
THAT SOLUTION WE SEE.
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL IS COME FORWARD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEMBERS KIM
STONE OF STONE ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF THAT CALIFORNIA
ORTHOPEDIC ASSOCIATION WE HAVE
AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION TO THE BILL IN PRINCE
BUT HAVE HAD VERY PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE SPONSORS
AND WITH THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE ART
TWO ISSUES ARE. A SCOPE ISSUE
AND ALSO THAT THE RADIOLOGIC
HEALTH BRANCH HAVE OVERSIGHT
OVER THE COURSE AND- WE ARE.
CONFIDENT AND OPTIMISTIC ABOUT
AT PRESIDING THOSE AS THE BILL
PROCEEDS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT IF YOU JUST
PUSH THE BIKE BUTTON IN FRONT OF
YOU THERE. THANKS OUR IT'S OUR
FIRST TIME. OKAY MISTER CHAIRMAN
BIRDS NOTHING PROFITS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA RADIOLOGICAL
SOCIETY WE HAD CONCERNS WITH THE
APPROACH TAKEN IN AB SEVENTEEN
OH FOUR AS INTRODUCED BY OF HOT
CONSTRUCTIVE DIALOGUE WITH THE
AUTHOR STAFF AND SPONSOR. WITHIN
THE RADIOLOGIC HEALTH BRANCH OF
CDPH THERE'S AN ADVISORY BODY
CALLED THE RADIOLOGY RADIOLOGIC
TECHNOLOGY CERTIFICATION
COMMITTEE. WHICH IS MADE UP OF
THE VARIOUS LICENSE USERS OF
IONIZING RADIATION INCLUDING
RADIOLOGISTS ORTHOPEDIC SURGEONS
PODIATRISTS AND RADIOLOGIC
TECHNOLOGISTS. THEY PROVIDE
ADVICE TO THE ARCH BEYOND
REGULATORY AND POLICY ISSUES AND
WE MAINTAIN THAT THE CURRENT
REQUIREMENTS. FOR THESE LIMITED
PERMIT CATEGORIES BE REVIEWED
AND CHANGED WITHIN THE EXISTING
REGULATORY PROCESS. AMENDMENTS
INTRODUCED TODAY ADDRESS SOME OF
OUR CONCERNS AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO REVIEWING THEM IN DETAIL AND
TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH AUTHORS
OFFICE AND THE SPONSORS. THANK
YOU VERY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
EITHER SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
PLEASE COME FOR TO THE
MICROPHONE IF YOU ARE. SEE NO
ONE WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES-
MISTRUST RAIDER PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES FOR PEOPLE OF WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION JUST THEIR
NAME. POSITION ON THE BILL AN
ORGANIZATION ONLY. OUR SECURE
WITNESSES TO HAVE A OPPOSITION.
OR IN FAVOR PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD RIGHT
NOW. THE FIRST COMMUNIST FROM MY
NUMBER ONE SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD AND STANDING
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JAMES
STEWART I'M SORRY I'M CALLING IN
REGARDS TO ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY AND SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL MULTIPLE
SCLEROSIS SOCIETY AND I WANTED
TO REINFORCE AND LET YOU KNOW
THAT JUST JUST TERRIBLY NOTICES
IN ONLY ON THE BILL. THEN JAMES
STEWART AND WE SUPPORT ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHTEEN EIGHTY PERFECT
THANK YOU OKAY. OKAY ANYONE
BEYOND. OUR NEXT COMMENT INCOME
NINE ONE TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. TYLER SEGUIN TWENTY SIX-
WENT OUT OF THE QUEUE BEFORE
THEY COULD BE. ASK YOUR COMMENT
WILL GOING TO WAR NINE ONE
TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
HI MY NAME IS BILL YES REPEAL
WORK AT OMNI SAN FRANCISCO
HOTEL- LOCAL TO MEMBER I WOULD
LIKE TO SUPPORT THE- I'M YES
SUPPORT THE- PRESCRIPTION THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY OKAY.
INTERESTING STUFF ON THE PHONE
LINES TODAY HERE SO OF- IT IS
WHAT IT IS SO OKAY NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. OR WHATEVER BILLS WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT. NEXT TO
COMPETITION NINE NINETY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
KURT BRAG ALLEY I SUPPORT THE
BILL AND I'M WITH UNITED HERE.
LOCAL TO IN SAN FRANCISCO THANK
YOU. THANKS JUST ONCE AGAIN
THIS- MY APPRECIATE PEOPLE WHO
WANT CALLING ON BILLS ALREADY
ABOUT- THOSE WOULD BE EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY AND TWENTY FIVE THIRTY WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT NOW AB
SEVENTEEN OH FOUR SO IF YOU ARE
YOU WILL HAVE WITH F. TESTIMONY
IN FAVOR OR OPPOSITION TO
SEVENTEEN OH FOUR THESE- THESE.
LET US KNOW. THE DROP REITER.
OUR NEXT COMING IN FROM LINE
NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON MY RELIEF THAT
IT'S OVER THERE- UNITED BUT HERE
YEAH SUPPORT BOOK THE BILL FROM. FIVE THIRTY. THANK YOU. BUT
AGAIN FOR THIS BILL IF YOU OF
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD OUR NEXT
COMMENT IS FROM NINE ONE OH
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THAT
WORKS. BUT THAT TIME- THREE ALLY
AS OLD PLEASED. IN ORDER. THE
NOT BOB NEXT CALLER PLEASE GET
THERE THAT. I THAT WOULD DELAY
CALLER AT THE MOMENT. THANK YOU-
WILL COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE- THE BILL
DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WHEN WE HAVEA
QUORUM AND CAN HAVE A MOTION-
WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE THIS PROJECT. MISTER SMITH THANK YOU YOUR
STAFF FOR BEING SO DILIGENT
PATIENT TURNS OF. THE BILL I
ALSO WANT TO THANK MY WITNESSES
AS WELL AS THE RHEOLOGICAL
SOCIETY OF. UNDERSTANDING SOME
OF THE CONCERNS THAT THEY HAVE
AS WELL AS MISS KIM'S DOWN.
UNDER CONFIDENT THAT WE CAN WORK
OUT THE DETAILS. OF MAKING SURE
THAT SOME OF THE OPPOSITION
WILL. BE A LESSON OR FAIRLY SO
GO AWAY THANK YOU SO MUCH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANKS
VERY MUCH MR CHAN. I MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER FIVE MISTER FLOOR
ARE YOU READY TO PRESENT. YOU'RE
NEXT IN LINE. THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
DOING YEAH. LET'S GO FILE ORDER.
I NEVER DID IT DIFFERENTLY THIS
YEAR SO. BOB GOOD. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS I'D LIKE
TO START BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE AND THEIR STAFF FOR
THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL AND WE
ARE HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AB EIGHTEEN
NINETY TWO WILL SET THE
REIMBURSEMENT FLOOR FOR
RECESSION ORTHOPEDIC APPLIANCES
TO BE AT LEAST 80% OF THE
PREVAILING MEDICARE ALLOWABLE
RATE EIGHTEEN NINETY TWO SHARES
OF THE SOCIALLY VULNERABLE
MEDICAL POPULATION WILL BENEFIT
FROM IMPROVED ACCESS TO CRITICAL
CARE. LEADING TO INDEPENDENT
PRODUCTIVE LIVES WITH THE SAME
TIME DECREASE THE IMPACT OF MORE
EXPENSIVE CARE AND SERVICES IN
THE MEDICARE PROGRAM WITHOUT A
REASONABLE REIMBURSEMENT
METHODOLOGY RATE. SOCIALLY
VULNERABLE PATIENTS WILL
CONTINUE STRUGGLED ACCESS OF
CARE AN ONGOING SUFFER AND
MOBILITY WHICH ULTIMATELY LEAVE
pTO. FURTHER HEALTH ISSUES HERE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT WITH ME
TODAY IS SPENCER GREEN PRESIDENT
CALIFORNIA ORTHOPEDIC AND
PROSTHETIC ASSOCIATION AND
RODNEY HARRISON A MEDIC CAL A.
B. D. AND HOPE YOU. PATIENTS
THEM. THANK MISS FLOOR- GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MY NAME IS
SPENCER GREEN I'M A CERTIFIED
PROSTITUTES TO AN ORTHOPEDIST OF
EIGHTEEN YEARS REGIONAL DIRECTOR
FOR HANGER CLINIC THE PRESIDENT
OF THE CALIFORNIA OR THOUGHT I
CAN PROSTHETIC ASSOCIATION I'M
HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN
NINETY TWO. OR THE TESTS AND
PROCESSES TREAT PATIENTS WITH
DEFORMED DYSFUNCTIONAL AND
MISSING LIMBS. THIS IS A
VULNERABLE POPULATION CALIFORNIA
IS EXPERIENCING AN AND THE
ACCESS TO CARE CRISIS FOR THOSE
IN NEED ORTHODONTIC PROSTHETIC
DEVICES. I'M REMINDED OF A
MEDICARE BENEFICIARY IN
BAKERSFIELD CALIFORNIA- THROUGH
PREGNANCY AND CHILDBEARING
EXPERIENCED PHYSICALCHANGES AND
NO LONGER FIT IN HER PROSTHESIS
. WHILE WAITING FOR MEDICAL TO
AUTHORIZE A NEW PROPERLY FITTING
DEVICE SHE SPENT FOUR MONTHS
WAITING TO HOLD HER NEWBORN BABY
WHILE STANDING UP. THESE
CRITICAL DEVICES PROVIDE
INDEPENDENCE MOBILITY AND SAFETY. TEN YEARS OF THE DEPARTMENT'S
DATA SHOWS THAT THE NUMBER OF
MEDICARE ALL BENEFICIARIES
NEEDING OR THOUGHT I CAN
PROSPECT OF VICES IS
EXPONENTIALLY INCREASING WHILE
THE NUMBER OF PROVIDERS IS
NOWHERE NEAR KEEPING PACE. THIS
TREND WILL CONTINUE AS THE
MEDICAL PROGRAM EXPANDS. THE
AVERAGE MEDICAL REIMBURSEMENT
FOR THOUGHT IT CAN PROSTHETIC
DEVICES IS 51% OF CURRENT
CURRENT MEDICARE. NATIONALLY
MEDICAID PAYMENTS AVERAGE 75% OF
CURRENT MEDICARE- CALIFORNIA
STATE THE PROVIDE THAT PRIDES
ITSELF ON ACCESS TO CARE AND
SOCIAL PROGRAMS HOWEVER WATCHING
OR THOUGHT I CAN PROSTHETIC
PROVIDERS TURN AWAY FROM THESE
BENEFICIARIES. BECAUSE THE
REIMBURSEMENT FOR THESE PRODUCTS
BARELY COVERS THE COST OF GOODS
. AB EIGHTEEN NINETY TWO SIX TO
CHANGE THIS PROBLEM. SO WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN PATIENTS DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO CARE WELL THE DEVICES
HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO BECOME ILL
FITTING. THEY LEAD TO SKIN
BREAKDOWN DECREASED MOBILITY.
AND OTHER HEALTH COMPLICATIONS
AND ILL FITTING PROSTHESIS LEADS
TO INCREASED HEALTH CARE AND
SOCIAL SERVICES COSTS TO THE
STATE. WHERE'S BENEFICIARIES THE
DO HAVE ACCESS TO QUALITY CARE
ARE MORE MOBILE MORE CAPABLE
MORE INDEPENDENT AND THEREFORE
MORE LIKELY TO REJOIN THE
WORKFORCE I ENCOURAGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THESE VULNERABLE MEMBERS
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY BY VOTING I
ON A. B. EIGHTEEN NINETY TWO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YOU'RE READY SIR. HELLO THANK
YOU SMEONE ON THE FLOOR AND
THANK YOU ALL GERMAN OTHER
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS FOR ANOTHER TERM
TO BE HERE SPEAK TO YOU- MY
NAME'S SEAN HARRISON. MOST WILL
BE IS ROCKING HER SO MANY BEAUTY
AND I'M AN ADVOCATE FOR
AMPUTEES. MY LIFE WAS AFFECTED
BY A LIMB LOSS BECAUSE- I WAS
INVOLVED IN A MOTORCYCLE
ACCIDENT. AND I'M I'M WITH
LIVING WITNESS LIVING TESTIMONY
OF WHAT. WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
TODAY SO MY LAKE HERE. IS AN
EXAMPLE OF WHAT AMPUTEES NEED.
WHEN I FIRST LOST MY LEG. I
DIDN'T HAVE A DEVICE LIKE THIS
SO I WAS NOT ABLE TO WORK WASN'T
ABLE TO GET AROUND TOO WELL ONCE
I GOT THE APPROPRIATE DEVICE I
NOW WORK A FULL TIME JOB. THE
ONLY THAT I WAS ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN SPARTAN RACING
PART OF A TEAM OF AMPUTEES PAYER
SPARTANS. WE BECAME WORLD
CHAMPIONS. NOW I STILL WORK AND
I'M AN ADVOCATE FOR ME. I AM A
LIVING TESTIMONY OF WHAT THE
DEVICE CAN DO FOR PATIENTS IF
YOU. ALLOW US TO HAVE THIS BILL
PASS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SHAPED UP.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. ANYONE
IN THE HEARING ROOM LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORTER OPPOSITION
PLEASE COME TO THE MICROPHONE
FOR JUST YOUR NAME AND POSITION.
ORGANIZATION ON THE BILL. AND NO
ONE WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES
THEN- STRUCK RAIDER- PHONE LINES
FOR PEOPLE IN EITHER SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL NAME
POSITION AN ORGANIZATION ONLY
PLEASE. WE HAVE A COMMENT FROM
LINE NUMBER TWELVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
KERRY VENABLE WITH HANGER CLINIC
IN SACRAMENTO AND I AM IN
SUPPORT AND EIGHTY EIGHTEEN
NINETY TWO THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. OUR NEXT
CALLER SOME NINE NUMBER
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS BRANDON ERICKSEN AND I
REPRESENT SOUTHERN PROSTHETIC
SUPPLY AND I SUPPORT A. B.
EIGHTEEN NINETY TWO. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
CALLER FROM NINE TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
I'M MAYNARD CAR COOK CEO OF
MEDICAL CREATION AND I SUPPORT
A. B. EIGHTEEN NINETY TWO. THANK
YOU X. COLOR PLEASE. NEXT CALLER
IS NOT FROM LINE ONE TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS RICHARD
RILEY PRESIDENT OWN PEOPLE WHO
STE I AM IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE
EIGHT NINE TWO. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT
CALL THE SHOP NINE NUMBER NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
KATHLEEN OFFICE I AM WITH CAPS
IN ORTHOPEDICS AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTEEN NINETY TWO.
THANK YOU X. COLOR PLEASE. WE
DON'T KNOW FOR THEIR CALLERS IN
THE QUEUE BUT ONCE AGAIN PRESS
ONE ZERO IF YOU OF OPPOSITION OR
- IN SUPPORT. WE HAVE NOBODY
ELSE QUEUING UP AT THE MOMENT
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. C. KNOWLEDGE WAS
EIGHT THAT THE BILL DOES ENJOY
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION I LIKE I
LIKE WHAT YOU'RE DOING HERE AND
I WANT TO THANK YOUR WITNESSES
FOR BEING HERE. TODAY AS WELL.
WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM. WE CAN'T
WE DON'T CAN'T ENTERTAIN A
MOTION CAN ENTERTAIN A VOTE. BUT
WE CAN'T LET YOU CLOSE. THIS
REQUEST AND I BUT WHEN THE TIME
IS RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH
APPRECIATE THANK YOU. VERY MUCH
TO WITNESSES. WE WILL NOW GO.
TO- MR GABRIEL. YOU HAVE AB
NINETEEN TWENTY NINE YOU HAVE A
BILLING CONSENT AND IF YOU WANT
TO PULL IT OFF. I WOULDN'T
RECOMMEND IT. WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY SIR.
I'M IF TO PUSH THE MICROPHONE
BUT IT'S ON THE ON YOUR LEFT.
WELCOME TO THE HEALTH COMMITTEE
. THAT NAZARIAN ALL RIGHT IT WAS
A LITTLE DIFFERENT WHEN I WAS IN
THIS ROOM YESTERDAY SO. THANK
YOU I THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN VERSE. I AM PLEASED
TODAY TO PRESENT AB NINETEEN
TWENTY NINE. A BILL TO PROVIDE
MEDICARE REIMBURSEMENT FOR
PROFESSIONAL VIOLENCE PREVENTION
SERVICES THAT HAVE PROVEN
EFFECTIVE AT STOPPING CYCLES OF
GUN VIOLENCE AND SAVING LIVES.
THE COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
INTENSIFIED THE COUNTRY'S GUN
VIOLENCE CRISIS. RECORD
INCREASES IN GUN SALES SOCIAL
COVER
PEOPLE AT INCREASED RISK OF GUN
VIOLENCE. TWENTY TWENTY AND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE OR SOME OF THE
DEADLIEST YEARS ON RECORD FOR
UNITED STATES. IN JUST A FEW
DAYS AGO WE EXPERIENCE YET
ANOTHER HORRIFIC INCIDENT OF GUN
VIOLENCE JUST A FEW BLOCKS AWAY
FROM THIS VERY HEARING ROOM.
THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS ARE NOT
ENOUGH WE MUST ADDRESS GUN
VIOLENCE HEAD ON NOT ONLY IS A
PUBLIC SAFETY ISSUE BUT ALSO AS
A PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE. OUR
HEALTHCARE SYSTEMS HAVE SAVED
COUNTLESS LIVES BUT PATIENTS ARE
USUALLY DISCHARGED BACK INTO THE
SAME CONDITIONS. THAT LED TO
THEIR VIOLENT VICTIMIZATION IN
THE FIRST PLACE. THIS CREATES A
REVOLVING DOOR OF VIOLENT
INDUSTRY A VIOLENT INJURY AND
TRAUMA CENTERS TO OFTEN SEE THE
SAME VICTIMS OVER AND OVER
AGAIN. AB NINETEEN TWENTY NINE
ADDRESSES THE UNFORTUNATE
REALITY THAT FAR TOO MANY
VICTIMS OF GUN VIOLENCE ARE AT
HIGH RISK FOR A RE INJURY. AND
RETALIATION AND WE LEVERAGES
FEDERAL MEDICAID DOLLARS TO
CREATE A SUSTAINABLE FUNDING
STREAM. FOR EVIDENCE BASED
VIOLENCE PREVENTION SERVICES
THAT PROMOTE RECOVERY AND REDUCE
THE RISK OF RE ENTRY. LIKE THE
CURRENT PANDEMIC THE GUN
VIOLENCE PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS
DEMANDS THAT WE TAKE ACTION TO
PROTECT THOSE MOST AT RISK. BY
EXPANDING ACCESS TO VIOLENCE
PREVENTION SERVICES AB NINETEEN
TWENTY NINE WILL SAVE LIVES.
REDUCE BURDENS ON THE MEDICAL
AND JUDICIAL SYSTEMS AND ADDRESS
TROUBLING RACIAL DISPARITIES IN
HEALTH AND COMMUNITY VIOLENCE
OUTCOMES. THAT'S WHY THIS
LEGISLATION IS SUPPORTED BY A
BROAD COALITION OF GUN VIOLENCE
IN PUBLIC HEALTH ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING GIFFORDS MOMS DEMAND
ACTION THE BRADY CAMPAIGN'S
EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS NURSES.
PEDIATRIC PACKED PRACTITIONERS
AND PUBLIC HEALTH ADVOCATES.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT ARE GABRIEL GARCIA
POLICY AND ADVOCACY DIRECTOR
YOUTH ALIVE IN KINDRED SIMONS
DIRECTOR FRONTLINE TRAINING AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AT THE
HEALTH ALLIANCE FOR VIOLENCE
INTERVENTION. THANK YOU AND WHEN
YOU HAVE A QUORUM AND EMOTION I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
GO AHEAD WHEN YOU'RE READY SIR.
PUSH THE BUTTON THERE IF YOU
DON'T MIND. GREAT THANK YOU CAN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS GABRIEL
GARCIA AND I'M THE POLICY AND
ADVOCACY DIRECTOR FOR YOU TO
LIVE WHERE CAN YOU BASED
ORGANIZATION IN OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA THAT FOCUSES ON
VIOLENCE PREVENTION.
INTERVENTION AND HEALING. GOT
THIS PANDEMIC WE'VESEEN- STORED
INCREASES AND GUN VIOLENCE. AND
AS MUCH AS HOMICIDE HAS BEEN A
LEADINGCAUSE OF DEATH ACROSS
THE UNITED STATES IT IS THE
LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH FOR YOUNG
BLACK MEN UNDER THE AGE OF FORTY
FOUR. SO THIS CRISIS ONLY GOTTEN
WORSE GOT THE PANDEMIC THAT'S
WHY WE NEED ALL HANDS ON DECK
APPROACH. THAT INCLUDES A
COHERENT PUBLIC HEALTH STRATEGY
TO ADDRESS AND REDUCE VIOLENCE
ACROSS OUR COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA. THAT'S WHY WE'RE
PROUD TO SPONSOR ASSEMBLY BILL
NINETEEN TWENTY NINE. WHICH
WOULD CREATE A COMMUNITY
VIOLENCE PREVENTION AND RECOVERY
PROGRAM THROUGH OUR MEDICAL
SYSTEM. WE KNOW THIS ESSENTIAL
BECAUSE THE DEPARTMENT
HEALTHCARE SERVICES ALREADY
PROPOSING TO DO THIS I DO A
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKER BENEFIT
THAT GOVERNOR NEWSOM HAS
PROPOSED INVESTING OVER THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS AND- IN
ADDITION TO THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN
HAS STOOD ON THE ROSE GARDEN
ALMOST A YEAR AGO TODAY. AND
CALLED FOR STATES TO FIND
VIOLENCE PREVENTION THROUGH
THEIR MEDICAID SYSTEMS AND THAT
VERY SAME EVENT ATTORNEY GENERAL
MERRICK GARLAND SAID IN THE ROSE
GARDEN. AND MENTIONED THE
HOSPITAL BASED VIOLENCE
INTERVENTION PROGRAM THAT WAS
CREATED IN OAKLAND BY YOUTH
ALIVE AS AN EFFECTIVE STRATEGY
FOR ADDRESSING AND REDUCING GUN
VIOLENCE. REALLY PROUD OF THIS
LEGISLATION BECAUSE IT IS BASED
OFF OF THE EXPERIENCES OF OUR
COMMUNITIES HERE IN OAKLAND.
WE'VE SEEN THESE S. SUCCESSFUL
RESULTS REPRODUCE ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY WITH THIS INTERNATIONAL
MODEL OF HOSPITAL BASED.
VIOLENCE INTERVENTION AND
PREVENTION. SO FOR US
RECOGNIZING THE PATH THAT WE'VE
GOTTEN TO INTRODUCE AND CREATE
THIS LEGISLATION WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT AND YOUR
AYE VOTE. WHEN THERE'S A QUORUM
ESTABLISHED AGAIN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON. WHAT. GOOD AFTERNOON. HAS BEEN A
VIOLENCE INTERVENTION PROGRAMS
ARE THE SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
OFFERED TO SURVIVORS OF
COMMITTING VIOLENCE AT HOSPITAL
BEDSIDE WELL THEY'RE STARTING
THEIR JOURNEY TO HEALING. THE
CONCEPT OF H. VIPS WAS DEVELOPED
INDIVIDUAL SHERMAN SPEARS WHO IS
A SURVIVOR OF GUN VIOLENCE
HIMSELF. THE ONE THING THAT
STOOD OUT FOR SHERMAN DURING HIS
INITIAL HEALING PHASE WAS THAT
THERE WERE NOT PEOPLE AROUND HIM
THAT COULD RELATE TO HIS
EXPERIENCE THAT COULD RELATE TO
HIS TRAUMA SOMEONE THAT COULD
OFFER SUPPORT FROM HIS
PERSPECTIVE. VIVUS PREVENTION
PROFESSIONALS. WHO WORK ON THE
FRONT LINES OF H. VIPS ARE THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT SHERMAN NEEDED.
WHEN HE WAS STARTING HIS HEALING
JOURNAL. AND BECAUSE THEY'RE
SHERMAN H. VIPS EXIST WE NOW
KNOW AND DOCUMENTED STUDIES
AROUND THE COUNTRY HAVE PROVEN
THAT H. PHIPPS REDUCE RE INJURY
RATES EVERY DEUCE HEALTHCARE
COSTS. THE MOST IMPORTANT
EFFECTIVE COMPONENT OF H. VIPS
IS THE INCREDIBLE IS THE
CREDIBILITY OF HVS AND THEIR
LIVED EXPERIENCE. WE HAVE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THEIR LIVED
EXPERIENCE IN THE PORTAL WORK
THEY ADVISE PREVENTION
PROFESSIONALS DO ON THE FRONT
LINES TO SUPPORT SURVIVORS OF
COMMUNITY VIOLENCE YEAH WE
CANNOT FORGET THAT VIOLENCE
PREVENTION PROFESSIONALS ARE
ALSO SURVIVORS WITHIN THEIR
HEALING JOURNEYS. AB NINETEEN
TWENTY NINE WOULD ALLOW AGENCIES
WHO EMPLOY VIOLENCE PREVENTION
PROFESSIONALS WHO CONTINUOUSLY
BILL MEDICARE AS AN ADD A
FUNDING SOURCE THIS WOULD ALLOW
EMPLOYEES TO INCREASE OF
VIOLENCE PREVENTION PROFESSIONAL
SALARIES TO ACTUAL LIVABLE WAGE
. IN ADDITION TO EMPLOYEES OF BY
A ROBUST MEDICAL BENEFITS AND
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AND ALSO
EMPLOYEE ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS SO
THEIR VIOLENCE PREVENTION
PROFESSIONALS CAN SEEK THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES NEEDED.
TO CONTINUE MANAGING THEIR OWN
TRAUMA. WHY THEY SUPPORT
SURVIVORS THE COMMUNITY VIOLENCE
WHO THEY NEEDED BAD SIDE. BY
THIS PREVENTION PROFESSIONALS
ARE A CRUCIAL COMPONENT TO H.
VIPS AND WE MUST KEEP THEM BOTH
MENTALLY AND PHYSICALLY SAFE TO
CONTINUE TO THE INCREDIBLE WORK
THAT THEY DO IN THEIR OWN
COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. IS THERE ANYONE
IS THERE OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. C. NINE
WILL GO TO BOB- MEMBERS OF THE
AUDIENCE IN EITHER SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION WITH JUST YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION IMPOSITION PLEASE.
THANK YOUR MEMBERS TO MADDEN
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS AND EVERYTOWN FOR GUN
SAFETY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MICHELLE GIBBONS
OF THE COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE. FINOTTO GO TO THE
PHONE LINES MISTER OPERATOR-
PEOPLE WHO WE WANT TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION FOR THIS
BILL JUST THEIR NAME POSITION
AND ORGANIZATION IF THEY
REPRESENT ONE WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. FOUR COMMENTS IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION TO A. B. NINETEEN
TWENTY NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN. ONE
ZERO. AND FIRST WE'LL GO TO LINE
THIRTY SIX. ONE THIRTY SIX-
MICHAEL OPEN. SHORT ON BEHALF OF
LOMA LINDA UNIVERSITY HEALTH IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT CALL.
LINE SEVENTY FIVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON KIDNEY FAN ON BEHALF
OF DIFFERENCE LAWCENTER A CO
SPONSOR OF EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
TWENTY NINE REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU X. COLOR
PLEASE. ONE TWENTY ONE. REBECCA
GONZALEZ NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. BLIND. ONE
HUNDRED THIRTY ONE. LINE ONE
THIRTY ONE YEAR MIKE IS OPEN.
LINE. ONE HUNDRED THIRTY SIX. HI
MY NAME IS PRINCE PHILIP PERRIS
WHERE I WORK AT ACCESO WITH
UNITE HERE LOCAL HE'LL BE AFTER
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE. ONE
HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR. GOOD
AFTERNOON AMY BROWN REPRESENTING
THE CITY OF LONG BEACH IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. AND MISTER CHAIR THERE
ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SEEING NONE OF THE
BILL DOES ENJOY A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. WHEN WE HAVE A
QUORUM. AT A MOTION SO- MR GABER
WHICH I CLOSE I WOULD THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN WITH YOUR
PERMISSION I WANT TO DIRECT MY
COMMENTS TO OUR MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE WHO ARE NOT DEMOCRATS-
I KNOW TAT SOMETIMES WHEN WE
DEAL WITH BILLS THAT RELATE TO
GUN VIOLENCE THEY CAN VERY
EASILY BECOME PARTISAN AND I
JUST WANT TO. EMPHASIZE HERE
THAT THIS IS NOT A BILL THAT
SAYS ANYTHING ABOUT WHO CAN HAVE
A WEAPON UNDER WHAT
CIRCUMSTANCES THEY CAN HAVE A
WEAPON IT SIMPLY SPEAKS TO THE
HEALTH IMPACTS OF GUN VIOLENCE
IN WHAT WE DO ABOUT PEOPLE WHO
HAVE BEEN VICTIMS. AND WE KNOW
THAT 44% OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
VICTIMS ARE LIKELY TO BECOME RE
VICTIMIZED IN THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS AND SO THIS IS ABOUT WHAT
WE DO TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
BREAKING THE CYCLES OF VIOLENCE
AND KEEPING THOSE PEOPLE SAFE SO
I REALLY WANTED TO UNDERSCORE
THAT. IN ALSO SAYS WE'RE ALREADY
INVESTING MONEY IN THESE
PROGRAMS WE PUT TWO HUNDRED NINE
DOLLARS OVER THE NEXT TWO YEARS
INTO OUR BUDGET TO FUND THESE
PROGRAMS WHAT THIS SAYS IS LET'S
ALSO USE MEDICARE AND IT'S A WAY
WE CAN SPLIT THE COST WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SO WE CAN
ACTUALLY SAVE RESOURCES FOR
TAXPAYERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE ALSO KNOW FROM
THE- FISCAL ANALYSIS OF A PRIOR
VERSION OF THE SPELL. THAT THE
COSTS ARE EXCEPTIONALLY LOW
THEY'RE A MERE COUPLE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS I THINK WE
CALCULATED LAST TIME THAT IF
THIS BILL WERE IF THESE SERVICES
WERE TO SAVE- YOU KNOW PREVENT
ONE OR TWO SHOOTINGS THAT THEY
WOULD PAY FOR THEMSELVES THAT
THEY WOULD SAVE THAT THEY'D SAVE
RESOURCES FOR TAXPAYERS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO I KNOW
OFTEN ARE ARE CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT GUNS BECOME PARTISAN. BUT
I JUST HOBLEY SUGGESTS TO- ARE
REPUBLICAN AND INDEPENDENT
COLLEAGUES THAT AT THIS IS
REALLY ABOUT ABOUT ABOUT SAVING
LIVES ABOUT SAVING TAXPAYER
RESOURCES AND IT DOESN'T GET
INTO THOSE OTHER CONVERSATIONS I
CAN BE MORE DIFFICULT AND WITH
THAT WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
GABRIEL THANK YOU TO WITNESSES.
SEE MR HOLDEN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PRESENT YOUR BILL MR HOLDEN.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN. WHAT I WOULD LIKE
TO CALL A COMMON SENSE MEASURE
THAT WILL ENSURE THAT CHILDREN
ARE PROTECTED WHILE THEY'RE AT
DAY AND SUMMER CAMPS. THIS
COMING SUMMER CHILDREN FROM ALL
OVER CALIFORNIA WILL ATTEND
THOUSANDS OF CAMPS. OF THESE
CAMPS ONLY OVERNIGHT CAMPS ARE
REQUIRED TO FOLLOW STATE
REGULATIONS IN VIRTUALLY NONE
ARE INSPECTED TO ENSURE THE
SAFETY OF CHILDREN ATTENDING.
INSPECTIONS THAT ARE CARRIED OUT
DO NOT FOCUS ON STAFF
QUALIFICATIONS OR BACKGROUND
CHECKS BUT INSTEAD ARE PRIMARILY
CONCENTRATED ON BUILDING AND
FOOD COMPLIANCE. THE CODE
INFOBANK CODE COMPLIANCE. EVEN
IF CANCER FOUND TO BE OUT OF
COMPLIANCE LOCAL HEALTH
OFFICIALS ARE NOT REQUIRED TO
SHUT DOWN UNSAFE CAMPS OR
PROGRAMS. FURTHER DAY CAMPS
ATTENDED BY CHILDREN WHICH
CONSTITUTE THE VAST MAJORITY OF
CAPS IN CALIFORNIA ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO FOLLOW ANY
REGULATIONS OR LAWS REGARDING
CHILD SAFETY INCLUDING SEX
OFFENDERS AND BACKGROUND CHECKS.
THIS BILL WILL ADDRESS THESE
DEFICIENCIES IN CURRENT LAW BY
REQUIRING CHILDREN'S CAMPS TO
ADOPT BASIC SAFETY STANDARDS A
REGISTER WITH THEIR COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH. PUBLIC
HEALTH. IT ALSO REQUIRES COUNTY
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS TO VERIFY THE
CAMPS ATTENDED BY CHILDREN
ARMENIAN THOSE SAFETY STANDARDS
. AB IN SEVENTEEN THIRTY SEVEN
ALSO REQUIRES THE CHILDREN CAP
OPERATORS CONDUCT ANNUAL
BACKGROUND CHECKS FOR ALL
PROSPECTIVE AND CURRENT STAFF.
MANY ARE PREVENTABLE TRAGEDIES
WE HAVE SEEN ACCOUNTS INDICATE
THAT WE MUST DO MORE TO PROTECT
OUR CHILDREN. IN THE CASE OF
ROCKS THE FORBES THE SIX YEAR
OLD WHO DROWNED WHILE ATTENDING
A DAY CAMPING OUT TO DINNER
THESE PROTECTIONS WILL BE TOO
LATE. BUT IT'S NOT TOO LATE TO
PREVENT FUTURE CHILDREN FAMILIES
AND COMMUNITIES FROM SUFFERING
THIS HEARTBREAKING EXPERIENCE.
HERE TODAY WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN IS DOUG FORD'S THE FATHER
OF ROXY. I WOULD LIKE TO
EMPHASIZE THAT I AM COMMITTED TO
ADDRESSING THE CONCERNS OF ALL
STAKEHOLDERS TO IMPROVE. AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY SEVEN WILL DO
SO AS THE BILL MOVES FORWARD.
OUR STATES CAPS CAMP SAFETY
REGULATIONS MUST CHANGE TO
ENSURE THAT STAFF ARE FULLY
QUALIFIED. INSPECTIONS
MEANINGFUL ENSURE CHILD SAFETY
AND PARENTS MAY REST ASSURED
THAT THEIR CHILD WILL TOOK
RETURN HOME SAFELY. LIKE TO
THANK YOU AND WHEN THE TIME IS
RIGHT. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE
VOTE AND- OUR WITNESSES- TODAY
MR FORBES JUSTIFY. GREAT THANK
YOU MR HOLDEN AND PLEASE GO
AHEAD MR FORBES. I'M SORRY THERE
WE GO THERE WE GO. MY NAME IS
DOUG FORD'S THIS IS MY WIFE
ELENA AND MY SIX YEAR OLD
DAUGHTER ROXY. SUMMER CAMP
OPERATORS ADMITTED TO SHOCKING
ACCIDENT KILLED ROXY. LATEST
DESPAIR EVENTUALLY RAVAGED HER
IMMUNE SYSTEM. SHE DIED FOUR
WEEKS AGO. HE WAS ONLY FIFTY SO
YOU MIGHT IMAGINE HOW HARD THIS
IS FOR ME RIGHT NOW TO BE HERE.
I STOOD OVER MY LIFELESS CHILD
WITH HER EYES STUCK HALF OPEN
PUPILS BLACK SKIN COLD AND BLUE
I ADMINISTERED CPR. MY BELOVED
WIFE KNOWING IT WOULDN'T WORK.
BUT I PROMISED THEM THAT I
WOULDN'T STOP UNTIL I PREVENTED
OTHER CHILDREN FAMILIES FROM
SUFFERING AS WE HAVE. I NOW RUN
THE NATION'S ONLY CAMP SAFETY
FOUNDATION. OUR ALLIANCES
INCLUDE THE BEAU BIDEN
FOUNDATION AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS CALIFORNIA. LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
L. A. COUNTY AMONG OTHERS. THEY
KNOW WE SEEK LONG OVERDUE
PROTECTION SO THAT KIDS AVOID
HARM TO CAMPS NATIONWIDE. WE
INTRODUCED OUR FIRST CAMP SAFETY
BILL IN TWENTY TWENTY.
OPPOSITION CAME FROM COUNTIES
AND COUNTY HEALTH LOBBY GROUPS
IN CAMP LOBBY GROUPS. ONE COUNTY
OPPOSITE OPPOSITION LETTER SAID
QUOTE OUR HEALTH DEPARTMENT IS
NOT EQUIPPED TO OVERSEE CHILD
SAFETY AND WELLBEING. THAT
COUNTY IS A TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR BUDGET FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
INCLUDING CHILD SAFETY. THESE
COUNTIES LOBBY GROUPS NO I'M NOT
EQUIPPED WITH MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. I'M NOT EQUIPPED WITH
THE FAMILY. AND YET I STOP AT
NOTHING TO PROTECT CHILDREN A
CAPS. THESE COUNTIES ESSENTIALLY
ADMITTED TO YOU THEY'RE NOT EVEN
A BITING THE WOEFULLY DEFICIENT
TWO THOUSAND AND NINE ORGANIZED
CAMP LAW. WHICH REQUIRES THEM TO
ENFORCE A FEW SIMPLE SAFETY
MEASURES. THIS ORGANIZED CAMP
LAW ALSO STATES THAT THE BOY
SCOUTS OF AMERICA IS CORDY TRUE
PROTOTYPE OF AN ORGANIZED CAMP.
YET WE KNOW THE BSA'S EXECUTED
THE WORST CHILD MOLESTATION
CAMPAIGN IN U. S. HISTORY USING
COUNTLESS CAPS. THIS IS FACTUAL
HARM. THEY'RE NOT ALONE. THERE'S
HARD LIKE THIRTEEN MOLESTATIONS
AT THE PAINTED TURTLE CAMP ARE
FOR SERIOUSLY ILL CHILDREN IN L.
A. COUNTY. ARE LIKE THE
MOLESTATIONS OF SIXTEEN GIRLS
UNDER EIGHT SEVEN AT THE FIRST
BAPTIST CHURCH CAMP IN SAN JOSE.
ARM RIGHT HERE IN THIS CITY WITH
RATES AT THE HOLY CATHOLIC
CHURCH CAMP PENDLETON. AND A
DEATH AT CAMP SACRAMENTO WHICH
COST TAXPAYERS FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS. I KNOW YOUNG PEOPLE WHO
DIED OR NEARLY DIED OF FOUR
DIFFERENT CAMPS FIFTEEN MINUTES
FROM MY HOUSE. THIS HARM THIS
KAMPAR PROCESS BECAUSE
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF ONLY TWELVE
STATES. THAT DOES NOT LICENSE
DAY CAMPS AND OUR RESEARCH SHOWS
THEY DO NOT COUNTIES DO NOT
AFFORD MEANINGFUL OVERSIGHT OF
OVERNIGHT CAMPS. CALIFORNIA
HIGHLY REGULATES DAY CARE
OPERATIONS WITH FINGER PAINTING
AND SINGALONGS. YET CALIFORNIA
CAMPS HAVE VERY YOUNG CHILDREN
SHOOTING LIVE ROUNDS FROM TWENTY
TWO CALIBER RIFLES AND BALANCING
ON ROPES A HUNDRED FEET HIGH
WITHOUT STATE REQUIREMENTS THAT
PROTECT THEM FROM HARM. THE
STATE DOES NOT REQUIRE
CERTIFICATION FOR CAMPS. TO
OPERATE THOSE HIGH RISK
ACTIVITIES OR REQUIRE BACKGROUND
CHECKS TO PREVENT MOLESTATIONS
OR EMERGENCY ACTION PLANS OR
TRAINED HEALTH SUPERVISORS OR
EVEN MEANINGFUL SAFETY
INSPECTIONS OR LICENSES. FOR
DECADES CAMP LOBBYISTS HAVE
CONVINCED US THERE'S NOTHING TO
WORRY ABOUT BUT DESPITE MY
NEARLY UPON BEARABLE SUFFERING
I'M HERE BECAUSE- MY SELF AND MY
FOUNDATION PROTECT MILLIONS OF
CHILDREN LIKE YOURS OF OUR-
FOUNDATION HAS NOW SUCCESSFULLY
PASSED THIS LEGISLATION. IN L.
A. COUNTY WITH TEN MILLION
RESIDENTS. I ASK THAT YOU JOIN
THEM. AND I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- YES IT THREE MINUTES THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MY NAME IS LILY
ANA CORONADO I SERVE ON THE
BOARD OF THEM YOUNG OUT
FOUNDATION THE FOUNDATION THAT
WAS ESTABLISHED IN HONOR OF
PROXY FORCE IN THIS PICTURE I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY SEVEN AND THANK
YOU TO ASSEMBLY MAN HOLDEN AND
HIS STAFF FOR HIS TIRELESS WORK
ON THIS ISSUE AND HIS
LEADERSHIP. FROM I'M ALSO OF THE
MOTHER OF TWO BOYS A FIVE YEAR
OLD AND AN EIGHT YEAR OLD. MY
EIGHT YEAR OLD WENT TO SCHOOLWITH ROXY. AND THAT IS HOW I
BECAME FRIENDS WITH DOG AND
ELENA- IT IS AN HONOR TO BE
HERE- WHEN ELENA. OBVIOUSLY
CANNOT BE HERE- SHE WAS A DEAR
FRIEND AND SO THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK. ON HER
BEHALF. AND IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. TO ME THIS LEGISLATION AS
THIS EMPLOYMENT SAID IT'S
COMMONSENSE BASIC SAFEGUARDS FOR
OUR CHILDREN. AS A PARENT IT IS
INCOMPREHENSIBLE HOW WE- DO NOT
REGULATE OR OVERSEE DAY CAMPS
BUT WE REGULATE AND OVERSEE
CHILD CARE FACILITIES WHEN MY
CHILDREN WERE INFANTS I REMEMBER
BEING ABLE TO GO TO THE DATABASE
THAT DSS AFFORD TO PARENTS TO
LOOK AT COMPLAINTS AND PRIOR
INCIDENTS OF- INJURY TO BE ABLE
TO EXAMINE AS A PARENT. IF THE
FACILITY WAS SAFE FOR MY CHILD
THAT WE CAN'T DO THAT FOR CAMPS
IS JUST NONSENSICAL AND THIS
BILL WOULD ALLOW PARENTS A LOT
MORE TRANSPARENCY AN OPPORTUNITY
TO DO THEIR OWN DUE DILIGENCE
ABOUT CAPS- IT DOESN'T SET A
CEILING IT REALLY SETS A FLOOR
IT REALLY IS THE MOST BASIC-
THAT WE CAN- WE CAN EXPECT FROM
THE INDIVIDUALS ENTRUSTED TO
CARE FOR CHILDREN WHEN MANY OF
US ARE WORKING. I'M I THINK ONE
THING I WANTED TO SAY AS WELL IS
THAT. WE DON'T REALLY KNOW MR
FORBES GAVE MANY EXAMPLES OF-
INJURY AND HARM INCLUDING WHAT
HAPPENED TO THEIR DAUGHTER- BUT
WE DON'T REALLY KNOW THE SCOPE
OF THE PROBLEM BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE- A DATABASE OR RECORD
KEEPING OR OVERSIGHT OR
REGISTRATION OR EVEN LICENSING
AND SO I THINK ONCE WE- DELVE
INTO THIS ISSUE WILL BE ABLE TO
SEE THAT THERE. THIS THE
MAGNITUDE IN THE SCOPE IS FAR
BEYOND WHAT WE WHAT WE WOULD
IMAGINE. AND SO- I WOULD ASK YOU
AND URGE YOU TO PLEASE SUPPORT
AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY SEVEN SO
THAT WE CAN DO EVERYTHING WE CAN
POSSIBLE TO PROTECT OUR MOST
PRECIOUS CHILDREN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL. PLEASE COME FORWARD
AND.
A MICROPHONE BUTTON THERE PLEASE
OUR- THANK YOU A GOOD AFTERNOON
TERM MEMBERS MICHELLE GIBBONS AT
THE COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
REPRESENT LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS THROUGHOUT OUR STATE
MORE HEARING RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL CHECK
FIRST WANTS TO COMMEND THE GOAL
THAT THE AUTHOR HAS TO CREATE AN
OVERSIGHT AND ENFORCEMENT
STRUCTURE FOR CHILDREN'S CAMPS
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE TO ENSURE
THE SAFETY AND WELL BEING OF
CHILDREN WHILE IN THEIR CARE.
WELL WE AGREE WITH THE SCHOOL.
WE MUST RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE
WITH HOW- THE BILL SEEKS TO
ACCOMPLISH THIS. THE COVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC DEMONSTRATED
WHY LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
EXIST THEY EXIST TO PROTECT
COMMUNITIES FROM PUBLIC HEALTH
THREATS INCLUDING BUT NOT
LIMITED TO INFECTIOUS DISEASES.
I AM AT RELATED ILLNESSES AND
CHRONIC DISEASES LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS DO NOT HAVE
EXPERTISE IN CHILD SUPERVISION
AND PLACING THE OVERSIGHT AND
ENFORCEMENT RESPONSIBILITY OF
CHILDREN'S CAMPS WITH LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS WILL FALL
SHORT OF THAT INTENDED GOAL AND
WILL NOT PROVIDE A SAFER
ENVIRONMENT FOR CHILDREN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER NAMED AREAS
WHERE HEALTH DEPARTMENTS ARE
FOCUSED IN AREAS WHERE WE ARE
DEFICIENT ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
THE FOCUS IS ON FOOD SAFETY IS
BECAUSE THAT'S AN AREA OF OUR
EXPERTISE THE CHILD SUPERVISION
IS NOT. WE'VE APPRECIATED THE
ENGAGEMENT WITH AUTHORS OFFICE
TO DATE WE CONTINUE TO ENCOURAGE
THE AUTHOR TO INSTEAD PLACE THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR CHILDREN'S
CAMPS WITH AN AGENCY WITH
APPROPRIATE X. EXPERTISE AND
OVERSIGHT OF ENTITIES WITH
CHILDREN IN THEIR CARE SUCH AS
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. CDSS CDSS HAS A
COMMUNITY CARE LICENSING
DIVISION THAT LICENSES VARIOUS
FACILITIES THAT PROVIDE CARE TO
CHILDREN INCLUDING CHILD CARE
FACILITIES IN FACT SOME
CHILDREN'S CAMPS SUCH AS YMCA
PROGRAMS ARE CURRENTLY LICENSED
BY CDSS AS CHILD CARE FACILITIES
YET THEY'VE SOUGHT LICENSURE IS
DAY CAMPS DURING SCHOOL BREAKS
FROM OTHER ENTITIES. CDSS HAS AN
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT CAN BE
EXPANDED UPON TO OVERSEE
CHILDREN'S CAMPS THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE CONSISTS OF THREE
MAIN COMPONENTS PER THEIR
WEBSITE PREVENTION COMPLIANCE
AND ENFORCEMENT. ACCORDING TO
CDSS THE PREVENTION THEY CAN
REDUCE PREDICTABLE HARM TO
CHILDREN BY PROVIDING AN
ORIENTATION PRIOR TO LICENSURE
PERFORMING BACKGROUND CHECKS
MAINTAINING STAFFING
REQUIREMENTS HEALTH SCREENINGS
PRE LICENSURE AND TRENDS AND
PROVIDING INFORMATION REGARDING
LAWS AND REGULATIONS. THEIR
COMPLIANCE CDSS INSURERS
CHILDCARE FACILITIES OPERATING
ACCORDANCE WITH EXISTING LAWS
AND ARE MADE AND MAINTAIN THAT
THROUGH AN ANNOUNCE FACILITY
INSPECTIONS COMPLAIN
INVESTIGATIONS ISSUING
DEFICIENCY NOTICES CONSULTATIONS
AND FURTHER. LASTLY ENFORCEMENT
ENFORCEMENT IS TAKEN WHEN AN
ENTITY FAILS TO PROTECT THE
HEALTH SAFETY AND PERSONAL
RIGHTS OF CHILDREN I WITHIN
THEIR CARE AND THEY CAN DO THIS
DO SO WILL. IN THE- LAW AND
LEGAL ACTIONS DENIALS OF
APPLICATIONS PROBATION
SUSPENSION REVOCATION OF A
LICENSE AND SO FORTH. THERE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS FAR MORE
SUITED TO PROTECT THE CHILDREN
AND THE SAFETY OF CHILDREN
ATTENDING DAY CAMPS WHERE IS OUR
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS INSTEAD
FOCUS ON PUBLIC HEALTH THREATS.
ARE HEALTH DEPARTMENTS WOULD BE
OPERATING OUTSIDE OF THEIR
EXPERTISE AND IN ADDITION WE
NEED TO. ACQUIRE A SIGNIFICANT
WORK FORCE AT A TIME WHEN PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS ARE ALREADY
LOSING STAFF DUE TO A LACK OF
ONGOING FUNDING AND EVEN MORE SO
DUE TO BURNOUT HARASSMENT. AND
THAT THREATS EXPERIENCED
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC. WE HAVE
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS ABOUT
EXPANDING THE HEALTH DEPARTMENT
RESPONSIBILITY BEYOND THE SCOPE.
AND WE JUST ASK THAT YOU PLEASE
PUT CHILDREN'S SAFETY FIRST AND
MAKE SURE THAT WE CREATE
OVERSIGHT STRUCTURE THAT CAN DO
THAT ACCORDINGLY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU X. WITH THIS PLACE. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ON KATHY
BURBANK AND I REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION FOR USE
AND I TO WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR HIS OFFICE HAS BEEN
EXTRAORDINARY. ACCOMPLISH YOUR
ACCOUNT TO ACCOMPLISH. SOMETHING
I SHOULDN'T DRINK LUNCH NO THAT
IS A GREAT OFFER. HE IS- TO WORK
WITH OUR ORGANIZATION TO TRY TO
RESOLVE SOME OF THESE ISSUES WE
HAVE BEEN OURSELVES INTERESTED
IN SEEING DAY CAMPS HAVE
OVERSIGHT AND IN FACT WE'VE
SPONSORED A NUMBER OF BILLS ONE
OF THEM VETOED BY THE PREVIOUS
GOVERNOR. THAT WOULD HAVE SET UP
A SYSTEM WHERE DAY CAMPS BE
REGISTERED WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND OVERSEEN BY
THEIR LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS.
ARE UNFORTUNATELY- WE HAVE A
LONG WAYS TO GO IN TERMS OF THIS
BILL UP BECAUSE THE BILL
CONTAINS A LOT OF ONEROUS
POSITION UP UP PROVISIONS WE
NEED TO CONTINUE OUR WORK WITH
THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE TO SEE IF WE
CAN ADDRESS THOSE. AND OUR
ORGANIZATION IS MADE UP OF THE
CHRISTIAN CAMPS THE INDEPENDENT
CAMPS THE AMERICAN CAMP
ASSOCIATION AND A LOT OF
TRADITIONAL YOUTH SERVING
ORGANIZATIONS WHO ALL WOULD LIKE
TO WORK ON THIS ISSUE BUT HAVE
NOT BEEN ABLE TO DO SO IN THE
FUTURE WE LIKE TO SEE. INPUT
FROM THE CAMPS TO MAKE THEM
STRONGER AND TO MAKE SURE THE
KIDS ARE SAFE THAT'S WHAT WE ALL
WANT AND THAT'S WHAT WE ALL ARE
WORKING TOWARDS SO APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR'S TIME ON THIS AND-
HAVE PLEDGED. TO CONTINUE
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE WITH HIM.
THANK YOU. I THINK THAT IN THIS
CASE WE I HOST WE HAVE SOME
TWEETERS OF WHAT WE CALL THEM SO
IF YOU'D LIKE TO. COME TO THE
MICROPHONE WILL ALLOW YOU TO
SPECIFY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
REALLY APPRECIATE THE COURTESY
I'M CHRISTINA TO CARL
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
LIBRARY ASSOCIATION. AND WE ARE
IN THAT- TWEENER POSITION WE
JUST HAVE SOME CONCERNS THAT
WE'VE CONVEYED TO THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND HIS STAFF. WE
APPRECIATE THE EXCELLENT
ANALYSIS THAT WAS DONE BY YOUR
CHIEF CONSULTANT ON THIS ISSUE
RAISING OUR POINTS. OF THE-CALIFORNIA LIBRARY ASSOCIATION
IS JUST CONCERNED THAT THE
DEFINITION OF CHILDREN'S CAMP IS
SO BROAD THAT IT MIGHT SWEEP IN
SOME OF THE SUMMER PROGRAMS THAT
WE'RE DOING AT THE PUBLIC
LIBRARIES ON SITE. THESE ARE
LASTING FIVE DAYS OR LONGER
SOMETIMES MULTIPLE WEEKS AND
SOMETIMES AN ENTIRE SUMMER THE
COULD BE ROBOTICS CAMPS COMPUTER
CODING CAMP SO WE CERTAINLY
DON'T HAVE THE HIGHER RISK
EVENTS. OF THAT THE SPONSORS ARE
TALKING ABOUT AND WE REALLY
WOULDN'T HAVE A NEED FOR A FULL
TIME HEALTH SUPERVISOR EITHER
SO. AS THE BILL MOVES FORWARD
AND WE HAVE GREAT RESPECT FOR
THE AUTHOR A WE KNOW WILL
CONTINUE THESE TALKS THAT WE
WOULD JUST RESPECTFULLY LIKE TO
CONSIDER. I HAVE THE COMMITTEE
CONSIDER MAY BE EXEMPTING PUBLIC
LIBRARIES FROM THE MEASURE THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANYONE ELSE. THIS WILL JUST ARE
YOU. A TWEENER ORI OR GIVE GIVE
A POSITION FOR OR AGAINST. AGAIN
SO THAT SO WILL BE JUST TAKING
YOUR NAME POSITION ORGANIZATION
COULD REPRESENT ONE. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I'M FARMING
DATING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. THANK
YOU. ANYONE ELSE. I THINK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS KERRY MCCARTHY
OF MY BESTS MY SON'S BEST FRIEND
WAS ROCKS THE FORMS AND OUR
FAMILY HAS BEEN DEVASTATED BY
HER LOSS I PLEASE URGE ALL OF
YOU TO VOTE YES ON THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. HELLO MY
NAME IS JOANNE VELVET OF IT. I'M
A MOTHER OF TWO- AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
ELVISH ARNETT I WAS ROXY'S
TEACHER. GOOD RIDDANCE EACH FOR.
A HOSPITAL. WHEN I TRIED TO GET
THROUGH THE- BECAUSE SHE WAS ON
LIFE SUPPORT. MELENDEZ WORDS
SHE'S GONE WE HAVE TO LET HER GO
. IS IT WOULD ALWAYS BE MY MIND
AND I DON'T WANT ANYBODY TO GO
THROUGH THIS AGAIN. MINESTRONE
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU FOR
. I AM JAMES THOSE ARE NOT THE
SON OF ELBOW DOES YOUR NET. I
SUPPORT. A AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN RESTRICTION
SHELTER ON BEHALF OF THE TULARE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON JESSICA THANK
US ON BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES I WOULD LIKE
TO RESPECTFULLY NOTE ARE
CONCERNED WITH THE SCOPE OF THE
BILL ON BEHALF OF OUR
ORGANIZATION. CAL CITIES SHARES
THE SAME GOALS AS THE AUTHOR AND
THAT THE SPONSORS OF THIS
MEASURE AND WE APPRECIATE- ANY
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH US TO
ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING. TO WORK
TOGETHER TO MAKE CHILDREN'S
CAMPS AND SAFE FOR EVERYONE
THANK YOU. IF YOU. ANYONE ELSE.
SEE NO ONE WE WILL- GO TO THE
PHONE LINES AB MISTRUST RAIDER
THESE WERE FOR ANYONE IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION TO THE BILL JUST
THEIR NAME POSITION ON THE BILL
AND ORGANIZATIONS THEY REPRESENT
ONE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO A B. SEVENTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN OF
ONE THEN ZERO. AND FIRST WE WILL
GO TO LINE. ONE HUNDRED THIRTY
EIGHT. LINE ONE THIRTY EIGHT
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. LINE.
FORTY SEVEN. BURKE TO HELP
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. THE LINE ONE OF.
FORTY SIX. HOW IT'S DONE. LINE
ONE FORTY SIX OR MY COULD OPEN.
NO THANK YOU. A LINE OF ONE
FORTY FIVE. MY NAME IS PETER
GABEL I LIVE IN SAN FRANCISCO
AND I'M A COMMUNITY MEMBER AND
ASSOCIATION WITH UNITED HERE
LOCAL TWO AND I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. LINE. ONE HUNDRED FORTY
TWO. THIS IS YOUR MEMBERS
MARKSMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA WATERFOWL ASSOCIATION
WITH A STRONG CONCERNS ABOUT THE
BILL LOOK FORWARD TO ENGAGING
WITH THE OTHERS OFFICE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
LINE. ONE HUNDRED FORTY ONE.
HAIRY CAT I'LL BE HAPPY TO RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. LINE ONE HUNDRED THIRTY
THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON JOSH
DUGGAR ON BEHALF OF THE URBAN
COUNTIES TO CALIFORNIA IN THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS UC
RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND SANTA CLARA
COUNTY IN RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
AND MISTER CHAIR THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME. I
THINK YOU WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE. IN
NONE- YOU KNOW WE DON'T HAVE A
QUORUM WE DON'T WE CAN'T
ENTERTAIN A MOTION- THE BILL
DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. MISTER HOLDEN-
AND IF THE OPPORTUNITY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER SORRY DID YOU
HAVE COME IN MISTER MCCARTY. IN
ON WHAT. YEAH THESE ARE ALL
HEARTBREAKING STORIES AND ONE OF
MY FROM I KNOW QUITE FAMILIAR
THERE'S A YOUNG GIRL WHO. HE
DIED- THAT THEY CAN'T SACRAMENTO
ONE OF THE WITNESSES FOR THE
TEST WE TALKED ABOUT THAT AND-
YOU CAN'T BRING THESE PEOPLE
BACK BUT GOING FORWARD HAVING
APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT. IS KEY
AND I KNOW THE YOU'LL FIND THE
RIGHT BALANCE MR HOLDEN IN THE
NETWORK ON THIS AND THANK YOU
FOR PUSHING THIS FOR. THANK YOU
MR MCCARTY ANYONE ELSE. OKAY YOU
MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR HI. A FIRST OF ALL I WANT
TO THANK YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR
. ANALYSIS THAT I THINK GIVES US
SOME IMPORTANT FOOD FOR THOUGHT
AND HOW WE CAN- BRING TOGETHER
SOME OF THE IMPORTANT ISSUES
THAT HAVE BEEN ARTICULATED NOT
JUSTIN. ADDRESSING THOSE OF
OPPOSITION OR- CONCERN- BUT
THOSE ELEMENTS OF THIS ANALYSIS
THAT RECOGNIZES THE NEED FOR ON
OVERSIGHT STRUCTURE THAT IS MUCH
MORE. PROFOUND THAN WHAT EXISTS
CURRENTLY- I WILL ALSO SAY THAT-
LOOK FORBES MY VIEW IS SHOWN A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF COURAGE. I
I'M NOT SURE I COULD HAVE DONE
WHAT HE'S DONE HERE TODAY-
HAVING LOST TWO VERY IMPORTANT.
MEMBERS OF HIS FAMILY. BUT I
THINK IT IS ALSO A TESTAMENT TO
SAY THAT LIFE DOES GO ON. AND IT
IS IMPERATIVE THAT WE- FIGHT FOR
THE CHANGES THAT WE THINK ARE
IMPORTANT THE C. IMPLEMENTED.
AND I'M HEARTENED- THAT EVERYONE
WHO SPOKE WITHIN SUPPORTER.
CONCERNS I RECOGNIZE THE NEED
FOR SOME CHANGE. AND THAT WE
NEED TO. TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY.
AND EMBRACE THIS MOMENT IN THIS
FAMILY THIS INDIVIDUALS PAYING
AND CHANNEL THAT TO SOMETHING
THAT I THINK WILL CREATE
MEANINGFUL AND SUSTAINABLE.
GUIDELINES THERE WILL BE IN
PLACE SO THAT NO FUTURE. CAN'T
PREDICT THE FUTURE. BUT TO THE
EXTENT THAT WE ARE THEN CHECKING
THE BOXES BY THINGS THAT ARE
CLEARLY RIGHT NOW THE
UNREGULATED. AND CIRCUMSTANCES
AND SITUATIONS WHERE YOUNG
CHILDREN A DAY CAMP. OUT OF THE
PARIS CONTROL. OUR ENVIRONMENTS
THAT QUITE FRANKLY WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT CAN HAPPEN. WHILE THEY'RE
IN THAT ENVIRONMENT. I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH ALL
CONCERNED INCLUDING. A YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND YOUR STAFF. WE
WILL CERTAINLY SIT DOWN AND ROLL
UP OUR SLEEVES AND WITH GREAT
EARNEST AND DEDICATION.
SOMETHING THAT I THINK WILL BE
RESPECTFUL. OF WHAT NEEDS TO
HAPPEN RESPONSIVE- BUT ALSO
MAKING SURE THAT WHAT WE DO PUT
IN PLACE AS THE RIGHT KIND OF.
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE CAN WALK
AWAY FROM AND FEEL THAT IT IS
GOING TO DO WHAT IT'S INTENDED
TO DO. IT IS NOT JUST PUTTING
SOMETHING IN A BILL AND SAYING
WELL. LET'S HOPE IT WORKS. IT'S
AN AGENCY NAME. AND THEN WE HOPE
IT WORKS. WE WANT MORE THAN HOPE
IT WORKS. WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WHAT WE DO HAVE. SOMETHING
THAT WILL PROTECT. AND THAT WILL
BE A SAFEGUARD AGAINST. THE
KINDS OF. TRAGEDIES THAT WERE
PART OF THE PRESENTATION TODAY
AND CERTAINLY. MY CONSTITUENT.
DOUG AND HIS FAMILY WHAT KIND OF
PAYMENT HAD TO GO THROUGH. SO I
THINK YOU AND AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. THE COMMITTEE HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ENTERTAIN A
MOTION- I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR- A VERY MUCH MR HOLDEN
THANK YOU TO YOUR WITNESSES.
SHOULD. THIS GARCIA. AB TWENTY
THREE TWENTY. GOOD AFTERNOON I'M
MISTER CHEN MEMBERS THAN HERE
PERCENT AB TWENTY THREE THIRTY
WHICH WILL ESTABLISH A PILOT
PROGRAM FOR FIVE COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA TO SUPPORT CAPACITY
BUILDING FOR COMMUNITY HEALTH
CENTERS PROVIDING REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE SERVICES. THE BILL
ISUNLIKE ANY OTHER BECAUSE THAT
PUTS IT PUTS THE EXPERTS
CLINICIANS AND CLIENT FACING
STAFF IN THE DRIVER'S SEAT OF
CHANGE TO DEVELOP PRACTICES THAT
ARE RESPONSIVE TO THE SPECIFIC
NEEDS OF THE CLIENT POPULATIONS
. ACCORDING TO THE AMERICAN
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION WOMEN OF
COLOR LGBTQ PLUS LOW INCOME
RURAL IMMIGRANT. AND PEOPLE WITH
LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENCY.
FACE SOME OF THE HIGHEST WITH IN
NEARLY EVERY ASPECT OF.
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
PATIENTS ARE MOST CERTAINLY
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES
EXPERIENCE HIGHER RATES OF
MATERNAL MORTALITY THERE WILL
CANCER MORTALITY STI INFECTIONS
AND ACCESS TO SERVICES AND
EDUCATION. THE KAISER FAMILY
FOUNDATION STUDY CONDUCTED INTO
OUR COUNTY FOUND THAT CULTURAL
STIGMA AND ADEQUATE
INTERPRETATION SERVICES AND THEY
NOT MAKES OF DOMESTIC ABUSE
INPATIENT RELATIONSHIP BECAUSE
SOME OF THE BIGGEST BARRIERS TO
PATIENTS. LENNIX STAFF
UNDERSTAND THAT THEIR PATIENTS
INTERSECTING IDENTITIES IMPACT
CARE BUT DON'T HAVE THE FUNDING
OR SUPPORT TO ADEQUATELY RESPOND
. CALIFORNIA IS THE MOST
POPULOUS AND MOST EVERY STATE IN
THE US THE COMMUNITY HEALTH
CENTERS UNIQUELY POISED TO
IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF CARE IN
THE COMMUNITIES THEY SERVE.
BECAUSE OF THIS DIVERSITY. THERE
IS NO ONE SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH
PROVIDING REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE. WITH TEXAS AND REACHED
THEM BAN ON ABORTIONS AND
IMPENDING SUPREME COURT DECISION
THAT WOULD EFFECTIVELY REPEAL
ROE VERSUS WADE THE FUTURE OF
REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS HANGS IN THE
BALANCE AND NEVER BEFORE.
PROJECTIONS BY THE GUTMACHER
INSTITUTE INDICATE THAT
CALIFORNIA COULD SEE AN
ESTIMATED ONE POINT THREE
MILLION PEOPLE TRAVELING FROM
OUT OF STATE TO SEEK
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE.
CALIFORNIA HAS COMMITTED ITSELF
TO BECOMING A REPRODUCTIVE
FREEDOM STATE A PERSISTING GAPS
IN SERVICE IN CHRONIC UNDER
RESOURCING OF OUR COMMUNITY
HEALTH CLINICS CONTINUE TO BRING
IN PATIENTS AND PROVIDERS HERE
IN THE STATE. WITH ME HERE TO
TESTIFY TODAY IS JUST POOREST
THE FORMER WOMEN'S FOUNDATION
PHILLIES POLICY INSTITUTE
ALUMNI. ENGINE NAME SERGEANT
WOMEN'S FOUNDATION STUDIES
POLICY INSTITUTE READING THE
FELLOW. THEY MET I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FROM ABLE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH PLEASE GO AHEAD WHEN YOU'RE
READY. PUSH THE BUTTON THERE SO
ALL RIGHT. ITS EXAM EXCEPT IT'S
NOT. THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBER WOULD AND HEALTH
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JUST R. AS I USE THEY THEM
PRONOUNS I AM CURRENTLY THE
ARTISAN RELATIONS MANAGER AT THE
LITTLE MARKET I BRING FIFTEEN
YEARS OF DEDICATION TO COMMUNITY
BUILDING IN THE ANTI TRAFFICKING
ANTI. CENTER BASED VIOLENCE
MOVEMENTS I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY THE
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CLINIC
INITIATIVE FOR INITIATIVE FOR
INNOVATIVE CARE PILOT PROGRAM. I
AM ALSO IS ALWAYS POLICY
INSTITUTE ALARMS SUCCESSFULLY
PASSING MULTIPLE BILLS THAT
SUPPORT CHILDREN IN FOSTER CARE
AND SURVIVORS OF SEX
TRAFFICKING. I WOULD LIKE TO USE
THIS TIME TO CREATE A SHARED
UNDERSTANDING ABOUT THE ABUSE
CONTINUUM'S OF POVERTY GENDER
BASED VIOLENCE HOMELESSNESS
PHYSICAL AND MENTAL ILLNESS THE
PREGNANT PEOPLE IN MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES FACE. WHEN I WAS A
TEENAGER I BEGAN IDENTIFYING AS
QUEER MY MOTHER OUTRIGHT
REJECTED ME AND I BECAME AND
HOUSE PORTABLE ALONE AND GROOMED
I WAS RECRUITED BY APPEAR WITH
THE PROMISE OF FOOD AND SHELTER
AND THEN WAS MERCILESSLY SEX
TRAFFICKED FOR THREE YEARS.
EVENTUALLY A MAN THREE TIMES MY
AGE AGREED TO HOUSE ME IF I
AGREED TO BE HIS GIRLFRIEND
UNFORTUNATELY THIS IS THIS ONLY
LED TO SIX YEARS OF VIOLENT
TORTURE- BUT ALSO CHILD WITH
THIS MAN. AS MUCH AS THE FATHER.
AT THE AGE OF TWENTY THREE AND A
LIFETIME OF DEBILITATING
CIRCUMSTANCES I WAS NOW PREGNANT
WITHOUT INSURANCE AND DURING
SEVERE. INTIMATE PARTNER
VIOLENCE. I DISCOVERED A
COMMUNITY HEALTH CLINIC
PROVIDING ACCESS TO REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE SERVICES FOR LOW
INCOME INDIVIDUALS WITH A
SLIDING SCALE OPTION. THIS
MIRACLE PROVIDED FEASIBLE ACCESS
TO HEALTH CARE AND RELIEF FOR MY
LIFELONG FEAR OF PUBLIC CHARGE
AND POSSIBLE DEPORTATION. WHEN I
MET WITH. DESPITE LIVING HERE
SINCE I WAS TWENTY YEARS OLD.
WHEN I MET WITH MY NURSE AN
OBGYN FOR THE FIRST TIME I WAS
ENCOURAGED TO CARRY MY PREGNANCY
TO TERM WITHOUT DISCUSSION OF
ANY OTHER ALTERNATIVES AND GIVEN
STANDARDIZED INFORMATION ON WHAT
TO EXPECT. IN THE COMING MONTHS
I WAS SO APPRECIATIVE OF THE
SERVICE AND OF ITSELF THAT I
EXPECTED NOTHING MORE AND WOULD
HAVE SETTLED FOR MUCH LESS. MY
PARTNER MONITORED ALMOST EVERY
APPOINTMENT HE OFTEN SCREAM TO
BE LITTLE ME IN FRONT OF STAFF-
WHILE THE STAFF PRESENT AND IN
THE EXAM ROOM AND ON WHAT MORE
THAN ONE OCCASION LASHED OUT AT
PROVIDERS THEMSELVES. OUTSIDE OF
MY PARTNER'S FAMILY THESE
CLINICIANS WERE THE ONLY OTHER
PEOPLE WITH WHOM I INTERFACE.
HOWEVER BEYOND CHECKING MY
VITALS AND THE FETAL HEART RATE
NOTHING MORE WAS SAID DONE OR
OFFERED. LOOKING BACK NOW I CAN
RECALL DESPERATELY WISHING
SOMEONE ANYONE WOULD HAVE ASKED
ME ARE YOU SAFE. ARE YOU OKAY IS
THERE ANYTHING ELSE WE MIGHT BE
ABLE TO HELP YOU WITH. I'M
ESPECIALLY ON THE RARE OCCASION
WHEN I WAS ALONE AND VISIBLY
BATTERED- MONTHS AFTER MY CHILD
WAS BORN I FINALLY CAME TO
REALIZE THAT THOUGH I MAY HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO EXCUSE OR ACCEPT
ABUSE MY PERSONAL NORM I COULD
NOT AND WOULD NOT ALLOW THIS TO
BE MY CHILD'S REALITY. AND DO MY
OWN AND YIELDING AND DESPERATE
SEARCHING HAS FINALLY CONNECTED
TO AN ORGANIZATION SERVING
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKING SURVIVORS THIS WAS A
PIVOTAL TURNING POINT IN MY
LIFE. WHAT I WOULD LIKE YOU ALL
TO TAKE AWAY FROM MY STORY AND I
THE MISSED OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS I
VISITED TO HELP ME HOW MYSELF.
HOW DRUMMOND FORMED REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE TRAINING COULD HAVE
HELPED SCREENING FOR ABUSE
SCHERING. MORE OPTIONS THAN JUST
CARRYING A PREGNANCY TO TERM
PROVIDING PERSONALIZED
INFORMATION CARE FOR SOMEONE IN
MY UNIQUE SITUATION I'M AN
IMMIGRANT WITH THEIR OWN PARENTS
SURVIVING. SURVIVING A LOT AND
NOT JUST THE STANDARD INFO HOW
CASE MANAGEMENT SERVICES KIND OF
HELPED ME CONNECT TO LIFESAVING
ORGANIZATIONS MUCH EARLIER IN MY
JOURNEY AND I WOULD NOT HAVE TO
JUGGLE ALL THIS ON MY OWN AS A
NEW MOM. HOW INCREASE LANGUAGE
SERVICES ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE
WHOSE LANGUAGE NEEDS. DO NOT
MEET LANGUAGE THRESHOLD COULD
HAVE HELPED OTHERS. REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE CLINIC INITIATIVE
FOR AN- INITIATIVE FOR
INNOVATIVE CARE PILOT PROGRAM
SEEKS TO ADDRESS THESE GAPS IN
COMMUNITY HEALTH CLINIC
SETTINGS. AND HAS A
TRANSFORMATIVE CAPACITY TO TRAIN
PROVIDERS IDENTIFICATION.
EXPENSE OF REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE
CULTURAL EMPATHY COMMON FORM
CARE SUPPORT TO PROVIDE
WRAPAROUND CARE AND CASE
MANAGEMENT. AS WELL AS TREND
TRANSLATION SERVICES FOR THOSE
WHO ARE CURRENTLY STRUGGLING TO
ADVOCATE FOR THE CARE THEY NEED.
AND WANT. GRADING MODELS FOR
OTHER CLINICS FACING THE SAME
LIMITATIONS TO THE STATE AND
GETTING ALL PREGNANT PEOPLE THE
HEALTH CARE THEY DESERVE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO VOTE I
ON AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBER
WOULD AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS GINNY SERGEANTS AND I
WILL BE READING A STATEMENT ON
BEHALF OF DOCTOR DERREN ALLARD A
FAMILY MEDICINE PHYSICIAN IN SAN
LUIS OBISPO COUNTY. MY NAME IS
DOCTOR DERREN ALLARD AND I AM A
FAMILY MEDICINE PHYSICIAN IN
SANTA MARIA CALIFORNIA. FOR THE
PAST THREE YEARS I HAVE PROVIDED
COMPREHENSIVE PRIMARY CARE
SERVICES INCLUDING BIRTH CONTROL
COUNSELING STI SCREENING AND
TREATMENT PRENATAL CARE AND
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH EDUCATION TO
THIS UNDERSERVED CENTRAL COAST
COMMUNITY AND HOSPITALS
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS. MOBILE
HEALTH UNITS AND FREE CLINICS.
ALTHOUGH THE KOBE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC PUT A SPOTLIGHT ON
DISPARITIES IN ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE AND BROUGHT THE TERM SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS TO HEALTH INTO THE
PUBLIC LEXICON THESE CONCEPTS
ARE NOT NEW. FOR YEARS
INDIVIDUALS WITH LIMITED ENGLISH
PROFICIENCY LGBTQ PEOPLE
IMMIGRANTS PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HELPLESSNESS AND PEOPLE OF COLOR
HAVE SHORTER LIFE EXPECTANCIES
HIGHER INFANT MORTALITY RATES
HIGHER RATES OF UNTREATED STIS
AND POOR OUTCOMES WITH THEIR
CHRONIC MEDICAL CONDITIONS.
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS HAVE
ALWAYS BEEN THE SAFETY NETS OF
OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM FILLING A
CRITICAL VOID WERE UNINSURED AND
UNDERINSURED INDIVIDUALS MANY OF
WHOM FALL INTO THE CATEGORIES I
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED CAN GAIN
ACCESS TO PRIMARY CARE AND
SPECIALTY HEALTH SERVICES THAT
MOST OF US TAKE FOR GRANTED.
UNFORTUNATELY DESPITE THEIR BEST
INTENTIONS THE RESOURCES
PROVIDED BY THE C. H. SEES ARE
LIMITED BY FINANCES. IN PERSON
INTERPRETING SERVICES ARE COSTLY
AND OFTEN NOT AVAILABLE AND
PATIENTS AND PROVIDERS ARE
FORCED TO WAIT ON HOLD FOR
MINUTES WHILE TELL INTERPRETERS
ARE CONTACTED. CUTTING INTO THE
ALREADY SHORT APPOINTMENT TIME.
REMOTE INTERPRETERS OFTEN MISS
COMMUNITY LINK OFTEN MISS BODY
LANGUAGE OR NON VERBAL CUES THAT
ARE CRUCIAL TO PATIENT PROVIDER
RELATIONSHIPS. PARTNERSHIPS WITH
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
ARE OFTEN DRIVEN BY INDIVIDUALS
RATHER THAN SYSTEMS AND DISSOLVE
WITH HIGH STAFF TURNOVER. IN THE
ABSENCE OF FORMAL TRAINING ON
TRAUMA INFORMED CARE VICTIMS OF
PAST OR PRESENT DRAMATIC
EXPERIENCES LIKE SEXUAL ASSAULT
INTIMATE PARTNER VIOLENCE OR
HUMAN TRAFFICKING CAN
INADVERTENTLY BECOME RE
TRAUMATIZED MAKING IT LESS
LIKELY FOR THEM TO SEEK CARE AT
A CLINIC OR THE HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM IN GENERAL. AB TWENTY
THREE TWENTY WOULD ALLOW C. H.
SEIZE TO INVEST IN THE NEEDS OF
THEIR PATIENTSAND IMPROVE
HEALTH CARE FOR PEOPLE FROM
HISTORICALLY MARGINALIZED
GROUPS. IF THE PANDEMIC HAS
TAUGHT US ANYTHING IT IS THAT
THE HEALTH OF A COMMUNITY
DEPENDS ON THE HEALTH OF EVERY
INDIVIDUAL REGARDLESS OF THEIR
INCOME LEVEL SKIN COLOR CULTURAL
HERITAGE GENDER OR SEXUAL
ORIENTATION. FOR THESE REASONS I
URGE YOU TO VOTE AYE ON AB
TWENTY THREE TWENTY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. C.
KNOWN TO GO TO THE AUDIENCE- IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION AND WE'RE JUST ASKING
FOR NAME AND POSITION IN
ORGANIZATIONAL MESS. AFTERNOON
MOLLY ROBSON WITH PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES OF
CALIFORNIA WERE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. MICHELLE GIVENS AT THE
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK YOU. RIGHT SPEND
SOME HAPPY AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
OBGYN IS DISTRICT NINE IN
SUPPORT IF. THIS IS YOUR AND
MEMBERS BRANDON MARCH WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE. THE KNOWN WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES- THIS MISTRUST
RAIDER- JUST. SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION- JUST NAME POSITION
AND ORGANIZATION IF YOU
REPRESENT ONE. IF YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO A. B. TWENTY THREE
TWENTY PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN ONE
ZERO IN FIRST WE WILL GO TO LINE
ONE HUNDRED FIFTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO HELLO WE CAN
HEAR YOU. YES I AM LEADERS
SIERRA I WORK FOR THE CHAPLAIN
IN A COALITION I'M A PEER
SUPPORT NAVIGATOR AND I'M IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTY TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY ONE. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. LINE. FORTY NINE.
HI I DO HAVE TO TEACH IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. A LINE ELEVEN. THANK YOU
CHAIR- SUCH A COMPELLING WOULD
CALIFORNIA'S ONLY A PORTION FUND
ACCESS REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE AND
WE ARE ABLE TO PUT IT AB TWENTY
THREE TWENTY THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE
TWENTY ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON
REBECCA GONZALEZ WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT OF TWENTY THREE TWENTY.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
LINE ONE HUNDRED SIXTY ONE. HI
MY NAME IS LISA MARIE FOR
VIOLENCE AND I'M FROM CHARITY
NOW COALITION- LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AND I SUPPORT IT A. B.
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY ONE. THANK
YOU. I KNOW ONE HUNDRED SIXTY
TWO. ONE ONE HUNDRED SIXTY TWO
YEAR MIKE IS OPEN. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS ON YOUR MOBILE
GALLAGHER GLASGOW INFORMED
ACTION PROJECT CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY THREE
TWENTY THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. WHY NOT ONE
HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR. HELLO MY
NAME IS ROBERT BYRD AND A
CITIZEN OF THE ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
NINETEEN. AND ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY THREE TWENTY EIGHT ONCE
MY SUPPORT YES IT'S CALLED THE
PORT A LECTIN INDUCED ABORTION
IS REMOVED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WELL NOT ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY NINE. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CONSERVE ERIN I'VE BEEN
CALLING IN SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF
NARAL PRO CHOICE CALIFORNIA AS
WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
MIDWIVES ASSOCIATION THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
ALAINA FIFTY ONE. HELLO CLEAR
LOOK SHOCKED WITH THE NATIONAL
COUNCIL OF JEWISH WOMEN ON THE
COURT A TWENTY THREE TWENTY. Q.
X. COLOR PLEASE. THE LINE AT ONE
HUNDRED SIXTY SEVEN. HI MY NAME
IS NOT SHE'S GONNA BAKER AT AND
I'M THE SENIOR POLICY ADVOCATE
AT FAMILY VIOLENCE LAWCENTER IN
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA AND I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY THREE TWENTY THANK YOU.
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ALIGNER. ONE SIXTY FIVE. ONE ONE SIXTY
FIVE- MY COULD OPEN. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES YES WE CAN HEAR
YOU. HI THIS IS JEANINE EREKAT
WITH THE PARTNERSHIP FOR
ADVANCEMENT OF NEW AMERICANS IN
SAN DIEGO AND I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
THREE TWENTY. THE Q. X. COLOR
PINK. MISTER CHAIR THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL BRING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THE NUN WILL- THAT THE BILL DOES
ENJOY DO PASS RECOMMENDATION WE
DON'T HAVE A QUORUM WE HAVEN'T
HAD A QUORUM ALL DAY- BUT WE
HELP HAVE A QUORUM AT SOME
POINT. WHICH CASE BIG
ENTERTAINMENT XIN. LIKE CLOSE.
YES I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
2% I WANT TO. THANK YES FOR
THEIR FOR SHARING THEIR STORY
WITH US AT TWO DAY- AND
INFORMING THIS BILL THE REALITY
IS THAT. ONE THIRTY IS TOO MANY
BUT HURST AT THEIR STORY IS NOT
UNIQUE. OUT THERE AND SO HAPPY
TO WORK ON THIS THE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS IS WORKING THAT THE
DEMOCRATIC WOMEN'S CAUCUS
WORKING ON A REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE PACKAGE. OUR LOOKING AT
OUR MOST MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES- EQUITY IS A PIECE
THAT I'M LEADING ON IS ONE OF
FIVE A NUMBER OF PIECES THAT I'M
WORKING ON ALL YOU NEED AND I DO
WANNA TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY AS
I'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS
PACKAGE AROUND EQUITY I'VE BEEN
ASK ARE THESE BILLS ARE DOING
ALL DOING THE SAME THING IN THE
BILL OF ALL THE DIFFERENT THING
EXCEPT THAT THEY ALL ADDRESS
EQUITY IN DIFFERENT WAYS AND
IT'S NOT A ONE AND THEN HAVE TO
DEAL WITH SO IF I COME BEFORE
YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
FOR THAT. I DO APPRECIATE THE
SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE WHEN APPROPRIATE
AND JUSTICE BE SURE ARE YOU
YOU'RE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS YES THANK YOU OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU TO
YOUR WITNESSES. MR LACKEY.
WELL THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THIS WHAT APPEARS TO
BE SUPER SUB COMMITTEE- THE
CHANCE TO OF FOR ME TO PRESENT
AB AT TWENTY FIFTY THREE. THANK
YOU ALSO TO THE COMMITTEE STAFF
ESPECIALLY MISS JUDY BABCOCK FOR
WORKING AND REFINING AND HELP IN
THIS BILL TO BECOME BETTER. SO
WE TRULY DO ACCEPT AND
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS. DURING MY
TIME AS A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL. I'VE
SEEN THE POTENTIAL POSITIVE
IMPACT THE FIFTY ONE FIFTY HOLDS
CAN HAVE ON CALIFORNIANS. AND
HOW THEY ACTUALLY HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO CHANGE LIVES FOR
THE BETTER POSSIBLY EVEN SAVE A
LIFE. UNFORTUNATELY WE'VE NOT
SEEN MUCH WORK TO IMPROVE THESE
HOLDS SINCE THE PASSAGE OF THE
LANTERN ACT. WE'VE SEEN SOME OF
THE NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES
HOWEVER- AS A RESULT OF THE LACK
OF MENTAL HEALTH INTERVENTION AS
WE LOOK AROUND AND SEE THE
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. PROTECCI SOME OF
OUR MOST VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS
BY ENSURING THE FIFTY ONE FIFTY
HOLDS ARE UNIFORMLY APPLIED IS A
KEY STEP TOWARD ADDRESSING AND
ADVOCATING FOR GRAVELY DISABLED
POPULATION. WE SEE THAT MANY
CALIFORNIANS ARE SUFFERING AND
NOT GETTING THE HELP THAT THEY
NEED. MY BILL I BELIEVE WILL
ACTUALLY HELP RESOLVE SOME OF
THE PROBLEMS. BY INCLUDING
STAKEHOLDERS FROM VARIED
DISCIPLINES OF MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS. SO THAT WE CAN
GATHER AND ENSURE THAT WE APPLY
THE AND THE LANTERN ANAK FAIRLY
ACROSS THE STATE. WE'RE
COLLUDING SUCH GROUPS AS THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES HELLBOY IS.
DISABILITY RIGHTS OF CALIFORNIA
AND EVEN MORE. OCCLUDING
MULTIPLE STAKEHOLDERS IN THIS
PROCESS WILL ENSURE THAT WE'RE
ABLE TO BEST SERVE THOSE MEMBERS
OF OUR COMMUNITY WHO ARE IN
DESPERATE NEED OF HELP. LET'S
TAKE THIS STEP TOGETHER AND I
HOPE THAT- YOU'LL SUPPORT THIS
BILL ALLOW THAT TO HAPPEN I LIKE
TO INTRODUCE. A MAT GALLAGHER
WHO IS AN ATTORNEY FOR CALAVERAS
IS A NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION THAT
ADVOCATES FOR THOSE WITH MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES. THE CHRIS ROCKY
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY SIR. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME
IS MATT GALLAGHER I WORK AT CAL
VOICES AND WE REPRESENT
INDIVIDUALS WHO RECEIVE SERVICES
IN CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM. SIMPLY PUT AN
INDIVIDUAL IS PLACED ON LPS
HOLDER CONSERVATORSHIP ODDS ARE
WE PROVIDE SERVICES TO THE- WE
SUPPORT AB TWENTY FIFTY THREE
WITH COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS.
BECAUSE IT WILL IMPROVE THE LPS
ACT. WE KNOW BASED UPON THE
AUDITOR'S REPORT IN THE WORK
THIS COMMITTEE IS DONE. AT THE
LPS THAT ACT IS NOT BEING.
APPLIED CONSISTENCY WITHIN ALL
CONSISTENTLY WITHIN ALL OF
CALIFORNIA'S COUNTIES. WE KNOW
WHAT WHAT IS HAPPENING IS NOT
WORKING IN THIS BILL SEEKS TO
IMPROVE THAT. BY BRINGING
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS TOGETHER
TO DEVELOP GUIDELINES TO LOOKING
GRAVELY DISABLED WHO IS A THREAT
TO THEMSELVES OR OTHERS AND IT.
IMPLEMENTING VARIOUS OTHER
MEASURES TO IMPROVE THE LPS ACT.
WE BELIEVE THAT WE CAN GO
FORWARD BETTER TOGETHER. WITH
THAT SAID WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
pI VOTE WHEN THE TIME IS
APPROPRIATE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. C. NONE WILL GO TO THE
AUDIENCE ANYONE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. OR YOU KNOW WHEN WE
GO TO THE PHONE LINES OF
MISTRUST RATED SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION- JUST NAME POSITION
ORGANIZATION TO REPRESENT ONE.
FOUR COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO THAT COMMAND AGAIN ONE THEN
ZERO. AND MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
NO COMMENT AT THE TIME WELL
THANK YOU RING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. MISS WALDRON. WANT TO
THANK MR LACKEY FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD IS A VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE WE KNOW THAT. IN
CALIFORNIA WHEN IT COMES TO
TREATMENT FOR SEVERE MENTAL
ILLNESS IT'S PRETTY FRAGMENTED
SYSTEM. AND THIS WILL BRING SOME
UNIFORMITY WHICH WE NEED- SO I'M
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL WHEN
WE HAVE A CHANCE. VERY WELL AS
YOU KNOW WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM
I THINK I'VE BEEN SAYING THAT
ALL DAY SO. THAT HASN'T CHANGED-
THE BILL DOES ENJOY A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION MR LACKEY WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE JUST REAL
BRIEFLY I WOULD JUST TELL YOU
THAT. I'VE HAD PERSONAL
EXPERIENCES WITH THIS- FIFTY ONE
FIFTY. INTERPRETATION THAT WE
HAVE RIGHT NOW AND IT'S
UNFORTUNATE THAT ACTUALLY ARE
MENTAL HEALTH. PROVIDER SYSTEM
RELIES ON A LOT OF THIS FIFTY
ONE FIFTY. ONE FORSMAN. BECOMES
OUR MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSION AND
IT'S NOT FAIR IT'S NOT RIGHT.
AND WE NEED TO STEP FORWARD AND
ACTUALLY DO IT IN A MORE
MEANINGFUL. AND UNITARIANS WAY.
SO WE BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL IS
NOT THE FIX ALL. BUT IT BUT IT
IS ACTUALLY A STEP IN THE IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION REALLY THIS CALL
FOR THIS TIME SO. WE APPRECIATE
THE AYE VOTE WHEN THE
OPPORTUNITY COMES. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR LOOKING THANK YOU
TO WITNESS THANK YOU. THEN WE
DON'T HAVE OTHER AUTHORS PRESENT
MR RODRIGUEZ ARE YOU PREPARED TO
PRESENT YOUR BILL. THESE.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY SIR THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS. THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT
AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY WHICH WOULD
REQUIRE CERTAIN PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE BUILDINGS CONSTRUCTED
AFTER JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO TO INSTALL AND
MAINTAIN SIX TRAUMA KITS ON
THEIR PREMISES IN ORDER TO TREAT
PEOPLE IN NEED OF EMERGENCY
MEDICAL CARE. DURING A DRAMATIC
EMERGENCY EVENT. RESPONSE TO THE
TRAGIC MASS SHOOTING AT SANDY
HOOK ELEMENTARY SCHOOL A GROUP
OF DOCTORS CONVENE A PANEL OF
NATIONAL EXPERTS. FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES TO CREATE
IMPROVED RESPONSE SYSTEM
DIRECTED PRIMARILY AT THE
CONTROL OF LIFE THREATENING
BLOOD LOSS. IN THEIR
RECOMMENDATIONS THE GROUP OF
EXPERTS CONCLUDED THAT
BYSTANDERS IMMEDIATE RESPONDER
SHOULD BE TRAINED AND EMPOWERED
TO STOP HEMORRHAGE IN ORDER TO
SAVE LIVES. THESE EXPERTS ALSO
RECOMMEND A TRUMP COULD BE
PLACED IN PUBLIC PLACES SUCH AS
SHOPPING MALLS SCHOOLS SPORTS
VENUES. TRANSPORTATION CENTERS
ETCETERA NEXT TO E. D.
RECOGNIZING THE FULL THE
DIFFICULT TO MAINTAIN DIRECT
PRESSURE THEY ALSO RECOMMENDED
THE USE OF TOURNIQUETS TO
CONTROL SEVERE BLEEDING. WITH
MASS CASUALTY EVENTS BECOMING
MORE COMMON IN TWENTY FIFTEEN
PRESIDENT OBAMA LAUNCHED STOP
THE BLEED CAMPAIGN TO ENCOURAGE
BYSTANDERS TO BECOME TRAINED AND
EMPOWERED TO TAKE LIFESAVING
ACTION WHILE EMS PERSONNEL ON
ROUTE. SACRAMENTO LIKE
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE COUNTRY
IS NO STRANGER TO THIS DRAMATIC
EMERGENCY EVENTS IN THE LAST
FIVE WEEKS THERE HAVE BEEN TWO
MASS SHOOTINGS THAT HAVE TAKEN
THE LIVES OF TEN INNOCENT
VICTIMS. DURING THESE TRAGIC
EVENTS A PERSON SUFFERED FROM
SEVERE BLOOD LOSS AND DIED
WITHIN FIVE MINUTES FOR EVERY
SECOND COUNTS. THAT'S WHY IT'S
SO IMPORTANT ASSURE OUR MEDIA
RESPONDERS HAVE THE INSTRUCTION
AND EQUIPMENT NEEDED TO SAVE AND
RENDER MERCY CARE. AT THE SCENE
OF EMERGENCY. WITH THREE PROVIDE
TESTIMONY. IN PERSON ARE. AMY
LIVE HURT A TRAUMA SURGEON AND
ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR AT UC SAN
DIEGO SCHOOL OF MEDICINE. AND
TYLER MCCULLOUGH WHO IS AN ARE
IN WITH THE CALIFORNIA MERCHANT
NURSES ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WITNESSES ARE
HERE. WELL IT WAS ON THE WAY
THAT WE CAN START WORK OKAY
THAT'S FINE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS TYLER MCCALL I'M A
REGISTERED NURSE WORKING THE
MERCY DEPARTMENT- WE PRIDE
OURSELVES ON TAKING CARE OF
TRAUMA PATIENTS. BUT WE CAN ONLY
TAKE CARE OF THEM IF WE GET
THEM- THIS TRAUMA KITS WOULD
HELP. WE RECEIVE MORE PATIENTS
IN THE MERCY APARTMENT AS A
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ STATED
PEOPLE CAN DIE AND FIVE MINUTES
OFTENTIMES LESS WE CAN'T DO
ANYTHING IF WE'RE NOT. IF WE'RE
IT WE CAN HELP THE PATIENT IF
THEY CAN'T GET TO US SO THIS
BILL WOULD JUST SAVE MORE LIVES
ON IN AND- HELP HEMORRHAGIC LOSS
IN THE FIELD. THANK YOU. SHE
GOOD AFTERNOON I THINK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE PRIVILEGE OF
ADDRESSING YOU MY NAME IS DR ANY
LEOPARD I AM A TRAUMA SURGEON
ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR OF SURGERY
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
SAN DIEGO. I'M A DOUBLE BOARD
CERTIFIED. GENERAL SURGEON AND
THE SURGICAL CRITICAL CARE. I'M
HERE TODAY REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF SURGEONS THE
THREE CHAPTERS. ARE IN
CALIFORNIA MERCADO SURGEONS AND
MYSELF. I WORK IN AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF SURGEONS LEVEL ONE
VERIFIED DROP TRAUMA CENTER AND
PROVIDE THE MOST ADVANCED AND
EXPEDITED CARE TO INJURED
PATIENTS. JUST AS THE LEVEL ONE
TRAUMA CENTER HERE AT UC DAVIS
PROVIDED THIS LEVEL OF CARE TO
THIS VERY COMMUNITY JUST A FEW
SHORT DAYS AGO AND AS THEY DO
EVERY DAY. THE CABBIE OUGHT TO
THIS KERR SAID THE INJURED AND
BLEEDING PATIENT. MUST SURVIVE
LONG ENOUGH. TO ARRIVE AT THE
TRAUMA CENTER BEFORE THEY HAVE
DIED FROM BLEEDING OUT. WITH A%
MAJOR BLEEDING INJURY IN ADULT
COMPLETED DEATH WITHIN FIVE
MINUTES. EVEN BEFORE EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES CAN CAN ARRIVE. INJURIES TO THE ARMS LEGS AND
SCALP DIMITRI WITH MINIMAL
EQUIPMENT THAT IS BOTH EASY TO
USE AND EASY TO TRAIN THE
GENERAL PUBLIC. THIS IS A TRAUMA
KIT THAT CAN ALLOW PATIENTS TO
SURVIVE TRANSPORT TO THE TRAUMA
CENTER. IT CONTAINS SIMPLE
EQUIPMENT LIKE GLOVES AND A MASK
. TRAUMA SHEARS OR SCISSORS
THAT'S BLUNT TIPPED TO REMOVE
CLOTHING TO ACCESS THE WOUND.
GAUZE PACKING THAT DOES NOT
EXPIRE. AND A VERIFIED
TOURNIQUET THAT CAN BE TAUGHT TO
THE PUBLIC EASILY AND SIMPLY TO
SAVE LIVES. THE STOP THE BLEED
PROGRAM IS SPONSORED BY THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF SURGEONS THE
WHITE HOUSE THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY. IS CURRENTLY
TAUGHT BY US TRAUMA SURGEONS IN
THE UKRAINE TO MAXIMIZE THE
SURVIVAL OF INJURY THERE. AND
WHILE MANY OF THESE TECHNIQUES
WERE DEVELOPED AN INITIALLY
STUDIED IN A COMBAT ENVIRONMENT.
THEY'RE GENERALIZABLE TO ALL
SOURCES OF BLEEDING THAT OCCUR
IN CIVILIAN LIFE. I HAVE TREATED
PATIENTS. THAT HAVE USED TURN IT
HAD IT NEEDED TOURNIQUETS ARE
OTHER BLEEDING CONTROL
TECHNIQUES APPLIED AFTER MOTOR
VEHICLE OR MOTORCYCLE CRASHES
INDUSTRIAL ACCIDENTS HOME SHOP
INCIDENCES AND EVEN BREAKAGE OF
GLASS WINDOWS OR COFFEE TABLES
NATURAL DISASTERS SUCH AS
EARTHQUAKES AND OTHER IS ANOTHER
POTENTIAL SOURCE OF MAJOR
VASCULAR BLEEDING INJURY.
EDUCATION THE PUBLIC IS
WIDESPREAD IN FREE CALIFORNIA
HAS LED THE EFFORT TO REQUIRE
READY AVAILABILITY OF EIGHTIES
COLOCATED THESE BLEEDING CONTROL
KITS WITHIN THOSE SAME
CONTAINERS AND LOCATIONS MAKE
THESE TOOLS ACCESSIBLE TO SAVE
LIVES AND REDUCES COST. EIGHTY
MANUFACTURERS EVEN ENCOURAGE
THIS COLOCATION THESE KIDS ARE
FORTY DOLLARS A PIECE MAKING
THIS LESS THAN TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLARS FOR ALL SIX REQUIRED BY
THE BILL- AND THIS IS 15% OF ONE
EIGHTY MISSION COSTS. LOCAL
STUDIES IN CALIFORNIA PROVES
THAT THIS SAVES LIVES WITH
WIDESPREAD AVAILABILITY OF THESE
TOOLS AND THESE TECHNIQUES MORE
LIVES WILL BE SAVED AND RESULT
IN LESS BLOOD TRANSFUSION. I
URGE YOU TO VOTE YES ON AB TWO
TO SIXTY FOR BLEEDING CONTROL
KITS TO BE MADE AVAILABLE WHERE
THEY ARE NEEDED IN THE COMMUNITY
TO SAVE LIVES. AND TO STOP THE
BLEED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. BUT
TO THE C. THIRTY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. CNN WILL
GO. TO- MEMBERS OF THE AUDIENCE
WHO WERE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION WILL JUST BE ASKING
FOR NAME ORGANIZATION POSITION
IF YOU HAVE ONE OF THE BILL. I
THINK WE HAVE SOMEBODY MOVING
TOWARDS THE MICROPHONE HERE.
RIGHT SPENT ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
. SEE NO ONE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINE SERVICE DROP RAIDER-
PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT
TO THE BILL ADJUSTER NAME
POSITION ORGANIZATION PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN.
ONE ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO COMMENT
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WILL BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. THE NONE DID THE
BILL DOESN'T JOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION MR RODRIGUEZ- WE
DON'T HAVE A QUORUM. IT'S ALEX
KEEPS SAYING THAT OPEN WE GET A
QUORUM BUT YOU KNOW HOW WE WILL
AT SOME POINT SO WE CAN
ENTERTAIN A MOTION. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE YES BACKGROUND
FROM ABOUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU TO WITNESSES FOR I
THINK YOU SHOULD. MISTER
O'DONNELL. IF ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN AB TWENTY THIRTY FOUR
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY SIR THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB TWO ZERO
THREE FOUR WHICH SEEKS TO
INCREASE ACCESS TO SCHOOL BASED
HEALTH AND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES IN FACT ALL ALL
SERVICES THAT A STUDENT MAY NEED
FIRST I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE'S PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
AND WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING WITH
MY STAFF TO IMPROVE THE BILL. WE
ALL KNOW HOW CRITICAL HEALTH AND
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ARE FOR
STUDENTS PARTICULARLY IN LIGHT
OF RETURNING TO SCHOOL. FROM
CODE. THE CODE LOCKDOWN IF YOU
DON'T MIND JUST. HOUSING FOR ONE
MINUTE WE HAVE A QUORUM WE'VE
BEEN WAITING FOR THIS MOMENT ALL
DAY. MADAM SECRETARY TO MY MIND
. IS GETTING GO HEAD TO THE
CHAIR YES I AM. THANK YOU THIS
REMINDER HERE WALDRON
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA. BIGELOW
REAL. LARA. MAIENSCHEIN MAYES.
MCCARTY NAZARIAN. RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ. SANTIAGO KALRA. WE
HAVE A QUORUM AND I DO APOLOGIZE
BUT I WAS VERY EXCITED ABOUT
THAT SO YOU KNOW PICK IT UP
WHEREVER YOU WANNA START OVER
WHATEVER YOU WANT AYE NAZARIAN
FORMS ARE GOOD THING THEY ARE
AND I'LL JUST PROCEED FROM AND
NOW YOU HAVE A MOTION I DRIVE A
SECOND- RESEARCHER. WITHOUT THE
L. A. B. THE ALLEY A BILLING
SYSTEM ALLOW SCHOOLS TO BE
REIMBURSED FOR MEDICALLY
NECESSARY FOR. SERVICES PROVIDED
TO ANY MEDIC CAL ELIGIBLE PUPIL
BY SCHOOL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS.
FOR TOO LONG A DH CS THE DH CS
AUDIT PROCESS HAS BEEN A
BARRIER. TO INCREASING ACCESS TO
THE SCHOOL SERVICES VENTURA
DIFFICULT FOR SCHOOLS TO RECOUP
THEIR COSTS THEREFORE THEY
REALLY DON'T PARTICIPATE IN THE
PROGRAM SO WE SEEK TO DATE TO
TODAY. IS TO RECTIFY THAT ISSUE
. SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN FRUSTRATED
WITH THE HEAVY ADMINISTRATIVE
BURDEN AND PUNITIVE AUDIT
FINDINGS FOR THE ALLEY A-
BUILDING PROGRAM. MANY DISTRICTS
OF FACE SIGNIFICANT DIS
ALLOWANCES REQUIRING THEM TO
RETURN A LOT OF MONEY TO THE
STATE IN FACT 75% OF LDA CLAIMS
AUDITED BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN AND TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
REQUIRED SOME LEVEL OF REPAYMENT
TO THE STATE. AND DURING THAT
TIME NOT A SINGLE L. EA ONE
FORMAL APPEAL. SCHOOL STUDENTS
TYPICALLY DO NOT RECEIVE
SUFFICIENT GUIDANCE FROM DH CS I
DO NOT HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
SUBMIT A CORRECTIVE PLAN ACTION
PLAN TO ADDRESS AUDIT FINDINGS.
REPAYING DISALLOWED CLAIMS MEANS
THAT SCHOOLS ARE DIPPING INTO
THEIR GENERAL FUND. TAKING
FUNDING AWAY FROM THE CLASSROOM
AND OTHER SERVICES. THEY PROVIDE
TO STUDENTS AS A RESULT SCHOOLS
ARE DROPPING OUT OF THE PROGRAM
ENTIRELY OR NOT BILLING FOR ALL
OF THE SERVICES THAT ARE
ELIGIBLE THEY ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
REIMBURSEMENT. CURRENTLY ONLY
FIVE HUNDRED NINETY FIVE ELEAZAR
OR PROXIMALLY ONE HALF OF THE
ALLEY IS IN CALIFORNIA.
PARTICIPATE IN THE ALLEY A
BROGUE BILLING PROGRAM. THIS
MEANS THAT WE ARE LEAVING
FEDERAL MONEY ON THE TABLE.
CALIFORNIA GENERATES TWENTY NINE
DOLLARS FOR MEDICAL MEDICAL
WHILE MONTANA IS RECEIVING FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS.PER ELIGIBLE
CHILD. THESE FEDERAL DOLLARS
CAREER AND REINVESTED IN OUR
SCHOOLS INTO INCREASED HEALTH
AND MENTAL SERVICES THEY CAN
OFFSET- THE BURDEN ON SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. WE'RE IN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN OUR OFTEN COMING UP
WITH THEIR OWN DOLLARS TO
PROVIDE THESE SERVICES AB TWO
ZERO THREE FOUR REQUIRES REFORMS
TO THE AUDITING PROCESS IS BY
ENSURING THAT SCHOOLS ARE
REIMBURSED FOR ALL ELIGIBLE
SERVICES THAT ARE NOT PRECLUDED
BY LAW. FEDERAL LAW SHIFTING THE
PRIMARY FOCUS OF AUDITS AND
RECOUPMENT OF CLAIMS TO EASE TO
TWO CASES OF FRAUD WASTE OR
ABUSE. REQUIRING THE AUDIT TEAMS
TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
TO L. A.'S WITH LARGE
DISALLOWANCE IS END RECORDING
ARTISTS AND APPEAL PROCESS THESE
TO BE COMPLETED IN A TIMELY
MATTER IN OTHER WORDS THEY
REALLY NEED TO EDUCATE DISTRICTS
HOW TO CONDUCT THE BILLING
PROCESS HOW TO PERFORM THE
BILLING PROCESS. SO THEY CAN DO
IT CORRECTLY THE FIRST TIME AND
NOT BE BURKE IN SOME TYPE AUDIT
THAT HAPPENED SEVEN YEARS AFTER
THAT THE ORIGINAL BILL. THESE
CHANGES WILL ENCOURAGE MORE
SCHOOLS TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
ALLEY BILLING PROGRAM BRING MORE
FEDERAL MONEY TO THE TABLE AND
ULTIMATELY INCREASE THE
AVAILABILITY OF CRITICALLY
NEEDED HEALTH AND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. TO OUR SCHOOL
CAMPUSES. I'D WITH ME HERE TODAY
MISTER CHAIR IS DOCTOR MERRY ON
TO ONE SANTA CLARA COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS AND
KATIE NELSON. A SCHOOL NURSE
FROM THE SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH HOWEVER WANTS TO GO
FIRST. THANK YOU HI I'M DOCTOR
MERION TO ONE I AM THE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS FOR
SANTA CLARA COUNTY AND WE ARE
VERY PLEASED TO SPONSOR AB
TWENTY THIRTY FOUR IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH CTA C. CESA AND
THE SCHOOL NURSES ASSOCIATION.
MY APPRECIATION TO
ASSEMBLYMEMBER O'DONNELL FOR
BRINGING FORWARD THIS CRITICAL
BILL THAT PRIORITIZES STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH AND WELLNESS. IN
SANTA CLARA AND THROUGHOUT THE
STATE STUDENT HEALTH AND MENTAL
HEALTH ARE IN CRISIS. SINCE THE
START OF THE PANDEMIC
INTENTIONAL SELF HARM AMONG
THIRTEEN TO EIGHTEEN YEAR OLDS
INCREASED BY NINETY ONE PERCENT.
AND OVERDOSES INCREASED BY
NINETY FIVE PERCENT. DIAGNOSIS
OF MAJOR DEPRESSIVE DISORDER
INCREASED BY 84% IN JUST THE
LAST YEAR. IN MY COUNTY WE HAVE
LAST SIX STUDENTS TO SUICIDE IN
THE LAST FIFTEEN MONTHS. SCHOOLS
HAVE LONG PROVIDED THE HEALTH
AND MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES THAT
STUDENTS NEED TO ACCESS THEIR
EDUCATION. DURING THE PANDEMIC
EVERY SCHOOL DISTRICT IN THE
STATE TOOK ON SIGNIFICANT HEALTH
ROLES AND RESPONSIBILITIES. IN
ADDITION 95% OF SCHOOLS SPENT A
PORTION OF THEIR STIMULUS
FUNDING TO INCREASE ACCESS. THIS
CONTINUES TO SEARCH SCHOOLS
UNDERSTAND HOW IMPORTANT IT IS
TO CONTINUE TO FUND ON CAMPUS
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. HOWEVER THE
ONLY ON GOING FUNDING AVAILABLE
TO SUPPORT THIS WORK IS THE
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCY BILLING
OPTION PROGRAM ALLEY A BOP. THE
PROGRAM THAT HAS BEEN PLAGUED BY
PUNITIVE AUDITS ARBITRARY AND
CHANGING RULES AND UNFOUNDED
DOCUMENTATION REQUIREMENTS ALL
OF WHICH HAVE PREVENTED STUDENTS
FROM RECEIVING CRITICAL HEALTH
AND MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AT
SCHOOL. ACCORDING TO THEIR OWN-DATA DH CS AUDITORS CURRENTLY.
DISALLOW PORTION OF 75% OF THE
ALLEY A BOB CLAIMS SUBMITTED BY
SCHOOLS THIS RATE OF
DISALLOWANCE IS UNPRECEDENTED
UNPARALLELED IN ANY OTHER STATE
OPERATING A SIMILAR PROGRAM. AND
HAS REMAINED CONSTANT SENSE ON
ITS BEGAN IN TWO THOUSAND NINE.
OR CALIFORNIA TO DRAW DOWN
MEDICARE REIMBURSEMENT RATES
MORE ALIGNED WITH OTHER LARGE
STATES IT WOULD INCREASE FEDERAL
FUNDING FOR SCHOOL BASED STUDENT
HEALTH AND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES BY APPROXIMATELY ONE
POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY. AND THESE DOLLARS
WOULD ENSURE THAT SPECIAL
EDUCATION PROGRAMS ARE
ADEQUATELY FUNDED SCHOOL BASED
HEALTH CENTERS BEHAVIOR HEALTH
SERVICES AND WELLNESS PROGRAMS
HAVE ONGOING FINANCIAL SUPPORT.
I URGE YOU TO JOIN THE SANTA
CLARA COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
AND SUPPORTING AB TWENTY THIRTY
FOUR WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WITNESS PLACE GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO YOU
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
THIRTY FOUR. MY NAME IS KATIE
NELSON I'M A REGISTERED NURSE
WITH A CREDENTIAL IN SCHOOL
NURSING. I AM CURRENTLY WORKING
AS A DIRECTOR OF MEDICAID
COMPLIANCE FOR THE SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION. AND
IN THIS CAPACITY I HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH ELEAZAR
THE STATE. TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
ALLEY A MEDICAL BILLING OPTION
PROGRAM AS WELL AS SPECIFIC
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS SUCH AS
SCHOOL NURSES. PSYCHOLOGISTS
SPEECH THERAPISTS AS WELL AS
OTHERS. IN THIS POSITION I
PARTICIPATE IN TRAININGS I
ATTEND THE DH CS IS BI MONTHLY
ADVISORY WORKGROUP MEETINGS. AND
I OFFER COMPLETE PROGRAM REVIEWS
TO THE ELEAZAR- CONTRACT WITH A
THIRD PARTY BILLING. VENDOR THAT
OPERATES WITHIN THE
COMPREHENSIVE PROGRAM DIVISION
AT S. J. C. O. E. WHEN SPEAKING
WITH DISTRICTS AND COMPLETING
PROGRAM REVIEWS. THERE ARE SOME
COMMON THEMES REGARDING THE
ALLEY A MEDICAL BILLING OPTION
PROGRAM I HAVE IDENTIFIED. THE
FIRST BEING THE ADMINISTRATIVE
BURDEN THAT IS THAT IT MAY CAUSE
SOME ELEAZAR ESPECIALLY SMALLER
DISTRICTS. I HAVE KNOWLEDGE OF
SMALL OF SEVERAL SMALLER
DISTRICTS RECENTLY DISCONTINUING
THEIR PARTICIPATION IN THE
PROGRAM. DUE TO THE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN
OUTWEIGHING THE BENEFIT OF
POTENTIAL INTERIM FIRST MET.
WHEN AUDITS OCCUR THERE'S A HIGH
POTENTIAL DISTRICTS WILL HAVE
FUTURE REIMBURSEMENT WITH HELD.
OR REPAYMENTS DUE TO VARIOUS
REASONS LACK OF DOCUMENTATION IS
TYPICALLY ONE OF THE MOST
PREVALENT AUDIT FINDINGS. THIS
IS OFTEN DUE TO HIGH STAFF
TURNOVER. FOR THE PROGRAM
COORDINATOR AT THE L. A. LEVEL
NOT FULLY UNDERSTANDING THE
COMPLEXITIES OF THE PROGRAM. AND
THE MANY REQUIREMENTS OR NOT
RECEIVING ADEQUATE TRAINING AND
SUPPORT. THERE'S ALSO THE
REALITY THATDIFFERENT
DEPARTMENTS WITHIN THE L. EA ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR DIFFERENT PIECES
OF THE PROGRAM WHICH CONTRIBUTES
TO THE LACK OF UNDERSTANDING. OF
THE PROGRAM REQUIREMENTS. IN
JULY TWENTY TWENTY THE NEW STATE
PLAN AMENDMENT WAS IMPLEMENTED
WHICH EXPANDED THE L. A. OPTION
BILL BILLING OPTION PROGRAM.
ADDING NEW PRACTITIONERS
ADDITIONAL SERVICES AS WELL AS
LIFTING THE MAXIMUM NUMBER OF
CLAIMS ALLOWED FOR GENERAL
EDUCATION STUDENTS. FROM TWENTY
FOUR SERVICES PER STUDENT PER
YEAR. TO ALLOWING FOR ALL
QUALIFIED HEALTH SERVICES
PROVIDED TO BE CLAIMED. MANY
ELEAZAR UNAWARE OF THIS
EXPANSION ESPECIALLY THE ABILITY
TO CLAIM FOR MEDICAL
REIMBURSEMENT FOR STUDENTS
OUTSIDE OF SPECIAL EDUCATION.
THE DHS OFFERS AND FACILITATES
ADVAIT ADVISORY WORK GROUP
MEETINGS AND TRAININGS EVERY
OTHER MONTH THROUGHOUT THE
SCHOOL YEAR ALTHOUGH THESE
TRAININGS- MEETINGS AND
TRAININGS ARE HELPFUL ADDITIONAL
TRAINING AND SUPPORT IS NEEDED
FOR ELLIE IS PARTICIPATING IN
THE PROGRAM. IT IS THE POSITION
OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL NURSES
ORGANIZATION THAT DAC HE EIGHT
CS PROVIDE ADDITIONAL PROGRAM AN
AUDIT SUPPORT THAT FOCUSES ON
FRAUD WASTE AND ABUSE THANK YOU
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS. C. NONE WILL
GO TO THE AUDIENCE FOR
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
JUST TO NAME A POSITION. ON THE
BILL AND ORGANIZATIONS WE
REPRESENT ONE. THE FIGURE CURRY
. MISTER CHAIR TONY TO CARE ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION CO SPONSORED THE
BILL WE LIKE TO THINK THE TO THE
AUTHOR FOR THIS WORK HE HAS DONE
ON THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. VIDEO OF ONE REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL NURSES
ORGANIZATION WE'RE PROUD CO
SPONSORS OF THE BILL.I'M ASKING
FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE. IN ORDER OF THE
PHONE LINES MISTER OPERATOR
JUST- LOOKING FOR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION NAME POSITION ON THE
BILL AN ORGANIZATION ONLY. IF
YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. THAT
COMMAND AGAIN ONE TEN ZERO. AND
FIRST WE WILL GO TO LINE SIXTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHE YES
THIS IS ERICA HOFFMAN ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION VERY MUCH INPUT ON
SUPPORTED THIS MEASURE THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
WHY NO ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY FOUR.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS DEREK
LENNIX FROM THE CALIFORNIA
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
EDUCATIONAL SERVICESTO CREATION
PLEASED TO BE A CO SPONSOR ON
THIS MEASURE. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. BLIND. ONE
HUNDRED SEVENTY SIX. YOUR
MEMBERS CRYPTOLOGY .COM WE HAVE
A CALIFORNIA STATE THE CREATION
PSYCHIATRISTS IN THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE.
ONE HUNDRED FORTY THREE. MORE
WANT TO GO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGISTS CO SPONSOR AND IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX. LOOKING
CHAIR MEMBERS ONE OF THE
BERNARD'S FIRE PRESENT LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WHY NO. ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY FIVE. HIGHLY TEACHER
KIRSTY ON BEHALF OF THE OFFICE
OF SUPER RIVERSIDE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. TEN MISTER CHAIR
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENTS AT
THIS TIME GREAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. ANYONE ON THE
COMMITTEE. I SUPPOSE A THANK YOU
FOR BRING THE GO FORWARD I THE
FACT WE HAVE AUDITS THAT ARE
HAVING A CHILLING EFFECT ON. THE
ABILITY FOR DISTRICTS ARE FOR
ELEAZAR TO. DO PROVIDE THIS
CRITICAL CARE TO STUDENTS IS
REALLY REALLY FRUSTRATING AND- I
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD. IT DOESN'T DO I DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WHICH LIKE TO
CLOSE. AS FOR RIVAL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THAT SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION THE
MOTION IS SET. BY MISS CARILLO
SECOND BY MISS AGUIAR-CURRY. DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. WHAT I WHAT I
WALDRON WALDRON AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE ARAMBULA.
BIGELOW MARIA RIO I FLOOR.
MAIENSCHEIN MAYES MCCARTY. THIS
AREA. NAZARIAN I RIVAS RIVAS AYE
RODRIGUEZ. RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO
. OUR. SEVEN ZERO RIVERSIDE BUT
YOU'VE GOTTEN FURTHER THAN
ANYBODY ELSE TODAY SO BECAUSE WE
HAVE A QUORUM SO- WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE BELIEVE THE BILL A CALL
THANKS SO MUCH GOD BLESS THE
CORN THANK YOU THANK YOU BUT
SOME IS COMING IN YOUR SISTER.
OR SOMETHING. A GUY NOW I'M
HEARING THINGS THIS IS SCARY
OKAY THERE'S NO DOOR OVER THERE
APPARENTLY OKAY I'LL.
THREE OF US I'M SORRY MR CANS
OUT THERE ISN'T SHE YEAH.
WELCOME BACK MISS BARRICADE HAND.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY THANK YOU
I HAVE. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ARE GONNA START WITH AB
SIXTEEN SIXTY SIX AT THIS IS A
BILL TO PROTECT ABORTION CARE
LAWS ACROSS THE COUNTRY- MAKING
ABORTION A CRIME WITH TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN
PENALTIES FOR BOTH PATIENTS AND
PROVIDERS THE SUPREME COURT HAS
DECIDED NOT TO STAND WITH ROE V.
WADE AND CHOSEN TO STAND ASIDE
AND LET THE LAWS UNDERMINE THE
RIGHT TO CHOOSE THAT WAS SO HARD
FOUGHT. THE QUESTION IS NOT
WHETHER BUT WILL HAPPEN THEY
WILL HAPPEN THE QUESTION IS
WHETHER WE RISK IN RUIN THE
LIVES OF THOSE SEEKING THEM OR
PROTECT THEM WHETHER PORTION
WILL BE SAFE OR DANGEROUS AND
WHETHER WILL CHOICE WILL BE
LEGAL OR FINANCIALLY RUINOUS
WITH ABORTION LEFT UP TO THE
STATES IT'S UP TO A STATE LIKE
CALIFORNIA TO STAND UP FOR THE
RIGHT TO CHOOSE. AB SIXTEEN
SIXTY SIX APPROACH TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIANS FROM CIVIL
LIABILITY FOR THEIR ACTIONS TO
RECEIVE PROVIDE OR AID IN
ABORTION CARE AB SIXTEEN SIXTY
SIX SIMPLY DECLARES ANY CIVIL
ACTION FOR EATING IN OR
RECEIVING ABORTION TO BE
CONTRARY TO THE PUBLIC POLICY OF
CALIFORNIA AND THEREFORE
UNENFORCEABLE IN OUR STATE
COURTS. OPPOSITION ARGUES THAT
THIS BILL LEGALIZES MALPRACTICE
LET ME BE CLEAR THIS IS ENTIRELY
UNTRUE. ANYTHING THAT IS
CURRENTLY ILLEGAL UNDER
CALIFORNIA LAW WILL REMAIN SO.
AS AN ATTORNEY I UNDERSTAND THE
POWER THE FULL FAITH AND CREDIT
CLAUSE. THE PUBLIC PUBLIC SEE
EXEMPTION WHICH YOU WILL HEAR
ABOUT FROM OUR WITNESS OF THE
FULL FAITH AND CREDIT CLAUSE
STATES THAT IT DOES NOT REQUIRE
ONE STATE TO APPLY AND OTHER
STATES LAW THE VIOLATES ITS OWN
LEGITIMATE PUBLIC POLICY.
CALIFORNIA HAS NO OBLIGATION TO
ENFORCE CIVIL PENALTIES WOULD
VIOLATE THE ABORTION RIGHTS
PROTECTED IN OUR OWN
CONSTITUTION. WHEN A PREGNANT
PERSON'S CHOICE ABOUT THEIR OWN
BODIES QUESTIONED THE LIVES OF
ALL PREGNANT PEOPLE ARE AT STAKE
WE IS A STATE MUST DO WHAT WE
CAN TO PROTECT THOSE WHO ARE
PROVIDING THIS IMPORTANT HEALTH
CARE. AB SIXTY SIXTY SIX CREATES
THE PROTECTIONS TO MAKE
CALIFORNIA A SANCTUARY FOR THOSE
MAKING REPRODUCTIVE CHOICES AND
THOSE PROVIDING CARE. WITH ME
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL OR
SALINAS AND ALL AN OBGYN
PROVIDER UC SAN DIEGO INDIA
DOESN'T RUN A PROFESSOR OF LAW
AT STANFORD UNIVERSITY. THEY
WERE MOST BY MISS KOREA SECOND
BY MISTER NAZARIAN SILENT MOTION
BUT SITE SO. OF THESE GO AHEAD
WITH YOUR WITNESSES. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR IN THE MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE FOR ALLOWING ME
TO PRESENT TESTIMONY TODAY MY
NAME IS DR SALINAS ANIMAL A
BOARD CERTIFIED OBGYN A COMPLEX
FAMILY PLANNING SPECIALIST I'M
ALSO A MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
FUTURE OF ABORTION COUNSEL. I'M
HERE TODAY REPRESENTING DISTRICT
NINE OF THE MERICAN COLLEGE OF
OBSTETRICIANS AND GYNECOLOGISTS
WHO IS CO SPONSORING ASSEMBLY
BILL SIXTEEN SIXTY SIX. ASSEMBLY
BILL SIXTEEN SIXTY SIX PROVIDES
PROTECTIONS TO ABORTION PATIENTS
AND CLINICIANS. BY PROHIBITING
CIVIL ACTION FROM ANY OTHER
STATE LAW FROM BEING APPLIED TO
THOSE IN CALIFORNIA. AS A
PHYSICIAN WHO PROVIDES FULL
SPECTRUM ABORTION CARE I CAN SAY
WITH CERTAINTY THAT THE
PROTECTIONS OF AB SIXTEEN SIXTY
SIX ARE OF UTMOST IMPORTANCE. AS
YOU ALL KNOW THE CURRENT
POLITICAL CLIMATE IN THE UNITED
STATES IS ALLOWING FOR
UNPRECEDENTED AMOUNTS OF
LEGISLATION AGAINST REPRODUCTIVE
RIGHTS. IN CALIFORNIA MY
COLLEAGUES AND I ARE ALREADY
SEEING PATIENTS TRAVELING FROM
TEXAS UNDER SB EIGHT TO OBTAIN
CARE. OKLAHOMA RECENTLY PASSED
SIMILAR LEGISLATION AND WE'RE
CONFIDENT THIS TREND WILL
CONTINUE. AN ESTIMATED THIRTY
SIX MILLION PEOPLE WHO CAN GET
PREGNANT WILL LOSE ACCESS TO
ABORTION IF THE SUPREME COURT
OVERTURNS ROE VERSUS WADE. I
PROVIDED ABORTION CARE
THROUGHOUT THE UNITED STATES.
AND I'VE SEEN FIRSTHAND THE
EFFECTS OF LIMITING ACCESS TO
ABORTION. AGENTS ARE FORCED TO
DELAY THEIR CARE THEY TROUBLE
HUNDREDS IF NOT THOUSANDS OF
MILES IF YOU FINANCIAL
DIFFICULTIES AND TIME AWAY FROM
WORK JUST UNDERGO A SIMPLE AND
SAFE MEDICAL PROCEDURE.
UNFORTUNATELY THESE PATIENTS ARE
THE LUCKY ONES THE ONES WITH THE
PRIVILEGE IN THE MEANS TO
ACTUALLY TRAVEL OUT OF STATE.
THE MAJORITY PATIENTS DON'T HAVE
THIS ABILITY TO LEAVE THEIR
STATE AND ARE ULTIMATELY FORCED
TO CONTINUE PREGNANCY IS THAT
MAYBE THREATS TO THEIR HEALTH
AND THEIR SAFETY. PERHAPS EVEN
MORE CONCERNING IS A RECENT
LEGISLATION OUT OF MISERY. WHICH
SUPPORTS CIVIL SUITS AGAINST
ANYONE PERFORMING AN ABORTION ON
A MISSOURI RESIDENT OR ASSISTING
A MISSOURI RESIDENT OBTAINING AN
ABORTION. REGARDLESS OF WHERE
THAT ABORTION TAKES PLACE. I
TAKE MY PATIENTS AT THESE VALUE
THEY COME TO ME WITH THE NEED
FOR A SERVICE THAT I CAN
EXPERTLY PROVIDE. I WILL NEVER
INTERROGATED PATIENT ABOUT THEIR
STATE OF ORIGIN AND I KNOW THAT
MY COLLEAGUES TREAT THEIR
PATIENTS WITH THE SAME RESPECT.
THIS IS NO LONGER THEORETICAL
UNFORTUNATELY IN THESE
LEGISLATION LIKE THIS PUT OUR
CALIFORNIA PROVIDERS AT RISK. WE
KNOW THAT ABORTION IS ESSENTIAL
HEALTH CARE. CALIFORNIA IS
BECOMING A SAFE HAVEN AND A
DESTINATION STATE FOR PROTECTING
REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS. I AM SO
HONORED TO SERVE MY PATIENTS BUT
I CAN ONLY CONTINUE TO DO THIS
SAFELY WITH THE APPROPRIATE
PROTECTIONS. PLEASE ALLOW MY
COLLEAGUES AND I THE PEACE OF
MIND TO FOCUS ON THE PATIENTS
SITTING IN FRONT OF US EVERY
DAY. AND PROVIDE THEM WITH THE
QUALITY OF CARE THEY DESERVE.
HELP US PROTECT ABORTION ACCESS
IN CALIFORNIA. BY VOTING I OUT
ON ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN SIXTY
SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
THIS HEARING. MY NAME IS DIEGO
ZAMBRANO AND I'M AN ASSOCIATE
PROFESSOR OF LAW AT STANFORD LAW
SCHOOL. I WRITE AND TEACH IN THE
FIELD OF CIVIL PROCEDURE. IN THE
PAST YEAR I'VE BEEN STUDYING
TEXAS S. B. ANTI ABORTION BILL.
I'M HERE TODAY TO COMMENT ON
POTENTIAL FEDERAL CONSTITUTIONAL
CHALLENGES TO AB SIXTEEN SIXTY
SIX. I BELIEVE THE BILL COMPLIES
WITH THE FEDERAL CONSTITUTION
AND WOULD LIKELY SURVIVE
CONSTITUTIONAL CHALLENGE. SO I'M
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL'S
CONSTITUTIONALITY. AS THE BILL
REPORT DISCUSSES THE MAIN
POTENTIAL ISSUE. WITH THE BILL
IS THE FULL FAITH AND CREDIT
CLAUSE OF ARTICLE FOUR SECTION
ONE OF THE U. S. CONSTITUTION.
UNDER THAT CLAUSE STATES ARE
REQUIRED TO RECOGNIZE OTHER
STATES STATUTES PUBLIC RECORDS
AND COURT DECISIONS. THE FULL
FAITH AND CREDIT CLAUSE HOWEVER
IS NOT IRON CLAD IN AB SIXTEEN
SIXTY SIX MAY BE ABLE TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF TWO WELL RECOGNIZED
EXCEPTIONS. THE PUBLIC POLICY
EXCEPTION FOR PROVISION BE ONE.
IN THE PENAL JUDGMENTS EXCEPTION
FOR PROVISION BE TO. FIRST A
COURT WOULD MOST LIKELY OF HOLD
AB SIXTY SIXTY SIX B. ONE THE
PROVISION WHICH PROHIBITS
CALIFORNIA COURTS FROM
ENTERTAINING CLAIMS. UNDER ANTI
ABORTION LAWS LIKE TEXAS SB
EIGHT. THAT PROVISION IS
PROBABLY CONSTITUTIONAL UNDER
THE PUBLIC POLICY EXCEPTION
WHICH PROVIDES THAT SEATS ARE
NOT OBLIGATED TO APPLY ANOTHER
STATE'S LAWS THAT VIOLATE THEIR
OWN LEGITIMATE PUBLIC POLICY.
AND THE PROTECTION OF A WOMAN'S
RIGHT TO CHOOSE WHETHER TO
TERMINATE PREGNANCY IS
DEFINITIVELY WITHIN CALIFORNIA'S
ONLY GERMAN PUBLIC POLICY. TO BE
SURE WHETHER THE STATE'S PUBLIC
POLICY DISCRIMINATES AGAINST
CAUSES OF ACTION ARISING IN
OTHER STATES IS RELEVANT. BUT AB
SIXTY SIX SIX DOES NOT AT ALL
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST OUT OF
STATE CAUSES OF ACTION IF FLAT
OUT STATES A GENERAL OPPOSITION
TO ANY SUCH LOSS IN STATE OR OUT
OF STATE. FURTHERMORE THE BILL
STRENGTHENED BY ITS AFFIRMATIVE
DECLARATION OF CALIFORNIA STATE
POLICY AGAINST SUITS TARGETING
ABORTION PROVIDERS. SECOND POINT
I WANT TO MAKE IS THAT
CALIFORNIA MAY BE ABLE TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE PENAL JUDGMENTS
EXCEPTION TO THE FULL FAITH AND
CREDIT CLAUSE TO PREVENT ITS
COURTS FROM ENFORCING SB EIGHT
STYLE JUDGMENTS. IF F. B. IF SB
EIGHT IS PENAL CALIFORNIA IS NOT
BOUND TO ENFORCE SB EIGHT STYLE
JUDGMENTS IN ITS COURTS IN AB
SIXTY SIX SIX B. TWO WOULD PASS
CONSTITUTIONAL MUSTER. ACTIONS
THAT- PENAL IN NATURE HAVE TO BE
IN FORCE IN THE STATE WHERE THEY
OCCURRED IN THE CRITICAL
DISTINCTION THAT MAKES OUR OWN
PENAL IS WHETHER A CLAIM
REMEDIES A PRIVATE INJURY.
CALIFORNIA HAS A GOOD ARGUMENT
THAT SPD'S PENAL BECAUSE IT
LACKS A PERSONAL INJURY
REQUIREMENT IT PROVIDES FOR TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND STATUTORY
DAMAGES AND IT IS ATTEMPTING TO
PUNISH AN OFFENSE AGAINST THE
COMMUNITY. SO IN SOME I BELIEVE
THE LAW WOULD SURVIVE CHALLENGES
ON THE FEDERAL CONSTITUTION
BECAUSE OF THOSE TWO EXCEPTIONS
AND I AM THEREFORE IN SUPPORT OF
THE LAW. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH IS THERE ANY THAN
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION HERE.
HELLO THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME
TO ADDRESS THIS COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS JENNIFER MILBORNE AND
I'M THE COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
COORDINATOR FOR ABORTION
SURVIVORS NETWORK THE ONLY
ORGANIZATION THAT SERVES THE
SURVIVORS OF ABORTION AND THEIR
FAMILIES. THIS LEGISLATION WOULD
PROHIBIT THE APPLICATION OF LAWS
THAT AUTHORIZES CIVIL ACTION
AGAINST PERSONS OR ENTITIES WHO
SEEK PERFORM INDUCE AID OR ABET
THE PERFORMANCE OF AN ABORTION
CONTRARY TO THE INTERESTS OF THE
CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA. I
BELIEVE THAT ABORTION IS NOT IN
THE BEST INTEREST OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND ITS CITIZENS
BOTH BORN AND UNBORN. I SPEAK
ABOUT THIS WITH SPECIFIC
AUTHORITY BECAUSE I AM THE
VICTIM OF A FAILED ABORTION.
DATA REPEATEDLY SHOWS THAT
ABORTION HARMS THE UNBORN
CHILDREN BY TERMINATING THEIR
LIFE STOPPING A VIABLE HEART
BEAT. AND THE MOTHERS OF THOSE
UNBORN CHILDREN WHO OFTEN
SUFFERED VISIBLE AND INVISIBLE
SCARS FOR THE REST OF THEIR
LIVES. ABORTION IS NOT HEALTH
CARE AND WHEN I HEAR STATEMENT
THAT ABORTION IS HEALTH CARE I
ARGUE THE ONLY REASON THAT I AM
ALIVE TODAY IS BECAUSE OF THE
FAILED HEALTH CARE MY BIOLOGICAL
MOM RECEIVED. THE ABORTION
DOCTOR FAILED TO COMPLETE THE
ABORTION PROCEDURE. NOW DOESN'T
THAT SOUND STRANGE A LIFE WAS
SAVED BECAUSE A DOCTOR FAILED.
USUALLY WHEN A DOCTOR FAIL
SOMEONE DIES JUST THINK ABOUT
THAT. I WAS MUCH FURTHER ALONG
IN JUST A TIONAL AGE THAN WAS
ANTICIPATED. AND DESPITE
STATEMENTS MADE BY THE ABORTION
INDUSTRY ABORTIONS REGULARLY ARE
PERFORMED ON BABIES THAT ARE
MUCH FARTHER ALONG THAN
ESTIMATED. WHICH CAN CROSS THE
LINE VIABILITY. I WAS NOT I DID
SENIOR. THAT NEEDED TO BE
TREATED I'M A HUMAN BEING. HOW
CAN SOMETHING BE CONSIDERED
HEALTH CARE WHEN THE DESIRED
OUTCOME IS THAT A HEART BE IS
STOPPED. NO I DON'T WISH TO
CRIMINALIZE WOMEN THAT SEEK
ABORTIONS. HOWEVER I WOULD ARGUE
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS AN INTEREST
IN PROVIDING BETTER OUTCOMES FOR
WOMEN IN THEIR UNBORN CHILDREN.
THIS BILL WILL HAVE THE
CONSEQUENCE PERHAPS INTENDED OF
MAKING CALIFORNIA A DESTINATION
OF ABORTION AS STATES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY RECOGNIZE THE WILL OF
THE PEOPLE AND THE SACREDNESS OF
LIFE AT ALL STAGES. THE ABORTION
INDUSTRY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WILL COLLABORATE TO
EXPLOIT VULNERABLE WOMEN AND
EXTINGUISH THE LIVES OF PREBORN
INFANTS. YOU MUST UP HOLD THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION WHICH
STATES ALL PEOPLE ALL PEOPLE ARE
BY NATURE FREE AND INDEPENDENT.
AND HAVE AN ALIEN OPAL RIGHT.
AMONG THESE ARE ENJOYING AND
DEFENDING LIFE AND LIBERTY. HOW
CAN A RIGHT TO AN ABORTION
SUPERSEDE MY OWN RIGHT TO LIVE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU X. WITNESS
PLEASE GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS BRIDGET
BLAIR I AM THE FORMER CEO OF
HOLLISTER PREGNANCY CENTER AND
THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA REGIONAL
DIRECTOR FOR THE SILENT NO MORE
AWARENESS CAMPAIGN I HAVE HAD
THREE FIRST TRIMESTER SUCTION D.
AND C. ABORTIONS AT THE AGE OF
FOURTEEN I BECAME PREGNANT I WAS
NAIVE AND IMMATURE A CHILD I
WENT TO PLANNED PARENTHOOD TO
HAVE AN ABORTION AND WITH NO
QUESTIONS ASKED I WEISS I WAS
SIGNED UP FOR EMERGENCY MEDICAL.
AND HAD A FREE ABORTION WITHOUT
MY PARENTS CONSENT OR KNOWLEDGE
. DURING THE SUCTION ABORTION I
SAW THE COLLECTION BOTTLE FILLED
WITH THE BLOOD AND PARTS OF MY
BABY I WAS TRAUMATIZED. AFTER
THE ABORTION I SPIRALED INTO
DRUG AND ALCOHOL ABUSE I BECAME
PREGNANT AGAIN AT THE AGE OF
SIXTEEN. THE PAIN AND SHAME I
CARRIED COMPOUNDED WHEN I FOUND
MYSELF BACK AT THE CLINIC A
SECOND TIME. I BECAME DEPRESSED
AND BEGAN STRUGGLING IN SCHOOL I
CUT CLASSES AND HAD TO GO TO A
LOCAL JUNIOR COLLEGE TO EARN
EXTRA CREDITS TO GRADUATE FROM
HIGH SCHOOL. WHEN I FOUND MYSELF
PREGNANT A THIRD TIME I WENT TO
THE CLINIC AN EMOTIONAL WRECK. I
WAS EMOTIONALLY FRAGILE AND
UNSTABLE. I FELT HOPELESS I DID
NOT RECEIVE AN ASSESSMENT
REGARDING MY EMOTIONAL HEALTH
NOR WAS I OFFERED ANY TYPE OF
PREGNANCY OUTCOME OPTIONS. ON
THE MEDICAL TABLE I WAS CRYING I
WAS VULNERABLE ON MY BACK MY
FEET WERE IN THE STIRRUPS AND
THE NURSE LOOKED DOWN AT ME AND
SAID. YOU DO NOT WANT TO DO THIS
DO YOU. I SAID NOW. THE NURSE
SAID IT WILL BE OVER SOON. I WAS
INVISIBLE EMOTIONAL DISTRESS YET
THE CLINIC PERFORMED THE
ABORTION EVEN THOUGH I SAID NO
BEFORE THE PROCEDURE BEGAN. THEY
DENIED MY RIGHT TO CHOOSE. THEY
DIDN'T THEY DENIED MY RIGHT TO
CHANGE MY MIND. AB SIXTEEN SIXTY
SIX WON'T PROTECT WOMEN. THE
ONLY PEOPLE AB SIXTEEN SIXTY SIX
WILL PROTECT OUR ABORTIONISTS
RAPISTS AND HUMAN TRAFFICKERS
WHO VIOLATE VIOLATED OTHER STATE
LAWS PROTECTING WOMEN. AB
SIXTEEN SIX WHAT WILL REFUSE TO
RECOGNIZE VALID JUDGMENTS IN
CALIFORNIA FOR ABORTION
MALPRACTICE COMMITTED IN OTHER
STATES AGAINST SUCH VICTIMIZERS.
IGNORING THOSE JUDGMENTS WILL
VICTIMIZE WOMEN A SECOND TIME.
FOR THESE REASONS I URGE YOU TO
VOTE NOW ON AB SIXTEEN SIXTY SIX
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- ARE THERE
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION HERE JUST YOUR NAME
POSITION ON THE BILL AN
ORGANIZATION IF YOU REPRESENT
ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON MY ROPE
SONORA CO SPONSORING THE BILL
AND HERE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
OKAY THE FIRM HAD A FLEET
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU THAT'S OKAY. SUSAN ARE NOT ALL I'M AN
ATTORNEY WITH THE RIGHT TO LIFE
LEAGUE AMERICA'S FIRST PRO LIFE
ORGANIZATION WE OPPOSE AB
SIXTEEN SIXTY SIX THANK YOU.
GREG BIRD WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FAMILY COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. GEORGE SOURIS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
. ANYONE ELSE. IN KNOWN WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES NOW- STRUCK
RAIDER- SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
FOR AB SIXTEEN SIXTY SIX JUST
NAME POSITION ON THE BILL AN
ORGANIZATION IF YOU REPRESENT
ONE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN ONE.
TEN ZERO. IN FIRST WE WILL GO TO
LINE ONE SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IT'S NOT REQUIRED ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
MIDWIVES ASSOCIATION ANNUAL PRO
CHOICE CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE FIFTY
EIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS COUNTY DOWN
OFTEN REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT AND
A PROUD CO SPONSOR THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE ELEVEN.
THANK YOU KAREN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS BUT YOU LOOK AT THE
ELEMENT CALIFORNIA'S ONLY
ABORTION ACCESS REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE BUT WE ARE IN FULL
SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN SIXTY SIX
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WHY NO ONE NINETY TWO.
JOHNNY MARTIN ON BEHALF OF
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA RECENT CO
SPONSOR OF THE BILL IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANKS CALLER
PLEASE. BLIND TWENTY ONE. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON REBECCA GONZALEZ
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. I KNOW ONE SIXTY SIX.
THAT AFTERNOON SO THEY CAN DEAL
WITH THE FINANCIAL ACCESS HELLO
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE MEASURE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WHY NO ONE NINETY SIX.
HI THERE GOOD AFTERNOON ON YOUR
MOBILE AGAIN WITH BLACK WOMEN
FOR WELLNESS ACTION PROJECT IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WHY NOT
ONE NINETY SEVEN. HELLO ON
BEHALF OF TEACH TRAINING EARLY
ABORTION FOR COMPREHENSIVE
HEALTHCARE IN THE COURT OF AB
ONE SIX SIX SIX THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LANE.
ONE NINETY THREE. HELLO
COMMITTEE AND MY NAME IS ROBERT
JOSEPH BIRD I'M AN ACTIVIST WITH
PRO LIFE SAN FRANCISCO ON THE
BASIS OF THE TESTIMONY FROM
NOVICES OPPOSITION WITNESSES
THAT YOU JUST PURCHASED YOUR
GRIEVANCES WELCOME NOW JUST YOUR
NAME A POSITION RESULT NOW VOTE
NO ON THIS BILL STANFORD
CHAPTER. THANK YOU. JUST YOUR
NAME POSITION ONE ORGANIZATION
PLEASE. LINE A ONE FIFTY EIGHT.
HELLO MY NAME IS THERESA BRENNAN
AND I'M THE PRAYER. ACTOR OF THE
RIGHT TO LIFE WEEK WE ARE IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO AB ONE SIX
SIX SIX. THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. I KNOW ONE SEVENTY TWO.
HELLO THIS IS CLAIRE LOOKED
SHOCKED FROM THE NATIONAL
COUNCIL OF JEWISH WOMEN IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. AND MISTER CHAIR
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR BRINGING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THAT THE BILL DOES AND YOU ENJOY
A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION MISTER
QUE HAN. ARE YOU HAVE A MOTION
FROM IS CARILLO SECOND FROM
MISTER HIS AREA. WHICH LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU ACCOUNT WAIT
I'M SORRY AND SHE IS A COMMON.
THANK YOU ITS ATTEMPT BEING
SILENT A QUIET OVER HERE YEAH
RAISE YOUR HAND DO WHATEVER AND
WAIVER SOMETHING VERY GOOD THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT SHE HAS A COMMENT.
FIRST DAY JUST WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR THIS INCREDIBLY. BOLD
AND COURAGEOUS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. AS WE ARE SEEN AT
WOMEN'S REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
AND- A REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
FOR PEOPLE WHO. NEED THIS TYPE
OF SUPPORT I THINK IT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT. ESPECIALLY
IN THIS MOMENT IN TIME. I DO
WANNA TAKE A MOMENT TO JUST SAY
THANK YOU TO THE TESTIMONY OF
THE OPPOSITION AS WELL. IT IS
INCREDIBLY CHALLENGING AND HARD
AND DIFFICULT TO SHARE THE
STORIES. AND THEY ARE NO WAY TO
BE DISMISSED. I THANK YOU TO THE
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT AS WELL
BECAUSE YOU ARE ALSO SHARING THE
VOICES OF. INDIVIDUALS PEOPLE
AND WOMEN WHO ARE NOT ABLE TO BE
HERE TODAY. OUT WHEN IT COMES TO
THE TEXAS LEGISLATURE IS MOSTLY
WHITE IT IS MOSTLY MALE AND IT
IS NOT A REFLECTION. OF THE
ENTIRE STATE OF TEXAS. AND AS-
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
CONTINUES TO BE ATTACKED. ACROSS
THE NATION I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT CALIFORNIA. DOES WHAT
IT NEEDS TO DO TO ENSURE THAT WE
ARE PROTECTING REPRODUCTIVE
RIGHTS REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM. AND
THAT ULTIMATELY. THE DECISIONS
THESE INCREDIBLY HARD CHOICES
AND DECISIONS. THE PEOPLE HAVE
TO MAKE ARE AT THE FOREFRONT OF
THE CONVERSATION. AND I JUST
INCREDIBLY
THAT ASPECT. AND AS CALIFORNIA
GOES SO DOES THE NATION ARE SO I
HOPE. ESPECIALLY IN THE LARGER
NATIONAL CONVERSATION OF. ROE V.
WADE CALIFORNIA AND THE FACT
THAT. FOR THE FIRST TIME EVER WE
HAVE MORE PEOPLE OF COLOR. MORE
WOMEN ELECTED INTO OFFICE AND
REPRESENTATION MATTERS. AND SO
WELL. WHITE MALE LEGISLATORS AND
WHITE LEADERS WHITE MALE LEADERS
IN TEXAS AND- WHITE MALE
GOVERNOR IN TEXAS WILL MAKE
DECISIONS ON. WOMEN'S
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTHCARE IN
CALIFORNIA IT IS WOMEN. IN IT IS
PEOPLE OF COLOR THAT ARE MAKING
DECISIONS. FOR WHAT IS TRULY A
REPRESENTATIVE STATE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND FOR THAT. I'M
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP AND
I WILL BE ONE HUNDRED SUPPORT.
OF YOUR BILL AND ALL THE
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE BILLS THAT
WE SEE MOVING FORWARD IN THE
LEGISLATURE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- THE MOTION ACTUALLY
BACK UP THE MOTIONS TO PASS.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK
YOU M. I WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CREO FOR HER
COMMENTS I KNOW SHE HAS BEEN AN
INCREDIBLE CHAMPION. FOR WOMEN
WHO HAVE BEEN FORCIBLY
STERILIZED HERE IN OUR STATE AND
DONE INCREDIBLE WORK THAT I'VE
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO SUPPORT.
AND I THINK THAT THAT EMPHASIZES
THE POINT YOU MADE WHICH IS
CHOICE MEANS CHOICE RIGHT IN
THOSE WOMEN THAT YOU'VE
ADVOCATED FOR SO INCREDIBLY IN
THIS LEGISLATURE WERE FORCED.
NOT TO HAVE CHILDREN RIGHT AND
SO WHAT WE STAND FOR AS A STATE
AND AS A BODY. IS THE RIGHT TO
CHOOSE AND SO I THINK IT'S THANK
YOU FOR KNOWLEDGE IN THE
TESTIMONY OF THE OPPOSITION
BECAUSE I THINK IT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE REMEMBER. WHAT
IT IS WE STAND FOR AND THAT IS
THE RIGHT FOR EVERY SINGLE.
WOMAN IN THIS STATE. TO DECIDE
FOR HERSELF WHAT HER FUTURE
HOLDS. AND THAT MEANS THE RIGHT
TO SEEK HEALTH CARE FROM
INCREDIBLE DOCTOR DR SANTA PAULA
I WANT TO THANK FOR PROVIDING
THIS HEALTHCARE. EVERY DAY TO
THOSE WHO NEED IT. AND THAT WE
AS A STATE WILL NOT STAND. FOR
FOREIGN STATES TO TELL US WHAT
WILL HAPPEN HERE AND WHAT WILL
HAPPEN TO OUR PROVIDERS. AND OUR
CITIZENS WITHIN OUR STATE
BOUNDARIES BECAUSE HERE. YOU MAY
COM AND WE WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
COMPREHENSIVE HEALTH CARE. AND
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NOT ABOUT. THANK YOU AGAIN MR
QUE HANNAH IS A WHITE MALE
CALIFORNIAN I SUPPORT YOU 100%
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL WOOD I WOULD I WALDRON
WALDRON NO AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA AYE BIGELOW. RIO RIO
AYE FLORA. MAIENSCHEIN MAYES
MCCARTY. THIS AREA NAZARIAN I'D
RIVAS RIVAS AYE RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO. ALL RIGHT
KALRA I. YOU HAVE A BOAT SAYS
THE FIRST BILL OUT TODAY AND I
THINK THAT'S APPROPRIATE THANK.
THANK YOU MR YOU HAVE ANOTHER
BILL. I DO NOT GOING ANYWHERE
SORRY MR SALAS I. I AM NOW WE
WILL TAKE A BABY TWENTY EIGHTY
NINE. I THINK YOU AT MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I AM HAPPY TO
BE HERE TO PRESENT THIS BILL.
WOULD YOU THINK ABOUT THESE
QUESTIONS WHAT SURGERIES OR
HOSPITALIZATIONS HAVE YOU HAD.
HOW OFTEN LAST YEAR HAVE YOU HAD
FIVE OR MORE ALCOHOLIC DRINKS
AND ANYONE OCCASION. WHICH
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITION MEMBERS
OF YOUR FAMILY BEEN DIAGNOSED
WITH. ON A SCALE OF ONE TO THREE
HOW OFTEN DO YOU FEEL AS IF
SOMETHING TERRIBLE MIGHT HAPPEN.
IF YOU ANSWER THESE QUESTIONS IN
A DOCTOR'S OFFICE ANY
INFORMATION INFORMATION
COLLECTED WOULD BE PROTECTED BY
HIPPA. BUT IF YOU ANSWER THESE
QUESTIONS TO CONNECT CONNECT TO
A MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDER THROUGH
AN APP YOUR INFORMATION WILL
ONLY BE PROTECTED BY THE C. PRS.
THIS SERVICE COULD AND DOES
LEGALLY SELL THIS INFORMATION OR
USE IT FR ADVERTISING.
ESPECIALLY SINCE THE PANDEMIC
THE ONLINE MENTAL HEALTH CARE
SPACES EXPLODED WITH AS MANY AS
TWENTY THOUSAND APPS IN THIS
CATEGORY GLOBALLY. FIRST THESE
COMPANIES WILL TARGET THEIR
ADVERTISEMENTS INDIVIDUALS BASED
OFF OF PROBABLE DIAGNOSIS. THEN
THEY WILL REQUIRE A DETAILED
SURVEY WITH QUESTIONS TARGETING
HIGHLY SENSITIVE INFORMATION
LIKE THE ONES I'VE GIVEN YOU.
WE'VE SEEN THESE DATA SHARED
WITH THESE APPS SHOP ACROSS THE
INTERNET AND EVEN SOLD TO THIRD
PARTIES IN THE CASE OF A SUICIDE
SUPPORT TEXTING LINE.  STUDY OF
THE THIRTY SIX TOP RANKED APPS
FOR DEPRESSION AND SMOKING FOUND
THAT TWENTY NINE TRANSMITTED
DATA TO SERVICES PROVIDED BY
FACEBOOK OR GOOGLE. IT IS
CRITICAL TO ENSURE THAT IF
PEOPLE ARE RECEIVING MENTAL
HEALTH CARE THEY KNOW HOW THEIR
DATA IS SHARED AND HOW IT IS
PROTECTED IF AT ALL. THIS BILL
LIMITS COMPANIES FROM SHARING OR
SELLING DATA UNLESS IT IS DE
IDENTIFIED DATA STANDARDS. THE
INFORMATION IS REASONABLY
NECESSARY TO BE SHARED AND THE
CONSUMER AFFIRMATIVELY CONSENTS
TO THE SHARING OF THIS
INFORMATION WHICH IS CRITICAL.
YOU HAVE TO SAY IT IS OKAY TO
SHARE YOUR- MENTAL HEALTH DATA.
THE SECOND PORTION OF THE BILL
REQUIRES THE DEVELOPERS TO
REGISTER WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL WHICH WILL ADDRESS THE
NEED FOR IDENTIFICATION OF THE
GOOD ACTORS IN THE MURKY SPACE.
ESPECIALLY FOR PROVIDERS LIKE
YOU'LL HEAR FROM TODAY. MENTAL
HEALTH CARE IS UNIQUELY
VULNERABLE AND IT IS BECOMING-DIGITAL AND WE MUST PROTECT IT
AS SUCH. WITH ME TODAY IN
SUPPORT IS MAUREEN MAHONEY
SENIOR POLICY ANALYST FOR
CONSUMER REPORTS AND I WILL BE
READING A STATEMENT FROM DR
PALMER SEAL A PSYCHOLOGIST WITH
OVER THIRTY YEARS EXPERIENCE AND
THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA ADVOCACY
COORDINATOR FOR THE AMERICAN
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION.
PLEASE GO AHEAD CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY MY
NAME IS MAUREEN MAHONEY I'M A
SENIOR POLICY ANALYST AT
CONSUMER REPORTS WE APPLAUD THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR INTRODUCING
AB TWENTY EIGHTY NINE BECAUSE IT
WOULD GIVE CONSUMERS HE
PROTECTIONS OVER THE PRIVACY OF
INFORMATION COLLECTED BY MENTAL
HEALTH APPS CONSISTENT WITH
PROTECTIONS OVER THE PRIVACY OF
SUCH DATA COLLECTED IN A MEDICAL
SETTING. MORE PROTECTIONS ARE
NEEDED BECAUSE THE COMPANY TÍNH
PANDEMIC HAS LED TO HIGHER RATES
OF DEPRESSION AND MENTAL ILLNESS
BUT THE SAME TIME IT'S MADE IT
HARDER TO OBTAIN CARE. MANY
CONSUMERS HAVE TURNED TO MENTAL
HEALTH APPS TO FILL THE GAP BUT
BECAUSE THESE APPS ARE
INCONSISTENTLY COVERED BY STRONG
HEALTH PRIVACY LAWS LIKE HIPAA.
IN CMA CONSUMERS ARE VULNERABLE
TO THE INAPPROPRIATE DISCLOSURE
OF THEIR INFORMATION SUCH AS
WELL WHETHER THEY SUFFER FROM
ANXIETY POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS OR
EATING DISORDERS. CONSUMERS AND
THERAPIST LIKE WE HAVE NO IDEA
WHETHER THE DATA WILL BE
ADEQUATELY PROTECTED WHEN USING
A MENTAL HEALTH UP. SOME APPS
COLLECT CONNECT CONSUMERS WITH
LICENSED THERAPIST OVER VIDEO
WHICH WOULD TYPICALLY BE COVERED
BY HEALTH PRIVACY LAWS BUT- THE
SAME APPS ARE SIMILAR SOUNDING
ONES MAY PROVIDE ME TRACKING
DIARIES THERAPY CHAT BOTS. OR
ASK YOU TO COMPLETE A
QUESTIONNAIRE ON YOUR MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM SYMPTOMS WHICH
TYPICALLY WOULD NOT BE COVERED
BY HEALTH PRIVACY LAWS. THIS IS
A PROBLEM BECAUSE CONSUMER
REPORTS TESTING HAS FOUND THAT
MENTAL HEALTH APPS SHARE
INFORMATION ABOUT USERS WITH
TECH COMPANY THE TRACK THEIR
BEHAVIOR ACROSS OTHER APPS. THAT
INFORMATION COULD BE USED TO
TARGET ADS TO YOU BASED ON
INFORMATION ABOUT YOUR MENTAL
HEALTH CONCERNS. CONSUMERS
SHOULD BE ABLE TO REACH OUT FOR
HELP WITHOUT WORRYING ABOUT HOW
THEIR DATA MIGHT BE SHARED-
MISCUES. WHILE IT'S TRUE THAT
THE STATE IS COVERED BY- THE
CALIFORNIA CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT
THIS WAS NOT ADEQUATE TO PROTECT
SUCH SENSITIVE HEALTH DATA. IT
GIVES CONSUMERS THE RIGHT TO OPT
OUT OF THE SALE OF THEIR
INFORMATION BUT THIS BILL IS
MUCH STRONGER BECAUSE IT WOULD
PROHIBIT MOST CASES OF DATA
SHARING. AT ALL AND THIS IS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE MANY CONSUMERS
AREN'T AWARE OF THEIR RIGHTS
UNDER THE CCPA AND WON'T
ACTIVELY REACH OUT TO STOP THE
SELL THEIR INFORMATION. AND ALSO
WE FOUND THAT EVEN WHEN
CONSUMERS DO NOW AND TRY TO OPT
OUT IT CAN BE DIFFICULT FOR THEM
TO DO SO. FINALLY PROPOSITION
TWENTY FOUR AMENDED THE CCPA TO
EXPLICITLY SET A FLOOR NOT A
CEILING ON THE MEASURE IT'S
INTENDED TO BE STRENGTHENED. IN
ORDER TO PROVIDE BETTER PROTECT
CONSUMER PRIVACY AND THIS IS
EXACTLY THE TYPE OF DATA THAT
DESERVES GREATER PROTECTIONS.
FOR THESE REASONS WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE GOALS OF THIS
LEGISLATION AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS TO SECURE KEY
MENTAL HEALTH PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS. FOR CONSUMERS. AND
WITH THE CHAIRS PERMISSION I
WILL READ THE TESTIMONY OF
DOCTOR PAUL MARCEL. LICENSE I
CALL JUST WAS UNABLE TO BE HERE
IN PERSON TODAY. THANK YOU
DOCTOR WOULD TO AN HONORABLE
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY HEALTH
COMMITTEE FOR HAVING ME HERE
TODAY MY NAME IS DR PAUL MARCEL.
I AM A LICENSE A CALIFORNIA
LICENSE ECOLOGISTS AND I AM
PLEASED TO PROVIDE SOME FEEDBACK
ON AB TWENTY EIGHTY NINE. I LIVE
IN HAVE A PRIVATE PRACTICE IN
SARATOGA NEAR SAN JOSE I WORK
WITH BOTH ADOLESCENTS AND ADULTS
AND AS ARE MOST OF MY COLLEAGUES
AT THE MOMENT I AM COMPLETELY
INUNDATED WITH REQUESTS FROM
INDIVIDUALS. SEEKING HELP FOR
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES AS A RESULT
OF THE PANDEMIC. OVER THE LAST
TWENTY FOUR MONTHS I'VE PROVIDED
CARE TO OVER A HUNDRED PATIENTS
DURING THE COPA NINETEEN
PANDEMIC FROM THE AGES OF EIGHT
TO SEVENTY FIVE. I'VE BEEN
MEETING WITH MY PATIENTS
VIRTUALLY TO PROTECT THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF MY PATIENTS AND
MYSELF. WITHOUT THE OPTION OF
MEETING BY VIDEO OR PHONE IT
WOULD HAVE BEEN IMPOSSIBLE TO
ASSIST THESE INDIVIDUALS. MANY
OF MY COLLEAGUES AND I HAVE A
SUCH HOMES WE'VE NEVER EXPECTED
AS MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
DIGITAL PRIVACY. AS PROVIDERS WE
TAKE RULES REGARDING PATIENT
PRIVACY CONFIDENTIAL
CONFIDENTIALITY AND HIPAA
COMPLIANCE VERY SERIOUSLY.
CERTAIN ONLINE SERVICES OFFER
COUNSELING CONNECTIONS OF SLOW
START TIME IS PROVIDERS WITHOUT
MAKING IT CLEAR THAT WHEN WE
CONNECT THROUGH THEM IT'S NOT
THE SAE AS WHEN PATIENTS VISIT
OUR OFFICES WHEN A PATIENT COMES
INTO THE OFFICE I KNOW THAT
EVERY PECE OF PAPER THEY TOUCH
IN EVERY PIECE OF INFORMATION
THEY GIVE ME. AS A LICENSED
MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDER WILL BE
PROTECTED UNDER THE AUSPICES OF
HIPAA AND ANYTHING A PATIENT
SHARES A CONFIDENTIAL I WOULD
NEVER BE SURE WITHOUT THE
WRITTEN PERMISSION. HOWEVER WHEN
WE GO THROUGH SOME OF THE SAME
COMMERCIAL PLATFORMS THE
ADVERTISER SERVICES OR RIGHT OR
WE RECOMMEND AN OP THE COULD BE
USEFUL TO OUR PATIENTS THE DATA
THAT OUR PATIENTS ARE AT THE TOP
AND NOT DIRECTLY TO US IS NOT
PROTECTED BY HIPAA. EVEN THOUGH
THE DATA THEY PROVIDE CAN HELP
THEM RECEIVE CARE FROM HAVE A
COVERED ENTITIES LIKE OURSELVES
A RECEIVE CARE IN LINE WITH THE
CARE FROM THESE ENTITIES IT
REGARDING THEIR PARTICULAR
CONDITIONS ARE PRIVATE PERSONAL
DETAILS REMAIN EXPOSED. MAY BE
SOLD BY THE APAP FORM. WHEN I
RECOMMENDED OCCUPATION I ALWAYS
ENCOURAGE THEM TO VERIFY WHAT
PERSONAL DATA IF ANY. WE SHARED
OR SOLD BY THE POP FORM. BUT
THIS INFORMATION IS OFTEN
DIFFICULT FOR PATIENTS TO OBTAIN
OR FIND IT IS NOT OUR JOB IS
PROVIDERS TO ENSURE EVERY STEP
OF CONSUMER. GOES THROUGH TO
REACH US OR OBTAIN HELP PROTECTS
INFORMATION BUT IS OUR CONCERN.
REACHES OF THE PRIVACY COULD
EVEN BE USED TO FURTHER
EXACERBATE. A PATIENT'S MENTAL
HEALTH. COMPANIES PROMISE ACCESS
TO CARE OUR PROFESSIONAL
CREDIBILITY IS ON THE LINE. WE
WORK WITH INCREDIBLY SENSITIVE
INFORMATION ABOUT OUR CLIENTS
INFORMATION THAT WHEN EXPLOITED
COULD LEAD TO PREDATORY
ADVERTISING OR EMPLOYMENT
DISCRIMINATION. WE DESERVE TO
KNOW THAT WHEN WE USED TO TELL
POP FORMS OR RECOMMEND THEM TO
OUR PATIENTS THEIR EXACTLY AS
SECURE AS OR IN PERSON
DISCUSSION. I BELIEVE IT IS
NECESSARY THAT STRONG GUARDRAILS
ON DATA COLLECTION FOR THIS
POPCORN TO ADOPTED AND I WOULD
ASK THAT YOU VOTE I ON AB
TWENTY. NINE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU M. ARE THERE IS THEIR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. ANY ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION THEY
KNOW WILL GO TO SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION THE BILL FROM MEMBERS
OF THE AUDIENCE WHEN DISASTER
NAME. ADDITION AN ORGANIZATION
IS AVERY WHO LED THE SENATE
CHANGE AND I'M FROM CAMPO THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF MENTAL
HEALTH CARE AND ORGANIZATIONS
AND WE SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. FOR ANYONE ELSE.
IN NO ONE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES NOW MR OPERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR PEOPLE
IF YOU WANT IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL THIS
THEIR NAME POSITION ON THE BILL
AN ORGANIZATION IF THEY
REPRESENT ONE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE.
THEN ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN
ONE THEN ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO
COMMENT AT THIS TIME OKAY THANK
YOU BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SEE
NO ONE WAVING AT ME- I DO
ACTUALLY DO SEE SOMEONE WAVING
AT ME. THIS WALDRON THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN- I'VE WORKED QUITE A
BIT IN THE MENTAL HEALTH. SPACE
AND THROUGH THE YEARS I MEAN ONE
OF THE BIG ISSUES THAT ALWAYS
COMES UP WITH MENTAL HEALTH OF
STIGMA. MAN IF WE HAVE PEOPLE
WHO COME FORWARD. YOU KNOW FOR
TREATMENT. AND THEN LATER. FIND
OUT. BECAUSE THEY'RE GETTING AN
AD FOR SOMETHING THEY'RE LIKE OH
MY GOSH HOW THE SOMEONE THOUGH
IT COULD ACTUALLY. BE YOU KNOW
EVERVERSE. THEY MAY NOT COME
BACK FOR CARE OR YOU KNOW SO I
THINK THAT'S A REALLY IMPORTANT
ISSUE. THE PRIVACY OF THIS-
THEIR THEIR CONDITIONS IN IT AND
LIFESTYLE AND- FAMILY HISTORY
AND ALL THOSE OTHER THINGS.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE. YOU KNOW
WHEN YOU HAVE A MOTION BY MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY A SECOND FIVE
DOCTOR ARAMBULA THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO PRIVACY AND
CONSUMER PROTECTION WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE I'LL TAKE MISS
WALDRON COMMENT AS MIKE THAT'S
RIGHT THANK YOU- MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. WHAT I
WHAT I. OVER OPEN. I DID- I'M
SORRY I COULD SAY IT AGAIN IF
YOU WANT. WALDRON WALDRON.
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
ARAMBULA. RAMBLE I BIGELOW.
CORREO AEREO I FLORA.
MAIENSCHEIN MAYES MCCARTY
MCCARTY I IN THIS AREA. NAZARIAN
I RIVAS RIVAS I RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO KALRA ALL
RIGHT. IN THE ZERO ZERO YOUR
BILL THAT WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR OTHERS THAT ON THINK
I'M ON A ROLL THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- THIS RIVAS SORRY MR SALAS
. OUR BEFORE S. ARAR. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I WANT
TO START BY ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS LISTED ON PAGE TEN OF
THE ANALYSIS I'M CURRENTLY
WORKING WITH CANNABIS
STAKEHOLDERS TO ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS AND PLAN TO REMOVE THEM
FROM THE BILL AT A LATER DATE
AND THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE FOR HELPING ME. WORK
THROUGH THIS BILL. WITH THE
AMENDMENTS OF AB SIXTEEN NINETY
OF THIS BILL WILL TRANSITION THE
SALE OF ALL IN ONE DISPOSABLE
VAPES WHICH ARE NOT RECHARGEABLE
TO REUSABLE OR RECHARGEABLE
SMOKING PRODUCTS TO ADDRESS.
IMPACTS THAT THESE SINGLE USE
PRODUCTS HAVE ON OUR HEALTH AND
ENVIRONMENT. ACCORDING TO THE
CDC THE UNITED STATES IS
EXPERIENCING AN EPIDEMIC OF LUNG
INJURY ASSOCIATED WITH USE.
ELECTRONIC CIGARETTES. USE OF
VAPES IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN OVER
20% OF U. S. HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS REPORTED USING VAPES IN
SCHOOLS INCLUDING CLASSROOMS AND
BATHROOMS. THE USE OF DISPOSABLE
E. CIGARETTES INCREASED ABOUT A
1000% AMONG HIGH SCHOOL E.
CIGARETTE USERS AND TWENTY
TWENTY. TEAMS MAY NOT REALIZE
THAT NICOTINE IS DEEPLY
ADDICTIVE THE NICOTINE FROM
THESE VAPE PRODUCTS CAN SPELL
TROUBLE AT ANY LIFE STAGE BUT
IT'S DANGEROUS BEFORE THE AGE OF
TWENTY FIVE BECAUSE THE BRAIN IS
NOT FULLY DEVELOPED. NICOTINE
ACTUALLY CHANGES ADOLESCENT'S
BRAIN CELL ACTIVITY IN THE PARTS
OF THE BRAIN RESPONSIBLE FOR
ATTENTION LEARNING AND MEMORY.
IT CAN ALSO WORSEN ANXIETY.
STUDIES HAVE FOUND THAT IT
CONTAINS THE LETTER AND VOLATILE
ORGANIC COMPOUNDS SOME OF WHICH
ARE LINKED TO CANCER. AS VAPE
USAGE SURGES IN THE UNITED
STATES THEY OFTEN OVERLOOKED FOR
THE FIRE DANGER THAT THEY POSE
FOR WASTE AND RECYCLING WORKERS.
ACCORDING TO THE FDA VAPES CAN
CATCH ON FIRE OR EXPLODED
SERIOUSLY HURT PEOPLE. A VAPE
PENS MAIN SAFETY ISSUE LIES IN
THE LITHIUM ION BATTERY IT
CONTAINS TO FUEL THE HEATING
ELEMENT OR A ADAM ATOMIZER.
RUSSIA HAS HOW TO SAY THAT-
LITHIUM ION BATTERIES ARE QUITE
POWERFUL AND SPARK THERMAL
EVENTS ARE FIRES WHEN THEY'RE
DAMAGED. THE SHAPING
CONSTRUCTION OF ELECTRONIC
CIGARETTES CAN MAKE THEM BEHAVE
LIKE FLAMING ROCKETS WHEN A
BATTERY FAILS. BETWEEN JANUARY
TWO THOUSAND NINE AND DECEMBER
THIRTY FIRST TWENTY SIXTEEN
HUNDRED AND NINETY FIVE SEPARATE
INCIDENTS OF EXPLOSION AND FIRE
INVOLVING AN ELECTRONIC
CIGARETTES WERE REPORTED BY THE
U. S. MEDIA. 62% OF THE
INCIDENCE OF EXPLOSION.
INVOLVING AN ELECTRONIC
CIGARETTE OR ITS BATTERY
OCCURRED WHEN THE DEVICE WAS
EITHER IN A POCKET- ACTIVELY IN
USE ADDITIONALLY VAPES CAN ALSO
CONTAIN HEAVY METALS BATTERY
ACID NICOTINE AND OTHER HARMFUL
CHEMICALS. IMPROPERLY DISPOSING
OF THESE ALL IN ONE DISPOSABLE
BABES ARE KNOWN TO LEACH TOXIC
CHEMICALS INTO THE ENVIRONMENT
POLLUTE WATER AND HARM WILDLIFE
THE MICROPLASTICS AND HAZARDOUS
CHEMICALS THAT LEACH FROM THIS
VAPE WASTE ACCUMULATES IN THE
FOOD CHAIN AND AFFECTS WHOLE
ECOSYSTEMS INCLUDING THE HEALTH
OF SOILS. CURRENT LAW PASSED IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE AND A. B.
NINE THIRTY NINE SAID OUR WASTE
HIERARCHY AT SOURCE REDUCTION
FIRST THEN RECYCLING. REUSABLE
REUSABLE VAPES ARE ALREADY
WIDELY AVAILABLE ON THE MARKET
AND OUR LAST WASTEFUL
ALTERNATIVE AND ALIGN WITH
CALIFORNIA'S WASTE HIERARCHY. BY
MOVING AWAY FROM ALL IN ONE
DISPOSABLE VAPES VAPES THE
SMOKING INDUSTRY WILL BE DRIVEN
TO TRANSITION THEIR PRODUCTS TO
BE LAST WASTEFUL. TODAY I HAVE
HEIDI SANBORN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE NATIONAL STEWARDSHIP
ACTION COUNCIL SERVING AS OUR
WITNESS THANK YOU. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MEMBER RIVAS CHAIR AND MEMBERS
I'M HEIDI SANBORN EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE NATIONAL
STEWARDSHIP ACTION COUNCIL A
NONPROFIT THAT ADVOCATES FOR
CIRCULAR AND EQUITABLE ECONOMY
AND WE ARE THE SPONSOR OF AB
SIXTEEN NINETY. AS DISCUSSED
BOTH COMMITTEES SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN ACCEPTED
AND THE PROPOSED SIXTEEN NINETY
YOU'LL BE VOTING ON TODAY IS
DIFFERENT THAN THE BILL AND
PRINT. THEREFORE ONLY FOCUS ON
THE AMENDED VERSION AND SINGLE
USE VAPING PRODUCTS IN MY
TESTIMONY. NON RECHARGEABLE
VAPING DEVICES INCLUDE A BATTERY
THAT CANNOT BE REMOVED TO
RECHARGE. BATTERIES ARE
CONSIDERED UNIVERSAL WASTE IN
CALIFORNIA AND ARE PROHIBITED
FROM DISPOSAL. HOWEVER MANY NON
RECHARGEABLE ELECTRONIC VAPING
DEVICES WE FIND ONLINE. ARE
ADVERTISED AND LABELED AS
DISPOSABLE WHICH IMPLIES THAT
THEY CAN BE DISPOSED OF IN THE
TRASH. THE FOR MANY CONSUMERS DO
NOT KNOW THAT THEY ARE HAZARDOUS
AND YOU THROW THEM IN THE TRASH
IN THE RECYCLING ILLEGALLY. THE
FREQUENT TOSLINK CRUSHING AND
SHREDDING IN THE WASTE AND
RECYCLING STREAMS CAN CAUSE
BATTERIES TO BE DAMAGE AND
IGNITE CATCHING FIRE TO ADJACENT
MATERIALS. AND VAPING VIA
DISPOSABLE PRODUCTS ON A QUOTE
IS ON THE RISE FOR BOTH TOBACCO
AND CANNABIS PRODUCTS. AMONG USE
CIGARETTES ESPECIALLY
DISPOSABLES ARE MORE POPULAR
THAN TRADITIONAL TOBACCO
PRODUCTS ACCORDING TO THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE NATIONAL YOUTH
TOBACCO SURVEY MORE THAN TWO
MILLION U. S. MIDDLE AND HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS REPORTED USING
E. CIGARETTES IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. NON RECHARGEABLE VAPES ARE
MORE AFFORDABLE AND THEREFORE
MORE ACCESSIBLE TO CHILDREN AND
TEENS. THE USE OF DISPOSABLE E.
CIGARETTES INCREASED MORE THAN
4100% IN MIDDLE SCHOOL THE
MIDDLE SCHOOLERS THAT USE E.
CIGARETTES IN TWENTY TWENTY.
REGARDING THE ENVIRONMENTAL AND
PUBLIC HEALTH IMPACTS OF NON
RECHARGEABLE VAPING PRODUCTS.
NUMBER RIVAS MENTIONED SOME
POINTS AD I'LL ADD A FEW MORE
ONE ELECTRONIC VAPING PRODUCTS
ARE PROPERLY DISPOSED IN THE
ENVIRONMENT TOXINS AND PLASTICS
LEACH INTO OUR ENVIRONMENT AND
IMPACT PEOPLE AND WILDLIFE
WITHOUT THE ABILITY TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES FROM EXPOSURE. JUST
THIS WEEK LAST WEEK IT WAS
REPORTED THAT RESEARCHERS HAVE
FOUND MICROPLASTICS IN HUMAN
BLOOD FOR THE FIRST TIME. WITH
SCIENTISTS FINDING TINY
PARTICLES AND ALMOST 80% OF THE
PEOPLE TESTED. ADDITIONALLY THE
STATE WIDE OCEAN PROTECTION
COUNCIL ADOPTED ON FEBRUARY
TWENTY THIRD THE FIRST IN THE
NATION STATEWIDE MICROPLASTICS
STRATEGY WHICH INCLUDED THE
RECOMMENDATION TO PROHIBIT THE
SALE OF SINGLE USE TOBACCO
PRODUCTS THE DEMONSTRABLY
CONTRIBUTE TO TOBACCO PRODUCTS
PLASTIC POLLUTION. INCLUDING BUT
NOT LIMITED TO ELECTRONIC
CIGARETTES. ADDITIONALLY THIS
CALIFORNIA SIXTEEN MEMBER
STATEWIDE RECYCLING COMMISSION
WHICH I CHAIR VOTED UNANIMOUSLY
TO APPROVE A POLICY
RECOMMENDATION THAT QUOTE SOME
PRODUCTS OR JUST TOXIC AND
UNNECESSARY AND HAVE SAFER AND
CHEAPER ALTERNATIVES. MAKING
THEIR SALE UNNECESSARY AND
COSTLY. INCLUDING SINGLE USE
VAPING PRODUCTS THE COMMISSION
INCLUDES REPRESENT OF SOME
GOVERNMENTS WASTE HAULERS
NONPROFITS AND UNIONS. THREE
THANK THE HEALTH COMMITTEE
STAFFER THERE- HELP AND HOPE
THAT THIS AMENDED VERSION WILL
PASS OUT OF COMMITTEE TODAY AND
I WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WAS RIVAS COUNTY VETERAN NORRIS
AND MARK STONE FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS BILL. THE TWO
PRINCIPAL COAUTHORS CRISTINA
GARCIA AND FOLK THING AS WELL AS
THE SIXTEEN OTHER CO AUTHORS
INCLUDING MEMBER MCCARTY AND
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY MAYBE
SIXTEEN NINETY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. IS THERE OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL. YOU KNOW IN THE
AUDIENCE WILL GO AHEAD AND TAKE
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION- MR NAME
POSITION ON THE BILL IN ANY
ORGANIZATION IF YOU REPRESENT
ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS PERSONAL HEROES ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA PRODUCT
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL ALAMEDA STOP
WICKS CALIFORNIA KARAMEA CHILD
AND ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY AND
WESTERN PLASTER WASTE MANAGEMENT
THIRTY ON SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU- THE ONE REPRESENTING
TO HELP OFFICERS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE. YOU KNOW WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINES NOW- IT MISTRUST
WRITER SO WE'RE TAKING SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION JUST YOUR NAME
POSITION ON THE BILL AN
ORGANIZATION IF YOU REPRESENT
ONE. YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO THAT COMMAND AGAIN ONE
SEVEN ZERO. AND FIRST WE WILL GO
TO LINE ONE HUNDRED THIRTY. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
CAROLYN COULD PRESENTING
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE
STUDENTS TO FIND SUPPORT OF AB
SIXTY NINETY. YOUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. LINE. TWENTY GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS ANY
GOVERNMENTAL ON BEHALF OF
FREAKING GREAT AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. LINE ONE EIGHTY
NINE. OUR BARBARA GORDON USE
THAT- I AM IN SUPPORT OF AB
SIXTEEN NINETY THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. LINE TWO HUNDRED
SIX. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THIS
IS ALEX KESSLER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANKS CALLER PLEASE. WELL I
KNOW ONE HUNDRED SIX. THEY'RE
ONLY HALF OF AMERICANS FOR SAFE
ACCESS WE REMAIN OPPOSED TO THE
BILL UNTIL SUCH TIME AS MEDICAL
CANNABIS DEVICES ARE REMOVED
THANK YOU. THANKS CALLER COULD.
LINE TWO HUNDRED SEVEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
HIS INITIAL FULLER WITH ERIN
REED AND ASSOCIATES AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE PEOPLE
THERE IS RESEARCH ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA PORAC AND BASED ON
THE IMMINENT TAKEN TODAY PARK
WILL LIKELY BE REMOVING OUR
OPPOSITION AB SIXTY NINETY THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. FINAL. ONE NINETY ONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THIS IS AND RIDDLED I SERVE AS
THE CHAIR OF THE MENTAL HEALTH
COMMITTEE FOR THE NORTH COAST OF
PARENT ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB SIXTY NINE
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. LINE. TWO HUNDRED
TWO. THIS IS DIANE GRACE IN
STRONG SUPPORT- THIS BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
. LINE A ONE NINETY. MORGAN
ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURING TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION WERE LISTED AS AN
OPPOSE POSITION BUT WITH THE-
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS WILL LIKELY
BE REMOVING OUR OR OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. LINE. ONE SEVENTY THREE.
PAGE BECKY RAP BUT PARENTS
UNITED AGAINST SMOKING AND
VAPING AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
AB SIXTEEN NINETY THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
WHY NO. ONE NINETY FOUR. YEAH
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS IN THE TANK AND ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
TWENTY SIX REACTOR GRATITUDE TO
THE AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS FOR
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH AND THE
INDUSTRY AND APPRECIATE THE
ANNOUNCEMENT TODAY ABOUT THE
UPCOMING AMENDMENTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANKS CALLER PLEASE.
I KNOW ONE FIFTY ONE. GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT DAY THE BRENDA
BASSETT WENT BACK CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE WE WERE
LOOKING AT AND OPPOSED BY BASED
ON THE AMENDMENTS LETTERS THAT
HAVE BEEN TAKEN CARE WE WILL
LIKELY BE REMOVING OUR
OPPOSITION AS WELL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
MEMBERS MY NAME IS THE HOLY CARE
AND ON BEHALF OF THE SURFRIDER
FOUNDATION WERE IN SUPPORT OF AB
SIXTY NINETY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WIND TO
TEN. HELLO JERRY MEMBERS THIS IS
JORDAN WELLS ON BEHALF OF THE
DOZEN ORGANIZATIONS THAT MAKE UP
THE CLEAN SEAS LOBBYING
COALITION AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU I THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. WHY AM TO ELEVEN.
HELLO THIS IS KELLY MCCORMICK
FROM THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE ON
MENTAL HEALTH WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB SIXTEEN NINETY THANK
YOU THANK YOU. X. OUR PLACE.
NINE TO TWELVE. GOOD AFTERNOON
SURE NUMBERS JIM LINDBERG ON
BEHALF OF THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. AND MISTER CHAIR
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. I HAVE I DO HAVE SOME
COMMENTS AND SO I WILL GO AHEAD-
I SUFFERS FROM A THANK YOU. FOR
ALL YOUR HARD WORK ON ON THIS
BILL. IT IS IT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE. WE NEED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE A CIGARETTE ****
ARE. QUITE LIKELY THE MOST
LITTERED LITTERED ITEM ON THE
PLANET. SMOKING IS MY ENEMY I'VE
BEEN A PASSION ANTI SMOKING
ADVOCATE MY ENTIRE LIFE. THE MY
VERSION TO SMOKING- MADE THIS
BILL PARTICULARLY CHALLENGING.
REPEATEDLY SHOW MYSELF AS A
PROTECTOR OF THE ENVIRONMENT SO
ONE WOULD THINK I WOULD BE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE BILL- POWER MY
CONCERN THE CONCERN THAT MANY
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE BROUGHT TO
ME IS THAT BANNING. THE PRODUCT
WOULD SIMPLY NOT SOLVE THE
LITTER PROBLEM THAT'S WHAT I'M
TALKING ABOUT THE FILTERS AND
THE CIGARETTES SO. CIGARETTES
WILL CONTINUE TO BE SMUGGLED
INTO THE STATE OR PURCHASED
OUTSIDE THE STATE. SOVEREIGN
TRIBES COULD STILL SELL
CIGARETTES THAT WITH FILTERS ON
THEIR LAND. THAT MEANS BANNING
THE PRODUCT WOULD NOT STOP
LITTERING OR SMOKING IN
CALIFORNIA. I THINK WE NEED A
DIFFERENT SOLUTION TO LITTERING
LITTER PROBLEM. AND I HAVE
CONFIDENCE THAT THE AUTHOR CAN
DO THAT- AS WE OFFER THESE
AMENDMENTS WHICH YOU HAVE
ACCEPTED BUT I THANK YOU FOR
THAT. I THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
WORKING WITH ME ON THIS BILL-
THE BILL. AS AMENDED AS AS
YOU'VE ACCEPTED- DOES ENJOY DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION IT WOULD BE
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE- IS THERE A
MOTION. MOTION BY MISTAKE OR
CARRY A SECOND BY MISS CARILLO.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE I HOPE THAT IN THE FUTURE
WILL BE ABLE TO WORK. TOGETHER
ON A SOLUTION ON CIGARETTE
FILTERS- I'D LIKE TO THANK HEIDI
SANBORN IN THE NATIONAL
STEWARDSHIP ACTION COUNCIL FOR
A- PARTNERSHIP. ON THIS BILL AND
THE HARD WORK THAT. SHE AND THE
ORGANIZATION HAVE PUT IN. BOB
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS THANK YOU. THEY GIVE US
RIVAS- AND THEY GET YOUR
WITNESS- MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL WHAT I WOULD AYE
WALDRON. WALDRON NO AGUIAR-CURRY
. AGUIAR-CURRY AYE ARAMBULA.
BIGELOW RIO RIO AYE FLORA.
MAIENSCHEIN MAYES MCCARTY
MCCARTY HI IN THIS AREA.
NAZARIAN I REQUEST AYE REVERSE
AYE RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE
SANTIAGO ALL RIGHT ALL RIGHT HI. EIGHT YOUR BILL IS A VOTES
IT'S OUT WE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OF THE BROTHERS AT ODDS. THANK
YOU. MISTER CELIS.
THANK YOU MISTER SALAS PROCEED
WHEN READY ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS A PRESENT AB
TWENTY SIX SIXTY SIX WHICH
DOUBLES AS A GRANT PROGRAM TO
PROVIDE STIPENDS TO MENTAL
HEALTH STUDENTS WORKING IN
INTERNSHIPS AND COMPLETING
LICENSURE HOURS WITH NO PAY
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
FUTURE HEALTH WORKFORCE
COMMISSION JUST ONE THIRD OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO LIVE WITH A
MENTAL ILLNESS RECEIVE THE CARE
THEY NEED TO DO A SHORTAGE OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE WORKERS.
ONLY TWO OF CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY
SIX COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH PLANS
MEET ACCESS REQUIREMENTS AND
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE SHORTAGE
THAT EXISTED PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC AND NOW HAS ONLY
WORSENED THE COST OF GETTING
HEALTH EDUCATION MEETING ALL
LICENSURE REQUIREMENTS ACTS AS A
BARRIER TO ENTRY FOR THOSE
INTERESTED IN THE PROVIDE IN
INTERESTED IN THE PROFESSION
ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT COME FROM
LOW INCOME BACKGROUNDS AB TWENTY
SIX SIXTY SIX WILL REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE ACCESS
AND INFORMATION TO ESTABLISHMENT
. GRANT PROGRAM PROVIDES SAVINGS
TO STUDENTS AND BEHAVIOR HEALTH
FIELDS OF STUDY WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING IN UNPAID
INTERNSHIPS ARE COMPLETING THEIR
UNPAID LICENSURE HOURS AB TWENTY
SIX SIXTY SIX ONE PREVENTIVE
HEALTH TREATMENT ACCESS IN
CALIFORNIA HELP THOSE
PROFESSIONALS THAT ARE
STRUGGLING TO FINISH THEIR
EDUCATION BEGIN THE WORK OF
HEALING PER COMMUNITIES WITH ME
TO TESTIFY TODAY IS JENNIFER
ALLEY WITH CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF MARRIAGE AND
FAMILY THERAPIST. THANK YOU-
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU-
THE LITTLE BUTTON THAT SAYS MY
COMMENT MY BAD SORRY THE FIRST
TIME IN THE NEW HEARING ROOM SO-
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M JENNIFER ALI
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPIST
WHO REPRESENT THIRTY FOUR
THOUSAND LICENSE AND PRE
LICENSED AMERICAN FAMILY
THERAPIST IN THE STATE SO IN
ORDER TO BECOME A MARRIAGE AND
FAMILY THERAPIST YOU A QUITE YOU
KNOW COMPLETE YOUR MASTER'S
DEGREE- YOU TAKE AN EXAM AND
REGISTER WITH THE BOARD OF
BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES WITHIN YOUR
REACH- REQUIRED TO COMPLETE
THREE THOUSAND CLINICAL HOURS OF
EXPERIENCE- IN ORDER TO TAKE
YOUR LICENSING EXAM. AND QUITE
FREQUENTLY THOSE THREE THOUSAND
HOURS MAY BE UNPAID. SO- ANY
TIME THAT THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR OUR MEMBERS TO BE
REIMBURSED- WHILE COMPLETING
THEIR THREE THOUSAND HOURS-
WE'RE OBVIOUSLY GOING TO BE
SUPPORTIVE. YOU KNOW ONCE YOU
COMPLETE YOUR EDUCATION SIX
MONTHS AFTER GRADUATION YOU'RE
REQUIRED TO START MAKING
PAYMENTS ON YOUR STUDENT LOANS
AND SO WHILE YOU'RE- TRYING TO
YOU KNOW. FILL YOUR LOAN
OBLIGATIONS TO COMPLETE YOUR
THREE THOUSAND HOURS IT IS A
QUITE BURDENSOME FOR OUR
ASSOCIATES AND IS ACTUALLY THE
WEAKEST SPOT IN THE LICENSE YOUR
PRICE. A PIPELINE I'M IN SO TO
HELP INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
LICENSED PROFESSIONALS IN THE
STATE- WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS-
INTERNSHIP GRANT PROGRAMS
REQUEST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION IN THE
AUDIENCE. AND IF THERE'S A
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
COME FORWARD. SUPPORT OKAY
PERSONAL COULD ALSO BE HALF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
PSYCHIATRISTS IN STRONG SUPPORT. OKAY NOTHING ANYONE ELSE IN
THE ROOM WE CAN GO TO THE PHONE
LINES AND- PLEASE LIMIT TO NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ONLY.
FOUR COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO THAT COMMAND AGAIN ONE
ZERO. FIRST WE'LL GO TO LINE
TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON REBEKAH GONZALEZ
NATIONALIST ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN STRONG SUPPORT TO
DISPEL. THANK YOU. AND WE DO
HAVE A COUPLE MORE PEOPLE
QUEUING UP ONE MOMENT PLEASE
WHILE WE PROVIDE THEM WITH LINE
NUMBERS.
AND OUTLINED IT TO FIFTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO SIR
MEMBERS IN THAT MACHINE ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WITH THE SUPPORT IF
AMENDED PETITION THANK YOU THANK
YOU. AN OUTLINE A ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHANGE AND
WHAT THE CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM
OF ADDICTION PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONALS IN SUPPORT OF. AND
WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU WE DO HAVE
A MOTION IN THE SECOND ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. NOT SEEING
ANY WITH THE AUTHOR LIKE TO
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU AND
A SO WE HAVE TO DO PASSED TO
HIGHER EDUCATION. AND WE HAVE A
MOTION SO SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. WHAT. WALDRON HI
WALDRON I AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE ARAMBULA.
BIGELOW CORREO I LARA.
MAIENSCHEIN MAYES MCCARTY
MCCARTY I'D NAZARIAN. NAZARIAN I
RIVAS RIVAS AYE RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO. KALRA ALL
RIGHT I. IF YOUR BILL HAS EIGHT
VOTE SUIT PASSES WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OFTEN FOR FURTHER ADD ONS
THANK YOU. I SEE MR STONE. OUT
THERE IN THE AUDIENCE. THE SHIP
. OKAY SO YOU'RE GONNA WAIT I
DON'T KNOW SO WE DON'T HAVE
ANYONE ELSE RIGHT NOW.
WE HAVE TO WAIT FOR. THE
CHAIRMAN OR ANOTHER AUTHOR. IN
THE MEANTIME WILL JUMP TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AND GET THOSE
VOTES. THEIR SECOND SECONDS
CAREER.
OKAY WE WILL TAKE A VOTE ON
CONSENT CALENDAR OF. I AM SEVEN
AB TWO ZERO SEVEN TWO GABRIEL
ITEM NINE AB TWO ZERO THREE TWO
EDUARDO GARCIA. ADAM LEVIN AB
TWO SIX FOUR EIGHT GRAYSON. IDM
FOURTEEN A. B. TWO TWO NINE
EIGHT MAYES AN ITEM TWENTY ONE
AB TWO ONE TWO SEVEN SANTIAGO.
AND THE MOST SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WHAT WOULD I. WALDRON
AYE WALDRON AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE ARAMBULA.
BIGELOW MARIA HI FLORA
MAIENSCHEIN MAYES MCCARTY
MCCARTY I IN THIS AREA THIS AREA
AND I REQUEST. RIVERSIDE
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO
OUR OUR HIGH. NINE THIS YEAR.
CONSENT CALENDAR NINE TO ZERO
WILL ADD ON LATER AND OUR
CHAIRMAN HAS ARRIVED FOR ITEM
TWENTY FOUR AB TWO TWO SEVEN
FIVE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
PRESENT AB TWENTY TWO SEVENTY
FIVE. AS HEALTH COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I DON'T HAVE TO TELL YOU
THE NUMBER OF BILLS WE HAVE SEEN
OVER THE PAST YEARS WITH
SUGGESTED CHANGES TO THE LANDER
MEANT THAT FOR SHORT ACT. WHILE
WE INTENDED THE WELL WELL WELL
INTENDED THESE PROPOSALS TENDED
TO ADDRESS SINGLE ASPECTS OF LPS
RATHER THAN AT THE BROADER MORE
SYSTEMIC SYSTEMIC ISSUES OF A
FIFTY FIVE YEAR OLD PROGRAM THAT
TO MY KNOWLEDGE. HAS NEVER HAD A
FULL EVALUATION OR REPORT.
THAT'S WHY LAST DECEMBER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE AND I
AGREED TO CONDUCT A JOINT
HEARING ON THE L. P. S. ACT.
AFTER NEARLY NINE HOURS OF
TESTIMONY AND DISCUSSION. IT WAS
APPARENT THAT THE SYSTEM NEEDS
ADDRESSING. MOST ALARMING WAS
THE LACK OF CLARITY AND
CONSISTENCY IN SOME BASIC ACTS
ASPECTS OF THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE ACT. INCONSISTENCIES THAT
RESULT IN PEOPLE BEING DETAINED
ON FIFTY ONE FIFTY HOLDS.
TREATED DIFFERENTLY DEPENDING ON
WHERE THEY RESIDE OR HOW THINGS
ARE INTERPRETED. THE SECOND MOST
ALARMING REVELATION WAS THE
ALMOST COMPLETE LACK OF DATA.
EITHER REAL TIME OR HISTORICAL.
HOW CAN A SYSTEM THAT IS
DESIGNED TO PROTECT AND SERVE
OUR MOST VULNERABLE POPULATION
HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO DATA. ON
WHICH TO ASSESS ITS
EFFECTIVENESS. HOW CAN WE AS A
LEGISLATURE BE CALLED UPON TO DO
THE RIGHT THING ON BEHALF OUR
CITIZENS WE DON'T KNOW WHAT WE
DON'T KNOW. AB TWENTY TWO
SEVENTY FIVE IS A RELATIVELY
SIMPLE BILL AND DEFEND
DEFINITELY A WORK IN PROGRESS.
FROM THE DATA PERSPECTIVE WE
HAVE LAID OUT A REPORTING
FRAMEWORK AND CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH A GROUP OF STAKEHOLDERS TO
SPECIFY EXACTLY WHAT DATA SHOULD
SHOULD BE REQUIRED FROM THE
COUNTIES. THE FACILITIES THE L.
E. O.'S AND OTHERS. THIS BILL
WILL CONTINUE TO EVOLVE. MR
STONE JOINT AUTHOR IS HERE TO
ADDRESS THE PERSON THE MORE
PROCEDURAL CHANGES THIS BILL
WILL ACCOMPLISH THROUGH
CLARIFICATION OF EXISTING LPS
ACT LPS REQUIREMENTS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER STUFF. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS AN
ELEMENTAL BILL. AND IT'S ONE
THAT COMES AFTER VERY LONG
HEARING AND A LOT OF DEBATE OVER
. HOW THE LPS SYSTEM IS AND
ISN'T WORKING AND ONE OF THE- AS
THE CHAIR POINTS OUT. DATA
COLLECTION AND UNDERSTANDING
WHAT WE DO AND DO NOT KNOW IS A
REAL GAP HERE. THE DUE PROCESS
CONSIDERATIONS WHICH ARE THAT
PART OF THIS THAT ARE RELEVANT
TO MY COMMITTEE ARE VERY
SIGNIFICANT DUE TO
INCONSISTENCIES IN
INTERPRETATION OF LPS ACROSS THE
STATE. AREAS INDIVIDUALS
DEPENDING ON WHERE THEY ARE
WHICH COUNTY THERE IN AND WHERE
THOSE. INTERPRETATIONS ARE
HAPPENING CAN BE BEING HELD. ON
BEYOND WHAT THE STATUTE ACTUALLY
ALLOWS. AND IN SOME INSTANCES
THERE TREATED A LOT MORE FAIRLY
SO WE HAVE SOME SIGNIFICANT
INCONSISTENCIES AND THAT IS ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WE THAT THIS
BILL IS WORKING TO TRY AND CLEAN
UP. IS MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
THE CONSISTENT APPLICATION IF
WE'RE GOING TO BE USING. THAT
WITH THE CARE COURT PROPOSAL
WITH A LOT OF OTHER PROPOSALS
AROUND CONSERVATIVES THAT HAVE
BEEN COMING OUT LPS SYSTEM IS
ULTIMATELY THE FOUNDATIONS THE
BACKSTOPS. TO ALL OF THIS SOME
OF THE PROPOSALS IT'S UNCLEAR.
MIKE TRIED TO AMEND THE LPS
SYSTEM WHICH IS A BIT
FRUSTRATING SINCE WE DON'T HAVE
THE DATA TO KNOW REALLY WHAT WE
NEED TO AMEND YET. WAR THEY'RE
GOING TO RELY ON THE LPS SYSTEM
BEING THAT. BACKSTOPS TO THE
FRIEND AND SERVICES THAT THEY
WANT TO PROVIDE. SO IF WE
HAVEN'T CLARIFIED AND DON'T HAVE
CONSISTENT APPLICATION OF THE
LPS SYSTEM. WE'RE POTENTIALLY
HEADED FOR SOME REFORMS THAT
WILL. BE A BIT OF ACCORDION NOT
UNFORTUNATELY. SO HI THIS IS.
IMPORTANT WORK ITS REALLY
FOUNDATIONAL WORK IS ONE OF THE
REASONS WE'RE DOING THIS
TOGETHER. AND I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR STONE- WE HAVE TWO
WITNESSES TO SPEAK TO A TO THE
BILL TODAY MICHELLE CABRERA.
WITH THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION AND
DEBORAH OFF WITH DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU SO
MUCH CHAIRS MICHELLE CABINET I
WITH THE- COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA. CBH DA MEMBERS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE DELIVERY OF
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER SERVICES IN OUR PUBLIC
SAFETY NET. PARTICULARLY FOR
CHILDREN AND ADULTS WITH
SIGNIFICANT NEEDS INCLUDING
OVERSIGHT AT THE LOCAL LEVEL OF
THE LPS ACT. CBH DA HAS A
SUPPORTING CONCEPT ON AB TWO TWO
SEVEN FIVE AND I WANT TO THANK
THE CHAIRS AND THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THE THOUGHTFUL
APPROACH TO POTENTIAL CHANGES TO
THE LPS ACT. STARTING WITH THE
FOUNDATIONAL INFORMATIONAL AND
OVERSIGHT HEARING IN THE FALL
AND CULMINATING WITH THIS BILL.
FIRST I WANT TO SAY THAT OUR
MEMBERS TAKE THEIR OVERSIGHT
RESPONSIBILITIES UNDER LPS LAW
VERY SERIOUSLY. OUR MEMBERS
UNDERSTAND BOTH THE AWESOME
RESPONSIBILITIES AFFORDED TO
THEM IN DETERMINING WHEN AND HOW
AN INDIVIDUAL'S RIGHTS CAN BE
REMOVED. AS WELL AS THE
PROTECTION OF HUMAN LIFE WHEN AN
INDIVIDUAL MAY BE A RISK TO
THEMSELVES OR OTHERS DUE TO
THEIR MENTAL HEALTH CONDITION.
WELL COUNTIES ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR DETERMINING WHO MAY PLACE
AND REMOVE HOLDS AND
COORDINATION WITH OUR PUBLIC
GUARDIANS TO ARRANGE FOR
TREATMENT SERVICES FOR MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES WE SHARE
OVERLAPPING ROLES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES WITH VARIOUS
OTHER SYSTEMS AND ENTITIES
INCLUDING LAW ENFORCEMENT.
HOSPITALS COMMERCIAL HEALTH
PLANS AND MEDICARE MANAGED CARE
PLANS. EXISTING REPORTING
STRUCTURES FALL SHORT BECAUSE
THEY FEEL TO RECOGNIZE THIS
COMPLEXITY. NOT ALL LPS
ACTIVITIES HAPPEN IN THE CONTEXT
OF DESIGNATED FACILITIES AND
COUNTY BEER HALL DOES NOT HAVE
THE AUTHORITY UNDER CURRENT LAW
TO COMPEL OUR PARTNERS. WHETHER
LAW ENFORCEMENT HOSPITAL OR
HEALTH PLANS. TO PROVIDE THAT
INFORMATION TO US SO THAT WE CAN
IN TURN PROVIDE A COMPLETE
PICTURE OF INVOLUNTARY HOLDS AND
TREATMENT TO THE STATE. WE'RE
EXCITED ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITY
THAT AB TWO TWO SEVEN FIVE
PRESENTS FOR S. TO MAKE
MEANINGFUL PRODUCT PROGRESS IN
ANSWERING A SIMPLE BUT IMPORTANT
SET OF QUESTIONS. WHO IS PLACED
ON HOLD. FOR HOW LONG AND WHAT
HAPPENS TO THEM. WE BELIEVE THAT
BASIC MACRO LEVEL DATA CAN HELP
THE STATE TO BEGIN TO UNDERSTAND
WHETHER AND WHEN INVOLUNTARY
TREATMENT IS USED AND HOW
EFFECTIVE IT MAY BE. TO THE
INDIVIDUALS WE SERVE AS WELL AS
OUR SYSTEMIC PARTNERS WELL I
MEMBERS HAVE CONCERNS WITH SOME
OF THE LANGUAGE AS IT IS
CURRENTLY WRITTEN IN THE BILL WE
BELIEVE THAT OUR GOALS ALIGNED
WITH THOSE OF THE AUTHORS AND
BALANCING TRANSPARENCY
ACCOUNTABILITY. AND TRYING TO
STANDARDIZE PRACTICES ACROSS THE
STATE SO WE'RE VERY EAGER TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHORS AND
ACHIEVE THOSE AIMS THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND I'M HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU MADAM. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR ART DEBRA
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA- WE
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE WHAT ARE
CHAIR WOULD ENSURE STONE ARE ARE
DOING WITH THIS BILL- I THOUGHT
THE HEARING WENT OVER NINE HOURS
IT WAS DEFINITELY ONE OF THE
LONGEST LEGISLATIVE HEARINGS I
HAVE EVER WITNESSED. AND IT WAS
SUCH AN IMPORTANT REVIEW OF THE
LAND TERMAN PETROUS SHORT ACT.
AND AT THIS POINT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO REALIZE THAT THIS
BILL THAT THE PART THAT I'M
GOING TO TALK ABOUT HIS. NOT SO
MUCH THE DATA. BUT TO CLARIFY
WHAT IT MEANS TO PUT SOMEONE ON
A FIFTY ONE FIFTY A SEVENTY TWO
HOUR HOLD. IT REALLY TREATS
PEOPLE UNFAIRLY AND TAKES AWAY
RIGHTS ACROSS COUNTY LINES
DEPENDING ON WHICH FACILITY
YOU'VE BEEN TAKEN TO AND HOW
THINGS UNFOLD AFTER THAT. SO
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS IT
CLARIFIES THAT THE SEVENTY TWO
HOUR CLOCK. STARTS TO RUN. THE
MOMENT YOU ARE DETAINED SEEMS
LIKE A PRETTY SIMPLE CONCEPT BUT
WHAT WE FIND IS IN REALITY IS
THAT IF A PERSON IS TAKEN TO A
FACILITY THAT IS NOT THE COUNTY
DESIGNATED FACILITY. THEY MAY
LANGUAGE THERE UNTIL A TRANSFER
IS NAY IS ABLE TO BE AFFECTED
AND SOMETIMES THAT COMES CLOSE
TO OR EVEN PASSED THE SAID THE
INITIAL SEVENTY TWO HOURS. WE'VE
ALSO NOTICED THAT DIFFERENT
COUNTIES TREAT THINGS ARE TREAT
THESE KINDS OF SITUATIONS
DIFFERENTLY SO MAYBE YOU'RE
LUCKY IF YOU GET YOUR FIFTY ONE
FIFTY AND ONE COUNTY RATHER THAN
ANOTHER AND IT JUSTSIMPLY
SHOULDN'T BE THAT WAY PEOPLE
HAVE RIGHTS. AND THOSE RIGHTS
ARE PROTECTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION AND THE UNITED
STATES SUPREME COURT AND THE
LETTERMAN PATRICK SHORT ACT SO
WE SEE THIS AS AS A CLARIFYING
CHANGE. AND WE ALSO BELIEVE
THAT- BECAUSE THIS BILL CONTAINS
. PROVISIONS TO ADDRESS WHAT
HAPPENS IF IT'S IMPOSSIBLE AND
BEYOND TO FACILITIES CONTROL. TO
TRANSFER TO A COUNTY DESIGNATED
FACILITY CERTAIN DUE PROCESS
RIGHTS WILL ATTACH AT THAT POINT
WE THINK THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT
VERY REASONABLE APPROACH AND WE
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. SEEING
NONE- ANY FOLKS IN THE AUDIENCE
WHO- JUST TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION ONLY. THANK YOU MADAM
VICE CHAIR TIBETAN REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF AMERICAN
CALLED MERCY PHYSICIANS WE HAVE
A SUPPORT OF A MINUTE POSITION
WE APPRECIATE THE TIME WITH BOTH
AUTHORS CONSULTANTS IN THE FORTY
TO CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON.
MATTHEW GALLAGHER WITH COWBOYS
IS THE STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THING NO ONE ELSE ARE
WE CAN GO TO THE PHONE LINES
WITNESSES ON THE PHONE NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY. FOUR
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
BUTTON ZERO THAT COMMAND AGAIN
ONE MINUTE THEN ZERO. AND WE
HAVE NO COMMENTS COMING THROUGH
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU-
COMMENTS QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE WE DO HAVE A MOTION IN
THE SECOND. SEEING NONE MISTER
CHAIR WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
OFFERED THAT OPPORTUNITY FIRST
OF MR STONE AT. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THIS THIS
GOES FROM HERE TO JUDICIARY. IS
A GOOD EXAMPLE OF COMMITTEES
WORKING VERY WELL TOGETHER TO
SOLVE SIGNIFICANT HISTORICAL
PROBLEM FOR CALIFORNIA. I ASKED
WE ARE ABOUT. AND I WANT TO
THANK YOU I WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE FOR
THE COLLABORATION ON THIS SIDE
I'M NOT AWARE THAT THERE'S BEEN
COLLABORATION WITH THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE NOW HEALTH COMMITTEE
FOR A VERY VERY LONG TIME- SO I
I'M THANKFUL THAT WE HAVE THE
OPTION TO WORK TOGETHER- AND
THIS IS THIS IS A CLASSIC
EXAMPLE. OF HOW OUR INTERIM
HEARINGS LEAD TO LEGISLATION AND
HOPEFULLY WE CAN GET
FOUNDATIONAL DATA FOUNDATIONAL
INFORMATION BE ABLE TO RIGHT
SOME WRONGS- AND- MAKE THIS ACT
A MORE. FAIR MORE UNIFORMS- WERE
MEANINGFUL FOR THOSE WHO ARE
GOING TO BE SUBJECT TO IT- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- WE KNOW IT'S NOT
A PANACEA. BUT WE KNOW IT WILL
ENSURE THAT DUE PROCESS
PROTECTIONS FOR INVOLUNTARY.
DETENTIONS COMPLY WITH FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS INCREASED OVERSIGHT
AND ACCOUNTABILITY. TO ENHANCE
DATA COLLECTION. THIS IS THE
BEGINNING AND WE ASK FOR I'VE OF
. THANK YOU THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO JUDICIARY COMMITTEE MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WHAT. I WOULD AYE WALDRON AYE
WALDRON AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE ARAMBULA. REBEL
I BIGELOW. CORREO RIO AYE FLORA
MAIENSCHEIN MAYES. MCCARTY
MCCARTY HIGH IN THIS AREA. RIVAS
RIVAS AYE RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ
AYE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I KALRA
ALL RIGHT I. TEN TWO ZERO YOU
BILLS OUT THANK YOU- WILL MOVE
TO ITEM TWENTY THREE AB ONE
EIGHT SEVEN EIGHT MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT. ADDRESSES
AFFORDABILITY PROVIDING BY
PROVIDING FINANCIAL HELP TO
CONSUMERS PURCHASING HEALTH
COVERAGE THROUGH COVERED
CALIFONIA ALLOWS COVERED
CALIFORNIA TO OFFER PRODUCTS
WITH LOWER OUT OF POCKET COSTS
SPECIFICALLY ZERO DEDUCTIBLES
AND LOWER COST SHARING THESE
PRODUCTS WOULD BE AVAILABLE TO
CONSUMERS EARNING UP 26100% OF
THE FEDERAL POVERTY A POVERTY
LEVEL. AND WERE DEVELOPED
THROUGH COVER CALIFORNIA'S
MODELING OF DIFFERENT COST
SHARING OPTIONS THIS BILL ALIGNS
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY
BUDGET THAT STATES THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL WORK WITH
THE LEGISLATURE ON OPTIONS TO
FURTHER IMPROVE AFFORDABILITY
AND HEALTH CARE COVERAGE WITH ME
TODAY IS DIANA DOUGLAS WITH
HEALTH ACCESS CALIFORNIA AND
BIANCA BLOMQUIST THE SMALL
BUSINESS MAJORITY I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
DIANA DOUGLAS ON BEHALF OF
HEALTH ACCESS CALIFORNIA THE
STATEWIDE CONSUMER ADVOCACY
HEALTH CARE COALITION. THANKS TO
SIGNIFICANT PREMIUM ASSISTANCE
PROVIDED FIRST BY THE STATE AND
THEN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT MORE
CALIFORNIANS THAN EVER HAVE
ENROLLED IN OUR COVERED
CALIFORNIA MARKETPLACE. WE ARE
PLEASED TO BE HERE TO SPONSOR AB
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT WHICH
WILL DRAMATICALLY FURTHER REDUCE
THE BURDEN BY ADDRESSING COST
SHARING FOR COVERED CALIFORNIA
ENROLLEES. EVEN WITH COVERAGE
RISING DEDUCTIBLES AND COPAYS
KEEP CARE OUT OF REACH FOR MANY.
60% OF CALIFORNIANS REPORT
FEELING WORRIED ABOUT OUT OF
POCKET COSTS WHEN USING HEALTH
INSURANCE A GREATER PERCENTAGE
THAN THOSE WORRIED ABOUT COST OF
HOUSING UTILITIES OR GROCERIES.
THIS IS UNSURPRISING GIVEN
DEDUCTIBLES OFTEN AMOUNT TO
SEVERAL MONTHS WORTH OF WAGES. A
PERSON IN A STANDARD SILVER PLAN
MAKING JUST OVER TWO THOUSAND
PER MONTH MAY HAVE A DEDUCTIBLE
OF THIRTY SEVEN HUNDRED. AND
AMOUNT THAT WILL RISE TO FORTY
SEVEN HUNDRED BY NEXT YEAR.
THEY'LL BE PAYING FORTY FIVE
DOLLARS FOR A REGULAR DOCTOR
VISIT TO SEE A PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIAN. HIGH OUT OF POCKET
COSTS OF LEAD TO HALF OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS SKIPPING OR
DELAYING CARE THIS PAST YEAR. AB
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT WILL
LIMIT DEDUCTIBLES FOR COVERED
CALIFORNIA ENROLLEES AND SILVER
PLANS AND ALSO UPGRADE ALL
SILVER ENROLLEES INTO MORE
AFFORDABLE TEARS OF COST
SHARING. THE BILL ALSO EXTEND
CARSHARING HELP TO THOSE MIDDLE
INCOME CONSUMERS MAKING ABOUT
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND PER YEAR.
WE ARE OPTIMISTIC THAT FEDERAL
PREMIUM SUBSIDIES WILL BE
EXTENDED LATER THIS YEAR WHICH
GIVES US THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS COST SHARING. WE ALSO
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
RESOLVE ANY OPERATIONAL ISSUES
THAT MAY IMPACT TO THE SYSTEMS
WE AIM TO PROVIDE. WE ARE PROUD
TO SPONSOR AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. A GOOD AFTERNOON AND
THANKS TO THE CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE FOR GIVING
SMALL BUSINESS MAJORITY THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT.
I'M PARTICULARLY EXCITED TO
SUPPORT AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT IS THAT IMPROVES
AFFORDABILITY FOR TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF LOW AND MODERATE
INCOME ENTREPRENEURS AND SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS. THERE ARE OVER
FOUR MILLION SMALL BUSINESSES
THAT MAKE UP 99% OF TOTAL
BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA. MORE
THAN HALF OF ALL ACA ENROLLEES
NATIONWIDE ARE SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS SMALL BUSINESS EMPLOYEES
OR SELF EMPLOYED INDIVIDUALS.
RECENT FEDERAL ACTION TO MAKE
HEALTH CARE MORE AFFORDABLE IN
CALIFORNIA ONE SOON TODAY THE
STATE CAN TAKE ACTION TO REDUCE
OUT OF POCKET COSTS THAT ARE
HINDERING ENTREPRENEURSHIP IN
OUR STATE. THE NEED FOR
AFFORDABILITY AMONG CALIFORNIAN
ENTREPRENEURS IS GROWING.
KEEPING IN MIND THAT SEVEN POINT
TWO MILLION WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA DEPEND ON THE JOBS
PROVIDED BY SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS ACCORDING TO OUR RESEARCH
MORE THAN ONE IN THREE SMALL
BUSINESSES REPORT THAT IT'S BEEN
A CHALLENGE TO OBTAIN HEALTH
INSURANCE COVERAGE FOR
THEMSELVES AND THEIR EMPLOYEES
DURING THE PANDEMIC. 16% HAVE
REPORTED THEY'VE CONSIDERED
REDUCING HEALTH CARE COVERAGE IN
ORDER TO KEEP THEIR BUSINESSES
OPEN. ENTREPRENEURS OF COLOR
WERE MORE LIKELY TO INDICATE
MAKING THIS CHANGE. A STRONG
AFFORDABLE MARKET PLACE IS
ESSENTIAL FOR THE FUTURE OF
CALIFORNIA ENTREPRENEURS AB
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT IS
ESSENTIAL FOR OUR. OVER THE CUT
OFF FOR HEALTH CARE SUBSIDIES
WHICH WAS ABOUT FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS. PLUS OUR RESEARCH SHOWS
THAT 70% OF THOSE POLLED SUPPORT
EXPANDING COST SHARING SUBSIDIES
TO INDIVIDUALS WHO MAKE UP
26100% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL IN CALIFORNIA. FOR THE
PAST TWO YEARS BECAUSE OF
FEDERAL TAX CREDITS MORE SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO ACCESS AFFORDABLE HEALTH
CARE. CALIFORNIA MUST BEGIN TO
ADDRESS ESCALATING COST SHARING
AS AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT
DOES. AND CALIFORNIA SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE NOT OUT OF THE
WOODS YET WE MUST ACT TO SUSTAIN
A STRONG RECOVERY FROM THE
PANDEMIC. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE OF
ANYBODY IN THE AUDIENCE WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT SUPPORT
OR OPPOSE NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION ONLY THANK YOU THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR BRANDON MARCH
WITH THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. MANAGER
NICK LEASES WITH A CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH PLANS
WHICH HAVE A SUPPORT IF AMENDED
POSITION ON THE BILL WITH YOUR
INDULGENCE WE TOOK PART IN THE
WORKGROUP PROCESS OVER THE
INTERIM ON THIS ISSUE. WE
SUPPORT THE USE OF STATE AND
FEDERAL FUNDS TO LOWER COSTS FOR
MEMBERS AT COVER CALIFORNIA BUT
SOME OF THE SAME OPERATIONAL
TIMING CONCERNS THAT WE REYES ON
THE PRIOR EXCHANGE BILL APPLY TO
THIS BILL AS WELL AND SO WE LOOK
FOR FURTHER CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE AUTHOR AND THE SUPPORTERS
TRY IRON THOSE OUT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. DEMAND REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. JUST COME ROUND OF THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. HELLO CHAIR
MEMBERS JENNISON ALLEY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU. HUD
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES IF
THERE'S WITNESSES ON THE PHONE
NAME ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY
PLEASE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
FOR COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO A COMMAND AGAIN ONE
ZERO. AND FIRST WE'LL GO TO LINE
TWO NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BUT AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS KNOW ATWATER MALL WITH
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT THANK YOU. AN OUTLINE IT
TO TWENTY. CASH SHORT ON BEHALF
OF THE ALLIANCE OF CATHOLIC
HEALTH CARE IN SUPPORT. LINE
TWENTY ONE. REBECA GONZALEZ
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. LINE. TWO TWENTY ONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBER
STATE BORDERS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA AGENTS AND HEALTH
INSURANCE PROFESSIONALS PROUD
STAKEHOLDER AND THE REFERENCE
WORKING GROUP IN SUPPORT. LINE
TO TWENTY TWO. MADAM CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SEXUAL
CONSUELO WITH ACCENTS
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE AND WE'RE
IMPORTANT EIGHTY EIGHTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT THANK YOU. IN LINE NO ONE
AT NINETY NINE. GOOD AFTERNOON
WINDOW A WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT. AND
WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU I WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
THERE IS A MOTION IN THE SECOND
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE WITH THE CHAIR IS
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. SO WE DO HAVE A
MOTION TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL WHAT I WHAT AYE WALDRON AYE
WALDRON AYE AGUIAR-CURRY. I
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE BIGELOW.
CORREO RIO AYE FLORA.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MAYES MCCARTY MCCARTY I THIS
AREA. RIVAS RIVAS I RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO HI
SANTIAGO AYE KALRA AWRY. LEBANON. ZERO THE BILL IS OUT WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR OTHERS
THAT AREN'T THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MR SANTIAGO YOU HAVE TWO
BILLS BEFORE US FOR THE FIRST
ONE IS AB NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY SIR YEAH
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
SELECTED EXCEPT THE COMMITTEE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS AND THANK
YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR THE HARD
WORK. AB AS AMENDED AB NINETEEN
EIGHTY TWO WILL ENSURE
CONTINUITY OF CARE FOR A DENTAL
PATIENT BY ADDING DENTAL PLANS-
TO WHAT THIS COMMITTEES ALREADY
WORKED ON THE PAST WHICH WAS AB-
FORTY SEVEN. I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- HEARING THAT I WILL MAKE
IT SIMPLE AND- NOW HANDED OVER
TO JUST COME AROUND WHO IS WITH
HE DENTALS OF CALIFORNIANS
ASSOCIATION AS WELL THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS
JUSTIN RANDALL CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION HERE TODAY AS THE
SPONSORS OF AB NINETEEN EIGHTY
TWO. LAST YEAR GOVERNOR SOME
FINE AB FOR FIVE SEVEN OR TO
STOP WHICH THE PROTECTION OF
PATIENT CHOICE IN TELEHEALTH
PROVIDER ACT WHICH REQUIRED
HEALTH INSURERS OR- PLANS ARE
SURE TO COMPLY WITH SPECIFIED
NOTICING CONTENT REQUIREMENTS IF
THE PLANNER ENSURE. OFFERED
SERVICES VIA A THIRD PARTY
TELEHEALTH PROVIDER WELL AB FOUR
FIVE SEVEN EXCLUDED DENTAL PLANS
WE HAVE SEEN EXAMPLES OF DENTAL
PLAN STEERING PATIENTS TOWARDS
THESE M. AT THIRD PARTY
TELEHEALTH VISITS IN LIEU OF IN
PERSON SERVICES. HOW HOW CAN BE
A USEFUL TOOL INDUSTRY TO TRIAGE
A PATIENT WHO IS EXPERIENCING
ANY PAIN OR DISCOMFORT BUT
ALMOST NO DENTAL CARE CAN
PEOPLE. CAN BE PROVIDED
VIRTUALLY IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
ANY REAL KARAPETIAN WE NEED TO
SEE THE DENTIST IN PERSON
ADDITIONALLY BECAUSE THE DILEMMA
THE LIMITATION THERE ON DENTAL
COVERAGE THESE TRIAGE
APPOINTMENTS CAN USE UP A
PATIENT'S- THE VISIT FREQUENCY
LIMITATIONS THAT ANNUAL MAXIMUM.
ONCE THE PATIENT IS EVENTUALLY
REFERRED TO AN IN PERSON
DENTISTRY TO RECEIVE THE CARE
THEY NEED. AB NINETEEN EIGHTY TO
REMOVE THE DENTAL EXEMPTION FROM
ACROSS FROM STATUE IN OR
DIRECTED DENTAL PLANS TO PROVIDE
A DISCLOSURE STATEMENT TO
PATIENTS EXPLAINED THE IMPACT OF
THIRD PARTY TELEHEALTH. VISITS
ON THE PATIENTS BENEFIT
LIMITATIONS THIS BILL WOULD ALSO
REQUIRE THE DENTAL PLAN TO
REPORT. OTHER PROVIDERS THEY
CONTRACT WITH ALONG WITH THE
NUMBER AND TYPES OF DENTAL
SERVICES ARE PROVIDED VIA
TELEHEALTH THE SUPPORTING WILL
HELP TRACK THE GROWTH IN
UTILIZATION OF TELEHEALTH IN
INDUSTRY TO BETTER ENABLE
PATIENT PROTECTION DOWN THE
LINE. AB NINETEEN EIGHTY TO
BUILD UPON AB FOUR FIVE SEVEN
AND IF NECESSARY TO ENSURE THAT
PATIENTS HAVE THE ABILITY TO
MAKE AN INFIRM INFORM DCISION
HOW TO ACCESS THEIR DENTAL CARE
AS THEY DO FOR THE MEDICAL CARE.
THE CLOTHES I LIKE TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH US ON
AMENDMENTS AND THE DENTAL PLANS
FOR THE OPEN DIALOGUE AND
COMMITMENT TO MAKING SURE THAT
THIS POLICY WORKS THE WAY THAT
WE INTENDED TO. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR IDOL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
IS THERE OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. IN NINE ANYBODY IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION. WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK FROM THE AUDIENCE JUST
YOUR NAME POSITION ORGANIZATION
. SEE NO ONE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES MISTER OPERATOR-
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION- NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL ONLY PLEASE. THE MASTER
CARE FOR COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO THAT COMMAND AGAIN.
ONE SEVEN ZERO.
AND WE DO HAVE SOMEONE KEEPING
UP JUST ONE MOMENT PLEASE WHILE
WE GIVE THEM THEIR LINE NUMBER.
THANK YOU.
IN A LINE TO TWENTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AMATEUR THIS IS NOT
BACK REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF DENTAL PLANS WELL
WE DO HAVE CONCERNS- WITH THE
BILL AND FRANKLY VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
AGREEMENT TO TAKE SOME
AMENDMENTS AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO SEEING THOSE AND- CAUTIOUSLY
OPTIMISTIC. THAT WE'LL BE ABLE
TO RESOLVE THIS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME
GREAT THANK YOU SO MUCH I BRING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
IN AND WE DO HAVE A MOTION FROM
MISS WALDRON SECOND BY DOCTOR
REGULAR THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS WHICH
LOOK AT THE HAS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE CHAIR.
WE LIKE TO CLOSE MISTER SANTIAGO
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIR MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. I WOULD. I
WOULD I WALDRON. WALDRON AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE BIGELOW.
RIO THE- I FLORA FLORA I
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MAYES MAYES NOT VOTING. MCCARTY
MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN. RIVAS
RIVAS AYE RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ
AYE SANTIAGO AYE SANTIAGO AYE
KALRA. ALL RIGHT I. ZERO IT HAS
TWELVE VOTES THE BILL WILL MOVE
ON I WILL BE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
OTHER STAT ON. AB TWENTY ONE
TWENTY SEVEN IS ON CONSENT SO
WE'RE GONNA LEAVE THAT ONE
THERE- IF IT'S ALREADY PASSED ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR SO IT'S
DEFINITELY STAY THERE- AT. THE
HEIGHT OF NUMBER TWENTY TWO AB
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY ONE WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY SIR I THINK MISTER
FOR THOUGHT LIKE TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AND YOUR
HARD WORK TO MAKE THIS A BETTER
BILL ALSO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE'RE PROUD TO PRESENT AB.
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY ONE WHICH
REALLY BUILT ON THE WORK THAT
WE'VE ALREADY DONE THE COMMITTEE
HAS HELPED US TO- BUT IT'S A
CREATURE- FROM MY BOOK BUT IF
THE COMMUTER FROM FRESNO AND
YOURSELF TO HELP US TO PUT. IT A
BILL LAST YEAR TO GET AND THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL THAT ALLOWED US
TO HAVE THIRTEEN. MILLION
DOLLARS TO ESTABLISH THE FIRST
TRANSGENDER TRANSGENDER WELLNESS
AND EQUITY FUND- IT'S A BIT THIS
YEAR WE COME BACK TO. CHANGE THE
NAME OF THE FUND TO BE MORE APT
A PROBABLY A REPRESENT OF THE
WORK THAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO TO
THE TGI WELLNESS IN EQUITY FUND.
AS WELL AS ESTABLISH AN ADVISORY
COMMITTEE. FOR THIS MEANINGFUL
WORKS OF THE DOLLARS SPENT AND
THE WAY THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO HAVE
THE IMPACT THAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED
TO. SO I WANT TO THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE AND
WOOD HANDED OVER. A TO OUR
WITNESS- BAMBI SO SEVERAL WITH
THE TRANS LATINA COALITION THANK
YOU. A I'M THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE-
GREETINGS- OUR CHAIR AND-
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE- THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY ONCE
AGAIN TO BE HERE TODAY- MY NAME
IS BAMBI SENSIBLE AND I AM THE
PRESIDENT AND THE CEO OF THE
TRANSCRIPT NOW COALITION. AND
ALSO A MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA-
TGI ALLY- POLICY ALLIANCE WHICH
IS A STATE WIDE COALITION OF
FRANCE LED TGI LEAD GROUPS AND
ORGANIZATIONS- I AM HERE TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY ONE WELL
WHICH WILL RENAME THE
TRANSGENDER ONENESS IN EQUITY
FUND TO THE TGI WELLNESS AND
EQUITY FUND. AND IT WILL CREATE
AN ADVISORY COMMITTEE FOR THE
FIND US ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO
MENTION- WE AS A COMMUNITY
UNDERSTANDS. THE IMPORTANCE OF
INCLUSIVITY. RENAMING THE FRONT
OF THE TGA WELLNESS AND EQUITY
FUND IS NECESSARY. THE RECOGNIZE
OTHER MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY.
LIKE PEOPLE WHO ARE GENDER
NONCONFORMING UNDER EXPENSIVE AN
INTERSEX PEOPLE. THANK TENTH OF
THIS LEGISLATION IT SAID THAT.
THE FINE WILL SERVE ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITY AND NOT JUST PEOPLE
WHO IDENTIFY AS TRANSGENDER. WE
MUST INCLUDE ALL TJ PEOPLE IN
POLITICAL AND SOCIAL DISCOURSE.
IT ALSO PROVIDES- ANYTHING FORM
FOR ALL OF OUR COMMUNITY TO
CREATE AN ADVISORY COMMITTEE THE
TGI WELLNESS AND EQUITY FIND AT
THE WILL NOT ONLY PROVIDE
DISABILITY FOR MEMBERS OF MY
COMMUNITY. BUT THIS ADVISORY
GROUP WILL ALSO BE INTEGRAL IN
PROVIDING ADVICE MEANT TO THE
FIND AND PROVIDE MEANINGFUL
INPUT. ON WHERE AND HOW THE
FUNDS ARE DISTRIBUTED. I AM A
FIFTY TWO YEAR OLD TRANS WOMEN
WHO HAVE INDOOR MANY HORRIBLE
EXPERIENCES IN MY LIFE BUT I AM
ALSO A POWER SURVIVOR. OF MY
EXPERIENCES I HONESTLY NEVER
THOUGHT THAT I COULD SEE- THEY'D
LIKE THIS. AS WE KNOW OTHER
STATES ARE ATTACKING AND
CRIMINALIZING TJ PEOPLE. AND I
AM GRATEFUL THAT WE ASK THE
STATE. ARE MAKING PROGRESS AND
SETTING PRECEDENTS FOR THOSE
OTHER STATES TO FOLLOW. WE KNOW.
WE NOW HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PASS THIS INCLUSIVE LEGISLATION
IN THIS UP TO ALL OF US TO
ENSURE THAT ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY ONE BECOMES A
REALITY FOR ALL OF TJ PEOPLE. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT YOU
SUPPORT THE PASSAGE OF AB TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY ONE I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE WITH ALL
OF YOU AND I HUMBLY REQUEST A
NAY VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. C. NINE ANYONE IN THE IN
THE AUDIENCE WAS JUST EXPRESS
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION JUST YOUR
NAME POSITION ON THE BILL AN
ORGANIZATION YOU REPRESENT ONE.
SEEING NONE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES WITH THE SAME REQUEST MR.
OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE
LINES. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
FOR COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO THAT COMMAND AGAIN ONE THEN
ZERO. IN FIRST WE WILL GO TO
LINE ONE AT NINETY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING LINDA WAY
WITH WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY PLEASED TO SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
. LINE. TO TWENTY TWO. THANK YOU
SCHERING COMMITTEE MEMBERS
QUIRK-SILVA FELLOW BAD ACCESS
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE AND WE ARE
IN FULL SUPPORT OF AB T. FIVE
TWO ONE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE TWENTY
ONE. GOOD EVENING REBEKAH
GONZALES WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
LINE A ONE EIGHTY EIGHT. I CAN'T
PAY MY MATTER ON BEHALF OF THE
ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION AND DRAMA
REPORT THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. LINE. TO TWENTY FOUR.
NINE TO TWENTY FOUR YEAR MIKE IS
OPEN. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS RANDY
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE AIDS
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WHY IN A ONE FORTY. HI
MY NAME IS ANGELICA CARILLO FROM
THE TRANSACTED OUT COALITION AND
THE ANTI VIOLENCE VIOLENCE
PREVENTION CASE MANAGER AND I AM
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
LINE. ONE THIRTY SEVEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS ASE ANAYA AND I'M WITH
THE TROUT BUT THEN THE COALITION
AND I AM STRONG SUPPORT A. B.
TWENTY ONE TWENTY. TWO PERFECT
THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT
THIS TIME OKAY THANK YOU BRING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THIS CARILLO. THE
SERVER AWAY THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I JUST I WANT TO
COMMEND THE AUTHOR FOR HIS
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE- WE SEE THIS YOU
KNOW QUITE A BIT AND THE WORK
THAT WE DID TOGETHER I WAS PROUD
TO BE A CO AUTHOR IN YOUR
REQUEST LAST YEAR AND IF I'M NOT
ALREADY WOULD LOVE TO JOIN YOU
IN AS WELL. AND I
JUST WANT TO GIVE BAMBI OUR
WITNESS TESTIMONY OUR OUR
DEEPEST GRATITUDE AND
APPRECIATION WE SEE YOU WE LOVE
YOU I'M SO GLAD THAT YOU'RE HERE
AT THE NEW BUILDING THE SWING
SPACE BUT IT'S STILL THE
PEOPLE'S HOUSE AND THE VOICE
THAT YOU BRING TO THE TABLE AS A
AS A TRANS WOMAN AS IN THE WORK
THAT YOU DO WITH THE TRANSIT THE
A COALITION. NOT ONLY FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN OUR OWN
COMMUNITY SINCE YOU KNOW YOU
LIVE LIKE IN LOS ANGELES AND OUR
CONSTITUENT AND BUT THE WORK
THAT YOU DO NATIONWIDE THE WORK
THAT YOU'VE DONE FOR SEVERAL
YEARS THE FACT THAT YOUR STORY
HELPED THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
CHANGE POLICIES FOR THE LGBTQ
TRANS COMMUNITY I THINK THAT'S
AN IMPORTANT ENDEAVOR AND THE
FACT THAT YOU'VE YOU'VE DONE IT
ALL ON YOUR OWN WITH THE HELP OF
THE COMMUNITY AS WELL BUT- ONE
VOICE. AND CHANGE. THE ENTIRE
CONVERSATION AND YOU'VE DONE
THAT FOR MANY YEARS AND FOR
THAT. I APPLAUD YOU AND I THINK
YOU AND I SEE YOU AND- I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT YOU'RE HERE
THAT WE ARE NOW MOVING
LEGISLATION AND POLICY AND- AND
BUDGET ALLOCATIONS. ARE IN A
MUCH NEEDED SPACE FOR THE TRANS
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR WORK. THANK YOU MYSTERY
OF THAT SOUNDS DISTINCTLY LIKE A
MOTION. MOVE THE BILL OKAY.
SECOND BY MISTER KALRA- THE BILL
DOES ENJOY A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS I TOO
WANTTO COMMEND YOU FOR YOUR
WORK IN THIS SPACE AND YOUR
TIRELESS WORK IN THE SPACE- IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT WORK I REALLY
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE DOING-
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- AND MY
COLLEAGUES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND- MY COLLEAGUE FROM PRESIDENT
OTHERS HERE WHO HELPED US WIN
THIS WITH ONLY AN IDEA. THE
MISSILES HAD BROUGHT UP TO US
AND NW IT'S A REALITY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR HELPING US TO
PUT THAT TOGETHER CONTINUE TO
PUSH. AND NOW WE HAVE THE FIRST
EVER FUND IN THE STATE THE DRESS
IS VERY IMPORTANT YOU ARE
SPECIALLY AFTER MODEL. THANK YOU
MR SANTIAGO- SO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS A SUCH AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. AMOUNT SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WHAT I
WOULD I'D WALDRON. WALDRON NOT
VOTING AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY
AYE ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA AYE
BIGELOW. MARIA I FLORA FLORIDA
VOTING MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
AYE MAYES MAYES AYE MCCARTY
MCCARTY I IN THIS AREA. RIVAS
RIVAS AYE RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ
AYE SANTIAGO AYE SANTIAGO AYE
KALRA ALL RIGHT I. LIVENESS ZERO
ZERO YOUR BILL IS OUT WILL BE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR OTHERS THAT ON
THANK YOU. YOUR WITNESS AS WELL
THANK YOU. OKAY WE WILL GO TO
THE TOP OF THE ORDER HERE AND
WE'LL GO THROUGH THE BILLS AND-
MISTERS ERIN WILL JOIN US SOON.
OF AS THE ONLY ONE MISSING RIGHT
NOW. OF WILL GO SERVICE ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE LIFT THE
CALL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BUT WE NEED A MOTION NEVER MIND
WE NEED A MOTION FIRST- A MOTION
BY MISTER- MAIENSCHEIN SECOND BY
MR MCCARTY- MOTIONS DO PASSES A
MINUTE TO APPROPRIATIONS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WHAT I WOULD AYE WALDRON WALDRON
AYE AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY
AYE ARAMBULA RAMBLE I BIGELOW.
RIO RIO AYE FLORA LEARN A VOTING
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MAYES MAYES AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY
AYE NAZARIAN. RIVAS RIVAS AYE
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I COVER ALL RIGHT HI.
ZERO THAT'S TWELVE ZERO A NUMBER
TO AB SIXTEEN SIXTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BARRICADE HAND
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE IN CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. LARA LARA NO
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MAYES MAYES NOT VOTING MCCARTY
MCCARTY AYE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I. LEVIN TO LEVEL TWO WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBER ITEM NUMBER THREE AB
TWENTY EIGHTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BARRICADE HAND
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS BIGELOW. LARA
LARA NO MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
I MAYES MAYES NOT VOTING. ELEVEN
ONE ELEVEN ONE LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR THE MEMBERS TO PASS ON-
TWO OF ADD ON HOPEFULLY. OKAY IT
IN A SECOND. THE META MISSED
SOMETHING HERE I CAN MATH I MISS
ONTARIO SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO I
TWELVE TO TWELVE TO ONE OF THE
ONE THEN SO OKAY AB SEVENTEEN OH
FOUR IS IN SEARCH OF A MOTION.
SECOND MOTION BY DOCTOR REGULAR
SECOND BY MR SANTIAGO THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS. A
MATTER OF SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. WHAT I WOULD AYE
WALDRON. WALDRON AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE BIGELOW.
RIO RIO AYE FLORA FLORA I
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MAYES MAYES AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY
I IN HIS AREA. RIVAS RIVAS AYE
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE KALRA KALRA HI.
THIRTEEN ZERO THIRTEEN ZERO ZERO
WITH THE ROLE OPEN FOR OTHERS TO
ADD ON ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB
EIGHTEEN NINETY TWO BY MISTER
FOR IN SEARCH OF A MOTION.
MOTION BY MISS WALDRON SECOND BY
DR RAM DEALER THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSES A MINUTE TO
APPROPRIATIONS MINUTES SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WHAT I
WOULD AYE WALDRON. WALDRON AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE BIGELOW.
CORREO. I LARA. LARA AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MAYES MAYES AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY
I IN THIS AREA. RIVAS RIVAS AYE
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I KALRA R. I. THIRTEEN
ZERO HOW BY THE SKIN OF YOUR
TEETH MISTER FLORA. THE ITEM
NUMBER SIX A. B. C. NINETEEN
TWENTY NINE BY MR GABRIEL- IN
SEARCH OF A MOTION. MOTION BY
MISS- AGUIAR-CURRY SECOND BY
MISS REAVIS- I'D MET SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL OF THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. WOOD I WOULD I
WALDRON WALDRON AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA AYE BIGELOW RIO RIO
I'VE LEARNED. LARA NOT VOTING
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I'M A
MAYES. MAYES AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I IN THIS AREA. RIVAS
RIVERSIDE RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ
AYE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I KALRA
OUR I. WELL ZERO ZERO- THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WHICH IS ITEMS
NUMBER. SEVEN NINE ELEVEN
FOURTEEN AND TWENTY ONE A SECTOR
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ARAMBULA. CONSENT
CALENDAR. ARAMBULA AYE BIGELOW
LARA. LARA I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MAYES MAYES I
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I. FOURTEEN
ZERO FOURTEEN ZERO. HE'S ON A
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT- AB TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FIVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA- THIS IS
IN SEARCH OF A OF A MOTION AS
WELL. MOTION BY MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY SECOND FIVE- THIS
RIVAS. THAT SECRETARY THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. WHAT I WOULD AYE WALDRON.
WILDER NO AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA AYE BIGELOW. CORREO I
FLORA FLORA NO MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MAYES MAYES
NONVOTING MCCARTY MCCARTY I.
THIS AREA NAZARIAN AYE RIVAS
RIVAS AYE RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ
AYE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I KALRA.
ALL RIGHT I. ELEVEN A TWO LEVEL
TWO ITEM NUMBER TWELVE- AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN IN SEARCH
OF A MOTION. MOTION BY MISS
RIVAS SECOND BY MISTER NAZARIAN
OB MOTION IS DUE PASSED A PUBLIC
SAFETY OF SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL WHAT I WOULD AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON NOT VOTING AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY NOT VOTING ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA AYE BIGELOW RIO.
CARRILLO AYE FLORA. LARA NOT
VOTING MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
AYE MAYES. MAYES NOT VOTING
MCCARTY MCCARTY I IN THIS AREA.
A VERY AND I RIVAS RIVAS AYE
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I KALRA. R. I. IN THIS
ERA OF THE HAS TEN TEN TEN
VOTERS OUT ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN
AB TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY THREE BY
MR LACKEY IN SEARCH OF A MOTION
. MOTION BY MISS WALDRON A
SECOND BY MISS- MISS REAVIS THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED TO
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE A SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. WHAT I
WOULD AYE WALDRON. WALDRON I
AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY NOT
VOTING ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA I
BIGELOW. REAL REAL AYE FLORA
FLORA I MAIENCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
AYE MAYES MAYES AYE MCCARTY
MCCARTY I IN THIS AREA THE VERY
AND I RIVAS RIVERSIDE RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
I KALRA. AWRY. THIRTEEN ZERO
THIRTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN AB TWENTY THIRTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER O'DONNELL- THIS
IS ALSO IN SEARCH OF A MOTION.
IT WASN'T A WE GOT A MOTION THAT
RIGHT WE HAD NEVER MIND WE JUST
NEED TO LET THE CALL ON AT I WAS
SO USED TO ASKING FOR MOTIONS I
JUST GOT CARRIED AWAY. WITH IT
THE CALL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE
BIGELOW. LARA LAURA HI
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MAYES MAYES AYE MCCARTY. MCCARTY
I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I ALL RIGHT
OUR AYE FOURTEEN ZERO FOURTEEN
ZERO ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN AB
SIXTEEN NINETY FIVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THIS RIVAS- PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA NOT VOTING
BIGELOW. LARA LARA NO
MAIENSCHEIN. MAIENSCHEIN I MAYES. MAYES NOT VOTING. SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I SENATE. TO TEN TO SO
ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN- LEAVE IN
SEARCH OF A MOTION BY MISTER
RODRIGUEZ AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY.
US MR SOSSION BY MR SANTIAGO.
AND THE SECOND BY A DOCTOR
REGULAR I'M- SHELLSHOCKED
APPEAR- OF THE CITY AMERITECH
TRIP PLEASE OF THE MEASURE
MOTIONS TO PASS TO JUDICIARY
PLEASE CALL THE- ALL THE ROLE
CULTURAL. WHAT I WOULD AYE
WALDRON. WALDRON AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
ARAMBULA BRAMBILLA AYE BIGELOW.
CORREO RIO AYE FLORA. LARA AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MAYES. THE TWENTY TO SIXTY BY MR
RODRIGUEZ I'D NEVER. EIGHTEEN
MAYES AYE MCCARTY. NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN I RIVAS RIVAS AYE
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE KALRA ALL RIGHT I.
THIRTEEN ZERO. THIRTEEN ZERO
THANK YOU ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN
AB TWENTY SIX SIXTY SIX BY
MISTER SALAS PLEASE LIFT THE CAR
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE UP TO
MEMBERS ARE WHAT I WOULD AYE
ARAMBULA BRAMBILLA I BIGELOW.
LARA LAURA HI MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MAYES. MAYES I
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO HI FOURTEEN
ZERO FOURTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY BY MR SANTIAGO NOT AB
NINETEEN EIGHTY TO PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BIGELOW NAZARIAN. THE
SYRIAN I. THIRTEEN ZERO THIRTEEN
ZERO ITEM NUMBE TWENTY TWO AB
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY ONE BY MR
LINIMENT WHAT PAYING ON. YEAH IT
IS THIRTEEN. NO I HAVE IN THIS
BILL MR MAYS ON ON THAT BILL
WERE YOU VOTE NOT VOTING OR
VOTING NO. WE HAVE USE NOT
VOTING. ON A. B. NINETEEN EIGHTY
TWO MR SANTIAGO. THE TELL. OKAY
I JUST WANNA CLARIFY THANK YOU.
OKAY I'M I'M NOT SO SURE ABOUT
YOUR STAFFING CAPACITY. THERE
MISTER FLORA BUT- WELL YOU
DIDN'T YOU DID THAT ABSOLUTELY.
HEY I THINK HE MAY OWE YOU
SOMETHING FOR THAT BUT- ANYWAY-
I'D HAVE HER TWENTY TWO AB
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY ONE- PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS BIGELOW. NAZARIAN
NAZARIAN I. THIRTEEN ZERO THANK
YOU I DON'T VER TWENTY THREE AB
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS BIGELOW LARA. LARA NOT
VOTING MAYES MAYES I NAZARIAN
NAZARIAN HI. THIRTEEN ZERO
THIRTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
FOUR AB TWENTY TWO SEVENTY FIVE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOULD PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS BIGELOW. LARA OR IN A
VOTING MAIENSCHEIN. MAIENSCHEIN
AYE MAYES MAYES I NAZARIAN. THE
SYRIAN I THIRTEEN ZERO THIRTEEN
ZERO AND THE FINAL ITEM NUMBER.
BAD STAFF WORK IS AT RISK. AB
TWENTY TWO SEVENTY FIVE MAYES
NOT VOTING. WELL ZERO TWELVE
ZERO SO ITEM NUMBER TWENTY FIVE
AT A TWENTY FIVE AB TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY BY SOME REMEMBER WHAT IS
LOOKING FOR A MOTION. THOUGH
MOST BY DOCTOR REGULUS SECOND BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBEN RIVAS. LOW
BLOOD SUGAR HERE M. UP MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
TO PASS YOUR PREPARATIONS WHAT I
WHAT I WALDRON. WALDRON NO
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
ARAMBULA BRAMBILLA I'D BIGELOW.
A REAL REAL AYE FLORA OR NOT
VOTING MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
AYE MAYES. YES IS HE. I MAY NOT
VOTING MCCARTY. MAYES FLOOR
WHATEVER YOU KNOW. THIS AREA.
THIS AREA I RIVAS RIVAS AYE
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I KALRA. WITH.
NINE ONE NINE ONE OKAY. BUT IT'S
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY TWO. ON ONE
OF MY BILLS WELL HANG ON JUST A
SECOND WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE
WE RAN OUT OF FINGERS ON THE
LAST ONES WERE TRYING TO CARRY.
IT IS TWELVE. TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY ONE IS TWELVE ZERO. ZERO
ZERO SO OKAY- OKAY WE'LL DO YOUR
VOTE CHANGE MISTER MISTER FOR
AND THEN WE HAVE WE HAVE GOT TO. HE SAID AGAIN PLEASE. FOT
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT YET
AB TWENTY TWO SEVENTY FIVE LARA
NOT VOTING T<c.cyan>. AND THAT'S</c>
THIRTEEN THE ZERO THIRTEEN ZERO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY WE'LL
GO TO THE TOP OF THE ORDER NOW
AND- I REMEMBER ONE AB EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY. PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE AND
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BIGELOW
NAZARIAN NAZARIAN AYE THIRTEEN
ZERO THIRTEEN ZERO THANK YOU
ITEM NUMBER TWO- PLEASE OPEN A
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS AB
SIXTEEN SIXTY SIX BIGELOW. IF IT
PHILLIP INTO THAT ITEM NUMBER
THREE AB TWENTY EIGHTY NINE. R.
K. HAND. HELLO JUST BIGELOW OKAY
WELL ONE THAT NUMBER FOUR AB
SEVENTEEN OH FOUR PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
BIGELOW NAZARIAN NAZARIAN AYE
FOURTEEN ZERO FOURTEEN ZERO ITEM
NUMBER FIVE AB EIGHTEEN NINETY
TWO MISTER FLORA PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BIGELOW NAZARIAN. THIS AREA AND
I FOURTEEN ZERO ZERO AND FINALLY
ABC NINETEEN TWENTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GABRIEL PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS BIGELOW. NAZARIAN THIS
AREA NINE THIRTEEN ZERO RIGHT
THANK YOU DID YOU MISS SOMETHING
WE DO WE MISS WHEN A NEW. A
SERVICE FOR THE CONSECUTIVE.
YEAH YEAH. YET LAST MINUTE.
I DON'T KNOW. THERE A. RIVER
NINETEEN THEY ARE WILL DOUBLE
CHECK HERE THIS. YEAH WE GOTCHA
. GOOD THING VERY MUCH OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH EVERYONE
THAT WITH THAT WE WILL CLOSE THE
ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEE A
COMMITTEE HEARING FOR THE DAY
THANK YOU. VILLAGER.